want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you two you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
ultimate motivation from david goggins
enjoy
for several years i gave myself a way
out
when you were three hundred dollars now
i was 300 pounds and i was only up till
i was 24 years old
i would climb a mountain i fall back
down i start climbing i fall back down
for the first 24 years of my life i went
to my first tail week my second hell
week and then my third whole week came
in seal training
and the co captain bowen looked at me
i'm on crutches i'm all jacked up he
says hey
this is your last time you're gonna go
through buds
this is it
i had several stress fractures
i had double pneumonia i was jacked up
and he gave me a few months to heal he
said this your last time going through i
shouldn't even let you go back through
wow
i started navy seal training with stress
fractures
stress fractures
that's hard to finish stress fractures
starting the hardest training argument
in the world with stress fractures
and this is when i started to not put a
cap on the body if the mind is there
every morning i wake up at 3 30 morning
4 o'clock in the morning go to my dive
cage
go in there before anybody saw me i'd
get duct tape and i would tape from my
forefoot
all the way up to the middle of my calf
and i would put two black socks on
and so i ran not using the pivot oh my
gosh and i ran my hip flexors so for the
first 45 minutes to an hour
i was in absolute excruciating pain
but what motivated me
through that whole process
was the fact that
this kid
came from that i'm in the hardest
training in the world
in the worst shape of my entire life
what if i can graduate amongst these
studs wow
all these guys around me are studs
they're stallions they're gladiators in
my class they're all healthy most of
them they're not broken like this they
may have some you know everybody's sick
going down training but if i can
graduate
it would change everything for me if i
can start the hardest chain in the world
broken
and graduate
so my mind fed off of that
you are now
from the weakest man you are now the
hardest man to ever live if you can do
this
if you can do this
life is one big mind game yeah and
you're playing it with yourself
is it true i don't care
it got me through the hardest training
starting out broken
when most people quit
i just started wow
and when you take that mindset and you
learn to flip that around
that's what made me powerful
and my body followed
and three months later
my stress fractures were healed by
running on them do you like suffering or
do you just
deal with suffering
real answer real answer yeah
i like to see
real answer i like to get a bunch of men
together okay
men
that are the hardest of the heart
and i want to be with these men
and i want to see them suffer
because i'm suffering right along with
you but i want to see me get through it
i want to see what you're made of
i want to see like almost like
the coliseum
in rome
go to the coliseum
and the only way to see who the better
is is to suffer you can't do it by
writing a paper
so let's go
because why what i found out through my
life
was i thought of myself as some weak
little kid
and what i found out and the only
message i want to get across to people
is
once you change
one thing
your mindset
you can attack everything and i find it
fascinating i'm fascinated
because i'll be in these moments i put
these guys on some pedestal yeah which
people do with you they do with me and
they shouldn't
and i was this guy who was a piece of
look at this oh my god how are you guys
it's amazing but once i worked my way up
there
i said my god man we can all compete
let's go
so
do i like suffering i like suffering in
the way
that is
competitive
that brings out the absolute best in me
and everybody else
so like i want to see a man be defeated
i want to see a man get broken
and say
i love these men
these men i love but there's very few of
them
there's very few of them and there's
very few that are willing to go there
more than once
i get a lot of questions
people asking me for help
so i asked them
will be done to help yourself
most of them say
i've been working hard
i'm all about being your own hero
but i'm not about kissing your ass
in life a lot of us believe
that we're working much harder than we
actually are
we think if we got up early for four
days
we've earned something
you gotta drop your entitled mindset
it's dead weight
we believe you work harder than we
actually have
trust me most of us have it
the one thing in life you gotta realize
is this
learn to help yourself
don't count other people
to help you
also if you wanna have more self belief
and self
i've designed a special free program to
help you get it where i send you a video
every day for
254 days the research says it can take
up to 254 days for you to build a new
habit and this program will help you get
it once again it's free and the link to
join is in the description below you
will never learn from people if we
always tap dance around the truth
everything i didn't want to do
is what got me to where i'm at today
what if i can become someone that no one
thinks i can be and just that just me
talking about that
i have the hair going up on my arms my
mom didn't know how bad my grades were
she never saw one report card
i hit i hate everything from and she
didn't even ask she was so bogged down
with life
and so i got away with a lot of
because her mind was occupied so it made
me honestly a weaker person
so i scammed life my mom helped me scam
life for a while but this time i
couldn't scam life i went the second
time took the asvab test failed it again
and a week later she got a letter in the
mail from my high school
and i'm a junior in high school and she
and it later says pretty much your son's
going to flunk out he's missed 25 at
school because she was always gone sonny
went to school he's gonna miss school
and so or he's gonna flunk out so
i was exposed once again my mom goes
well
she read the letter to me
she put my bed and her best advice was
guess what you're gonna flunk out of
school
that was it in a conversation
so this is when i developed my
accountability mirror and
this is awesome
i
i look in the mirror and at this time
i
didn't want to be
the black kid in school there's like
five or six of us in school and like
1700 kids like that
and i made up a character
to kind of like draw attention from
color
okay and so what i did was i started to
design haircuts
and one haircut i had was the old man
and i shaved my head up here just like
this you did this i did this and i would
keep the hair on the side like a old man
has
and one time i shaved my whole head and
had a reverse part so i had hair up here
and it kind of zigzagged so i did things
to be this cool crazy
kind of like creative kid
you know like crisscross came out this
time pants sagging but backwards so my
back pockets are here i had two freshman
i was crazy man
but
i was a crazy cool kid in school
so i look in the [ __ ] mirror i see
this letter i'm i'm i'm [ __ ] up
and i'm like you know what man no one is
coming to help me yeah i remember back
to what my principal said i went to the
principal when they wrote that [ __ ] on
my car and in my notebook
and the best advice he can give me
god help his soul was this
they're ignorant they spell [ __ ] niger
god
and so that's but honestly i talked to
the guy as i wrote my book
and i have nothing wrong with principal
freeman
he he actually
i actually interviewed him for the book
and he was happy to interview he was
good man
what you could tell us some black cuz
you're a white guy in white society we
could we could tell me you could shut
the school and have a damn so i started
talking to myself this way in this
mirror
what this principle because at that time
like this is the best you can do
principal freeman
that was my mind then but in in this
mirror
it wasn't my mom it wasn't principal
freeman it wasn't my dad it was me
because when nobody coming back to help
david goggins that was my mindset now
and so
with my non-spelling ass i started
getting these sticky notes
and writing
my mom wakes up like what what is wrong
with you i go man i'm i have to change
because i i can't stay here
i can't i i looked at myself in here and
i was defeated i go look at myself i'm
like who am i
so i'm defeated in this mirror and i'm
like okay i'm changing on the other side
of that extreme place that i call
suffering call whatever you want
there's a whole other world
that people have not even examined
but you have to go to that extreme place
to examine it we want to stay here in
this comfortable place once you're going
to push yourself to that extreme place
it's like a whole nother universe it's
almost like like you're an astronaut and
you've examined something like up in
outer space no it's always been there
but you have to be going through all the
muck and all the
it's examined and you realize why god
through all this crap there's a whole
other whole universe over here in my
mind yeah yeah hold that universe when i
was in the worst time of my life in hell
week
i looked at everybody
and said i'm the most trained person
here yeah well that's the truth i've
gone through more mental torture than
any ewok even fathom yeah so i'm looking
at the baddest people on the planet i'm
looking i'm like this
you guys can't hold a stick so i started
looking at verses like i don't belong
here
versus like
i might be the best person ever come
here wow
who could have
pulled this off
who could have been given
a sewer to live in in their mind
and say okay at birth i'm gonna put you
in the worst place on the planet earth
and let me see if you can go to the top
of the mountain right
with nothing right
but just hard work grit and figuring it
out and not putting yourself back in the
dungeon every time something got hard
so that's what became
my daily voice was you really are the
baddest person on the planet and after a
period of time
you start to believe that right we have
two voices in our mind
and boy i know they're [ __ ] true
i've heard them i hear them now
and they're real
there's that one voice that voice i used
to love to hear that we love to hear
it's that soft
that soft
voice that says sleep the [ __ ]
it's okay
it's that cuddling voice you want to be
hugged and nurtured and all that
that says it's gonna be okay
well there's another [ __ ] voice
that wakes you up in the middle of the
night
it's not your girlfriend
it's not your boyfriend
it's that demon [ __ ] voice that
whispers in your [ __ ] ear
that says get up [ __ ]
you're not good enough
you gotta work harder you haven't put
enough time in it's that voice you want
to run away from it's that voice you
don't want to hear but guess what it's
that voice you need to listen to stay
hard listen to the whisper did you cast
out negative people in your life or just
use it as fuel to do even better and do
you still have relationships with energy
sucking vampires there's no relationship
with so energy people that suck the life
out of me you're gone that's a total tom
ferry like energy sucking vampires avoid
those people right but this is the thing
about though yeah you can't use it for
fuel either yeah you have to get that
hate you can't move forward
with hate yeah you can't i try to do it
yeah i used to have energy and all that
stuff but what happens is we when you're
in a horrible situation in life
that hate and anger
for some reason you can't remember
because
that place you're at is so disgusting
you forget about them yeah so you might
just let go of it anyway we had this
class
that they designed
e to l for one by that time
self-talk visualization
arousal control
it's all great
it's all
great it has to be a lifestyle yeah
you work on
mental calisine on a daily basis
because you're you know your brain your
mind like your brain is in the muscle so
much
you will lose it you will lose the
ability to suffer in the worst of times
if you come out of it for too long
if you can lift 315 pounds
and you stop going to the gym for a
month
i guarantee you won't be able to pick
the same weight up again
you're going to find peace from going to
war with yourself cause we all got
we all got people look at me
the reason why my story resonates with
people because i don't hide
i'll tell you exactly the [ __ ] i am i
will admit to it people are great at
hiding
so they want to just find peace no you
gotta you gotta take your [ __ ] fix
whatever's up in you don't just shove it
under a rug fix it and then you'll find
some peace later it's funny you talk
about that i work with a guy who's in a
business like this for five years i'm
not gonna mention his name yeah he
called me up five years ago and said i
want you to work with me yeah his job
a big day for them was if you had five
meetings
and 40 calls 40 that was like according
to their big business plan that was a
day yeah he said i want to make more
money um all this just bug you know it's
bogging me down i said this is your day
five meetings and 40 calls like do you
start at 10 and yeah
and and this company you work for says
that this is a great day this is what we
want
i had this guy no [ __ ]
one day he made a thousand
cold calls
and had seven meetings yeah so his new
norm which is now the company like how
did you become he made a hundred
thousand went to making six hundred
thousand dollars in three years yeah
that's that's the jump he had just
because his mindset changed because the
company
put this
this label this is what is a good day a
good day is 40 calls
five meetings i said that's a
day because you're comparing yourself
with mediocre people bingo
bingo do not run
with mediocre people i'm going to tell
you how to beat these mediocre people
this is your new
300 dials in eight meetings yeah
and his whole world changed how do we
learn from you and the seals
to handle our pain we're in the midst of
pain
what because it hurts and it hurts
physically sometimes obviously and then
some of us are dealing with emotional
pain
what do we do in those moments when
we're feeling the most pain and we're
going i cannot
go one more second
so this is the thing
a few years ago the navy seals designed
a program called
um the buds butts prep program
and my last two years in the military i
did 21 years
they sent me down to great lakes chicago
and we were training these guys to get
ready to go to buds still training
because a lot of guys weren't getting
through we thought this program would
help them get through
so these guys would leave our program
studs
push-ups sit-ups swimming everything
but the numbers were the exact same
so i was scratching my head like how the
work these guys go through two months of
this before they get the buzz and still
quit
yeah and we'll ask you a question in a
second don't go for it
i started going back through my mind and
realizing one thing
we were building bigger stronger faster
quitters
why is that
if you don't work on the one thing the
most powerful weapon in the world is
your mind yeah
so the answer your question is this
whether it be physical pain or mental
pain
we all have to start from zero with pain
and what that means is
if you don't go back we all have
something that bothers us everybody in
this world is insecure about something
that's right something in life whether
it be your family your mom your dad your
brother your sister your wife your
husband your kids something has messed
you up
and whenever you're in physical pain
even though you might not be thinking
about that
mental stuff that happened to you
your mind is thinking about it
all these dungeons that we've created
all these trap doors
that our life has created most of the
time we quit
is because we don't have any mental
tools to get us through the other side
so
my whole thing for people is you have to
examine
why are you doing it in the first place
what makes people quit so much in still
training in in all other special ops
training
is the mind it's always comfortable to
sit there you watch the navy seal show
discovery channel you're in a 72 degree
house oh yeah you have your lemonade
your milkshake whatever yeah i can do
that oh sure you're comfortable although
i'll say this i never say that well some
people do yeah a lot of folks think you
know because it feels very comfortable
in that comfortable environment oh
totally absolutely the second you get
out there in that environment where it's
40 degrees like in my third house we you
know we had a guy die
of pulmonary edema died out there my
third hell week
you have to really
want
what able you know whatever you're going
for yeah if not
all these questions that come up like
you said how you go one more step
further yeah your mind's gonna ask you
all these questions
how can you go one more step further if
you don't have the answers to that and i
can't give them to you yeah that's right
you have to know why am i here
for me when i was going through seal
training i was willing to die
so all these negative questions that
kept on coming up my head
i had the answer for them
it's those people that don't have the
answer
for those negative questions right and
and if you can't answer those questions
you will quit when you're when you're
mine this is this this whole 40 rule
that i talk about all the time that i
made up a long time ago i started making
it up through pain tell them what that
is what you go so basically the 40 rule
is
i am a strong believer that we quit
because why how the 297 pound cockroach
guy right who quit on everything is now
considered one of the best man on the
planet
how is that possible
it means
i had to change one thing my mindset
so
there's no way in hell that that was it
but that was that guy was in me when
that guy came down here and said hey
guess what man you're a fat ass but i'm
gonna now make you a badass
i want a miracle
to be a badass no
it was in me
i had to believe and make that belief
work
and through hard work i did that
so the 40 rule was like we have a like a
car
some cars have a governor on it
and when you gets like 92 miles an hour
that car start doing this because it
can't go any faster those cars that
don't have governors on like like a fast
ass whatever porsche whatever i'ma
[ __ ] bury it dawn
we have that abilities but we
have put this governor on our minds
and you have to the factory that put the
governor on that car the factory is now
you
that put this in your mind you gotta
take that
off
until you take it off
you're gonna constantly get to 92 miles
an hour and do this
because you ain't growing faster
yeah in my fact you might even go slower
so basically i started realizing this
through my life through going through
all these times so i get a lot of emails
about
how do i stay motivated hungry driven
well let me tell you something
most days in life when i wake up
i'm not motivated hungry or driven
i've committed to myself the best person
myself
what most of us are looking for
is a special [ __ ] feeling of oh i
feel great this morning i'm gonna get
out of bed and get a quick five miles in
or go to the gym
if you're looking for that feeling
let me tell you one thing ain't gonna
come
you have to learn to do
when you don't want to do it
learn to bring that savage mentality out
of yourself the animalistic [ __ ]
you think a savage gives a [ __ ] about
how he feels or how she feels then just
do it
learn to be your best self when you're
least motivated stop looking for a
feeling
to control what goes on in your life you
have an obstacle to overcome
so overcome
i'm a big guy in visualizing i'm a big
guy in making a world it may not exist
to me it does
to me it does
and
i'm overpowering myself every day
and you gotta find tools to do that
that's the tool that i use anybody that
can accomplish anything that is hard
the only separator is is that they
really want to be there
there's some people that get inspired
and that inspiration moves them to try
to do something but the inspiration
is very high right now in this nice
environment we're in a nice environment
the ocean's out there i'm talking to you
if i want to go to the refrigerator and
get something to drink eat i can i watch
a movie about some bad asses you're
inspired
but the second you're not in this
environment
and you're actually doing what inspired
you
that suck factor is not real you can't
just get off your couch and get a shake
or get a box of donuts or turn the tv or
go take it
or go go get your girlfriend and cuddle
up nah you're now there and only those
people
who have been there
a million times in their minds
and have lived in that water and have
suffered
a million times and realized my legs may
break
my knee may break my bones will hurt i
will be the coldest i've been in my life
i will be miserable
and accept that
because what happens is we when you get
in a horrible situation in life your
mind i call it my one second decision
when you get a horrible situation in
life your mind immediately says get the
out of here everybody does even if you
want to be there
but it starts to have all these
different questions
in your mind in that one second
it says okay why are you here why are
you doing this why this why that and
then you start to say yourself
if you don't want to be there that bad i
have a beautiful wife at home man why
the [ __ ] doing this man like this is
stupid this is gonna get these guys
injured
like they're gonna pay for this for the
rest of their lives i'm not gonna break
my body up to do this
your mind starts to say yeah this is
stupid
but if you have if you are already
knowing that this is gonna happen to you
you have all the answers to these
questions
that your mind starts to give you when
you're in suffer mode
let's say for
shits and giggles i'm training for 100
mile race yeah let's say a 200 just for
shits and giggles i'm training for 100
mile race right okay good so let's say
i'm training for 100 mile race
and i get to mile 50 yeah and i feel
like
and like everybody else my mind gets
soft
why because i'm human
i'm not some damn you know hybrid
creature that was formed from the
heavens above no not human i suffer i
don't like it i'm uncomfortable i don't
like it
so my mind starts to get weak
and we start to forget
about how badass we are i call that the
cookie jar but it's not about the cookie
jar right now this is about self-talk
yeah but but the cookie jar kind of goes
to self-talk too it's a piece of it so
basically what i do here is you have to
make sure that your mind doesn't become
[ __ ]
when it's suffering whether it's in pain
all it wants to do is find the easy way
out which is usually quit
if you quit the pain goes away
immediately yeah
you got to give yourself enough
energy and fuel in your mind to stay
just a little bit longer so you can talk
yourself into staying for the whole
thing this how it works most of us never
start anything cold
if you're going to go
to college you got to steady your ass
off
if you want to run a 100-mile race a
marathon if you want to go be mr olympia
if you want to go be a scientist a
doctor you're one of the best
salespeople on the planet you've got to
work you've got to work but this is you
got to build you got to build that but
what happens is
in that moment when we need self-talk
when we're failing and we're in our
worst spot possible
we forget
the back end yeah
my fault the front end the all the build
up to where we're at today
we forget how much work we put in so for
me
i'm at my office one more time so
i'm in the middle of it right i'm making
my calls i hate it you're at mile 50. i
hate it your mind's getting you know
wiggly on you i just want to get out of
here yeah we forget that we put years
years maybe not into making these dials
but to getting where you're at today to
become this person become this person to
be in a position to make this money
where the [ __ ] you want to make whatever
you want to do in your life yeah
we forget that we forget that journey
on what it took for us to get in this
moment to make the right decision yeah
so that's my self-talk is this okay i'm
gonna get the [ __ ] out of here man i'm
done
then i remember this
you ran 2 000 miles
training to be in this moment right now
we forget that yep we forget the three
o'clock in the morning runs or getting
up early for work or whatever you're
doing we forget all that in that moment
of suffering i remind myself yeah i only
have 50 more miles i put in six months
of training you did sixty seven thousand
sixty seven thousand pools that's 130
right exactly this is no big deal we
forget all of that yeah so what i do my
self-talk is basically
going back down memory lane yeah of all
those
days i ran the rain or i had to study
real late at night and i didn't want to
do it but i did it to get here yeah
that's the hook that is the hook it's
the hook
i want it to get here yeah now you're
here and now you want to quit yeah so
you got to be mindful but this thing
about it if you haven't put in any hard
work
to reflect on you
yeah
so there is no self because you got
nothing to pull back it's just a lie
nothing to say hey you've done this
before that's right or you've done
something like this before all this all
this like people want to be all positive
all this positive talk it doesn't work
if it's a lot like
if you didn't study for your big exam
and you go into it saying i'm gonna pass
it yep no you're not yeah you're gonna
fail it yeah that self-talk is not gonna
work self-talk without real work
is just a lie yeah so my self-talk is me
reminiscing back on the struggle to get
to this moment
and that tells me we're not quitting
today yeah not today for instance in
hell week yeah they said when you get to
wednesday of hell week you're broken so
everybody on wednesday but give them
contacts yourself okay 72 hours a day
i'm talking about 130 hours of training
yeah it starts on sunday ends on friday
and on wednesday you're almost done
halfway through yeah so everybody on
wednesday they hear this because
everybody says wednesday's like man
you're so tired you're done so that
becomes your new norm yeah
no you're cruising into wednesday
getting ready to feel tired when you
don't even know why because someone told
you you could feel tired
so for me i was like hang on a second i
started studying my mind a whole bunch
while growing up facing these things
don't listen to anybody's dialogue but
your own they're tired they're not you
yeah so it's just all about this is your
mind has a tactical advantage over you
at all times it knows your weaknesses it
knows your strengths and it will guide
you into your nice comfort zone yeah we
have to reprogram our mind to get it
like a different vantage point so that
you know how to be in charge of yourself
versus your mind being in charge of you
no matter how far you get in life
you have to be able to go back to
scratching your mind
at a moment's notice
you can never get so far beyond scratch
what that means is
when you accomplish something in life if
you want to go back to scratch
and go back to that seven dollar a month
place where i once lived and visit that
place for a long period of time
if you were here when you went back to
scratch you would now be here
scratch is what makes you better
scratch friction obstacles create growth
there's no friction
when you're this far up in the game
anymore you think there is
that's right when you cheat so much the
friction is is is minor
because why
i'm sore i'm gonna get a massage today
i'm hungry i'm gonna eat today the
refrigerator is always full
so your comforts are now so your
discomfort is now very miniscule to your
discomfort back here in the seven dollar
month place
so you have to go back to the total
discomfort
to then raise your level of where you're
at now i'm not saying stay there and
stay there
visit visit it
and then you raise your level take a day
trip that's right yeah always take day
trips yeah don't stay there that's right
but take a date
i start there first yep so i worked with
a few pictures i won't name their names
big name pictures
and i studied them for a long time i
want to be better man i want to be
better and be better so i i got film on
i studied him i studied about okay what
is wrong
that's it yeah i saw it
whenever something bad would happen
on the mound that's the first thing they
would do totally the head drops
shoulders roll forward
they look down
that sends a direct message
to your brain that i failed
i am a failure
that starts the downward spiral to being
a failure
on that mound you can't even recover
yeah
it's that so i started teaching this
it's that person who you throw a bad
pitch
you get the ball back
your chin is not high because it shows
that you're way too proud your chin
stays here
your shoulders stay nice and level your
feet firmly on the ground your hands
planted like i'm ready to beat
somebody's ass and i'm ready for battle
it tells your mind
wow
maybe we didn't [ __ ] up that bad we're
still in the fight
so that's the one thing i always do is
like even if i [ __ ] up yeah keep your
body positioned like you're still a
warrior
like you're still fighting if you get a
hundred bad calls in a row yep
hello i'm david goggins how you doing
today yep
okay wrong one
don't start getting poopy pants and get
upset with yourself no it's a mentality
and your body language has a direct
thing to your brain and how it functions
what's your daily meditation or mantra
or repetition to yourself
every day i tell myself
i used to believe i was the weakest man
that god ever created
so now i believe that i'm the hardest
human being that god ever made
i don't care if it's true or not
it's the most important conversation to
me it's the thing that drives me every
day it it it's the one thing that keeps
me going every day is that you must
constantly be that man that you want to
be so before i start this journey be
navy seal i go back to see my dad
because i realize now i gotta fix some
[ __ ] i'm blaming everything i gotta go
back you know how a lot of times you're
like
if you're a runner you're you're your
your right knee may hurt but it's not
your right knee that hurts it's really
left hip yes but we're constantly on the
right knee
i'm concentrating on all my
but i need to go back to the root of the
problem which is my dad
i gotta face the demon
i gotta go back and see what made him so
to make me so why am i
mm-hmm
so i go back and i and i go back in as a
as an older man now i'm in my 20s i'm
not a kid anymore and i want to see this
man and face him as a as a as a grown
man but still as a kid in my head i was
still a kid but i was a grown man as my
age i went back and i realized he was
the same man that he was still the same
still the same
and i talked to him he was still nuts
and um but i i i go back and face that
one more time but to face it in a
different way how'd you do it
differently
i looked at him in a way we never said
sorry to one another and he went off
about my mom and my grandparents and all
kind of i looked at them in a way that i
realized now
why you put this up
i had to almost be him
to realize it's okay brother
it's okay because i realized that
somewhere in your life
something brought you up
and you didn't deal with it
and so you put that [ __ ] on me my mom
and everybody around you
i'm gonna deal with my
wow so even though you gave me all this
you you gave me a satchel that i didn't
deserve and now i'm off people think i'm
a liar
you gave me this you created this
nightmare of goggins
i'm gonna fix it though i saw these navy
seals before i became one my god they're
better than me yeah they bear me i gave
up a hundred sets
and i had to work up to realize these
are human beings yeah
with the same that i have yeah this some
people run faster swim better but
mentality's mentality yeah there's no i
you're not gonna outwork me so i'm gonna
catch up somewhere yep so that being
said
i used all that 300 pound man that fat
guy that dumb guy people say why you say
dumb you have to be real with your self
you got to be wrong if you're not smart
you're dumb but you can become smart
you can become smart it's not a
permanent tag you're dumb forever yeah
you're fat forever no be raw don't find
the cushy word so who i was i was this
nobody guy
and i created this goggins
and that goggins
there's david goggins and there's
goggins
david goggins is a calm cool guy that
sits back
used to be a
you know weak kid now he's just a normal
guy goggins is a guy that is willing to
tape up his legs to go after it
um
in that book you read about david
goggins and also goggins
what i realized in my life
is that
goggins is who i love
goggins is who i created
my dad created david goggins
i created goggins so what's happening
with me
and
since can't hurt me came out and since i
got on social media which is why i
don't like social media which i'm not on
there very much which i give people
one time i have to do me
i have to do me
so people get it twisted man i am who i
am yeah what's in that book is me yeah
so now what they see
is this guy who's trying to get people
to get off their [ __ ] ass
that just happened to happen man
i didn't set out when i set out to be a
conceal and set out to go to ranger
school and all the stories i did and
break records i didn't set out to
[ __ ] please
right i didn't set out to say hey pay me
now i got a great story
and i realized now that my life has kind
of gotten to a point where people know
me i have followers and whatnot the
biggest depression of my life
is you get caught up into
helping so many people out
and it's great and i love that but you
lose yourself in all of that
truth it literally and people go man but
but my god like you're you're changing i
get all that [ __ ] man but what the
is motivating you in that book
what's motivating you is the stories i'm
telling you about what i did in my life
once i stop living that i'm no more
yes
i am not the that you are now being
motivated from
so right now in the mirror i now got
back to goggins
i'm now back to running 100 miles a week
i'm now back to getting i saw and i
talked to my girl about all the time
you you you travel you speak you you
know you you all this
it's all great and dandy for some for
most people
i'm goggins what makes me me
is the dungeon
and yeah and people well oh my god
they're gonna hear this my god dude you
don't have any peace in your life don't
get it twisted weak people
who hear me get all poopy pants about
how i talk
so be it
what changed me
was i had to be hard on myself
and i have to continue to grind
myself into a fine dust yeah
period that's where i feel good i think
i accomplished something if things come
easy it's not fun i must fail at
something repeatedly it has to haunt me
and then once i complete it
i feel like i accomplished something
i don't want to set out and say oh
there's an a
we're good right stupid no i want to
turn it in a million times and say you
fail you failed and i said okay roger
that
and sit there and analyze what i'm doing
wrong
go to these places that people don't go
to anymore because all this social media
everything's computerized
i want to go to that dark place my mind
says okay how are we going to get this
done we live in a world that's so busy
and so active and moving so fast right
now i am sitting with tom ferry
my mind is sitting with tom ferry
is not talking to tom ferry about
thinking about my god i can order some
more books i'm sort out out of here i'm
doing this i'm doing that
that's the first thing about
visualization yeah you must make sure to
silence out all the
of life which is very hard to do and it
is very hard because
your
your visual picture
must be clear
it has to be clear
it can't be like kind of in and out like
a like a fuzzy tv you got to see it it
has to become real you got to take a
snapshot of it a million times put in
the bank
that snapshot of me was getting that
4021 pull-up yeah knocked out because
the record was 4020. yeah
i visualized that over and over and over
again i visualized what i was going to
say because a guy's name was steven
highland i was thinking like what you're
going to say to me to him on video i
finally got his ass yep so i visualized
success
but then i went through that's the
that's the fun part yeah
i have to do
4020 pull-ups to get to that 4021
pull-up
i know now because it took me three
chances to get it all those failures
they were great for me to examine
where i was [ __ ] up at along the way
so i take all that and i and i put in
the bank as far as visualization okay
when i get to 2500 pull ups my hands
start to rip
okay get ready for that so i started
visualizing how am i gonna handle the
pain mm-hmm okay then you start
visualizing okay my my nutrition was off
you start visualizing all these things
because you have to mimic it
a million times but i can't mimic 4020
pull-ups
by doing it but you can see all the
milestones where you fail right and see
yourself going beyond it that's right
yeah so that that was my big thing about
i either walk in get the chalk see i had
to see everything over and over and over
again and when i realized i had to keep
that visual that picture in my head for
17 hours it took me 17 hours to break
that record
so for 17 hours while i used to be loud
everywhere i went i put these headphones
in yeah i never listen to music by
listening to one song going the distance
you know for 17 hours it's 2 minutes and
13 seconds yeah for 17 hours i had that
in that's a lot of rocky a lot of rocky
and i just went here yeah for and so i
was able to visualize
every rep yep so i visualized my hand
placement
making sure that felt right before i got
going i didn't ignore
all the little pains my hands got sweaty
okay that means i was aware of
everything that means my okay my hands
about to rip it's getting sweaty wipe it
off be aware everything i was totally in
the moment because of how i visualized
everything i have a good living now for
me where i'm at in my life
i was out on a fire in colorado
and we were digging fire line on this
like 50 like it was like on the side of
a daggone mountain yeah and we're trying
to keep the fire from moving and we're
digging this fire line 14 inches or my
fault 18 inches wide three miles long
12 of us digging
and it is the hardest work you make
twelve dollars an hour wow okay
nothing you set up your shop like when
you're done digging you pretty much lay
down you go to sleep and you get up you
dig some more really happens for two
weeks longer what are you digging it's
like a whole
line so you're trying to get down to a
mineral source so you're trying to get
down to the to the earth so so that if
that fire is moving
it can't burn dirt really so you're
moving fuels got it you're you know so
so not only are you digging you're
cutting down trees it's hard work but
the moral story is i'm 43 don't need to
do it at all this is why i do i'm making
money i'm making my own i i i have a
good life
i don't need to do it
everybody ask me why i do it this is
why this 21 year old kid was out there
and
he wanted a pair of running shoes that's
all you want with pair of runners shoes
60 70 100 bucks or whatever you know
easy for us yeah shoes
he looked up at the mountain
that we had been on for days digging
this fire line
and he said that'd take me five or six
hours of work to buy those shoes
something like a buyer
it's the perspective of life that
perspective of life right there
of that is the value that we lose
when things start to come so easy
in life
it's the perspective that 21 year old
have we looked about that mountain and
thought he looked at his hands he looked
at the at the amount of hours of pulling
that pulaski that that tool and raking
that ground and then cutting those trees
and moving them and that hours of work
he looked at his feet and said these old
shoes would do
it's that perspective in life that we
lose
and that's that story to most people may
not mean anything
it's that story i always want to have in
my life
you cannot lose perspective
of
where you've come in life i mean a
thousand dollars a month 300 pounds just
i can't do any of this stuff yeah these
people are better than me yeah so the
first thing is that's the first big
problem right there
first big problem is that you have put a
lot of people above you yeah put no one
above you yeah no one whatever but if if
if you believe in something say that
again say that again because that's
you know but you know but the man the
people that make more money the people
that are better looking the ones that
are on social media and they're so good
at this i put god above me besides that
there's no one better than me got it you
have to become an equal so this i look
at it
if you're playing and i talked about it
at your conference if you're playing
roger federer yeah okay
be
before you get on the court with roger
federer he's the best of all time yeah
but you're also a professional tennis
player man yeah you're forgetting your
own resume yep so
once you get on the court let's say it's
a grand slam
it's five sets hopefully if you can go
the distance with this guy yeah but
before you even bounce the ball to serve
it
you're down two sets because while you
look across and you're playing roger
federer yeah but guess what
you get a good shot on roger federer in
the third set
and you realize i can play with this
but it's too late yeah you gave up two
sets before you go on the court
you gotta stop giving up two incest
before the game begins my dad really
helped create this i'm not giving him
credit yeah like oh he was a great dad
like clapped my hands for his ass
he helped create this because he was
just that he was a a devil
you know he was a guy that had to be
very insecure very beat down something
had happened to him when he was younger
because the the way he treated me my
brother my mom was just horrible
so
he would beat us my mom my brother my me
and i'm not talking like oh you got in
trouble something to give you a weapon
he would he was drunk okay so whenever
he woke up man he woke up drinking went
to bed drinking and that's how it was
and when he get drunk he just got
violent
so my mom caught my dad cheating
we got home about four o'clock in the
morning
so i'm about seven eight years old
and
i hear some ruckus outside my room as
i'm getting ready to bed down for the
night
and my mom and dad are outside my room
because there's a staircase right there
and my dad is smacking the hell out of
my mom
and knocks her
almost unconscious where she's kind of
out of it you know she's kind of loopy
she falls down he grabs him by her hair
and drives you downstairs by her hair
and so at this age
i'm starting thinking man you know what
the dude man like you know i'm scared
but then something in me saying you
gotta go
and do something oh my god but i'm
scared of death of this guy he's been
beating me
since i can remember and i mean like
laying me out for nothing
and i'm still thinking man okay man like
what am i gonna do so my brother he and
i were very different when my brother
would see the fighting he would go to
this room and hide all right yeah i
didn't do that i always stuck around so
this time i stuck around i decided to
help her out so i go on the stairs and i
jump on his back
and literally he tells my mom you're
raising a gangster and she's like on the
floor
and he's almost smiling almost like
proud
but
that smile went to a frown pretty quick
and he beat the living hell out of me
and he beat me literally from my neck
down to my ankles like black and blue so
the next morning
um i was gonna go to school half today
my mom woke up and she pulled the covers
back
and what she saw
was how bruised i was
and so when she pulled the covers back
and saw a bruise that was i'll never
forget looking at her face
because she used to write letters for me
you know for me my brother to miss p.e
because we were so bruised up from
getting beaten so you know he's sick or
whatever and so you know she was lying a
lot from my dad
so this particular day she didn't write
a letter
but when i laid in the bed and looked at
my mom and she pulled the covers back i
never forget looking at her face
and her face is tattooing my brain and
while i say that
um this past year i got the vfw award
for americanism award
and if you google david goggins vfw
award
i'm in front of 5 000 veterans and i'm
getting this amazing award john mccain
got it and i'm up here thinking man i'm
not freaking this award this is amazing
it's for giving back and also having a
great military career
and i could give this six minute long
speech
and i'm up there man i'm talking and i'm
thinking i'm thinking people who help me
out i get to my mom she's sitting back
you know she's sitting right here on
stage behind me
and i haven't cried in 30 years i can't
even picture it haven't cried in 30 i
don't do that
and i turn around and say and i
want to thank my mom for um
not picking me up
when i was knocked down but teaching me
how to get up because she never picked
me up ever and because her circumstances
sucked yeah so anyway i looked back and
i said that and i got done i didn't even
get a chance to say it
i looked at her eyes and my head went
right back
to her face when she saw me bruised up
and that
me up in for 58 seconds look at the
video
and you'll see me my head's down and i'm
sobbing wow and i'm in front of 5 000
vets and the guy who was who was hosting
the thing had to come up to me
and like put his hand on my back and i
was just destroyed
overcome with emotion
and then
58 seconds go by and i get up and i
deliver this speech and so i tell you
that because
life
my life tattooed me whenever times got
hard my mind said you're not good enough
right let's go right
so
my mind wasn't my eyes my mind weren't
connecting right
so how do you combat that so how you can
bat that is this
i call it the cookie jar okay
you have to remind yourself
we all have a story we've all all of us
have gone through very hard times
but we're when we're in a hard time
our mind has a way of forgetting
what all we've overcome
i have a way of taking one second when i
want to quit and say okay
you endured this so i look at my life
and how i came up as the ultimate
training ground
versus most people look at it as why
what was me god why exactly why right i
had to flip this upside down and say
hang on a second
god was training me to be one of the
baddest men on the planet absolutely
right that's how
he this was this was my journey when i
was younger
life in society
made this big world with all these
endless possibilities
endless possibilities my life made my
possibilities this big yeah because it
made me afraid of all these different
things yeah so all this stuff trapped my
mind it shackled my brain it made me a
prisoner within my own self saying this
is all i can do because why i'm afraid
of this i'm insecure over here i got
stuff down over here back behind me good
lord who knows who's behind me i might
look behind me so your life is this big
versus it being like i can do all this
out here if i start to break down these
ball you know these these different
walls and barriers
and that's what i started realizing
i could become a navy seal
i could become this but
i was afraid of the water think about
this i know
why
are you going to go be a navy seal
when all you do is play in the water
yeah for and we don't play we are in it
and we're living in it you're tying
ocean you're swimming for me
the ocean is unforgiving yeah so my mind
is i'm gonna go be a navy seal yeah
if i didn't face that fear
no one would ever know me i was number
three behind michelle obama for a long
time until my book sold out yeah
and i was a guy just
21 years ago
who was 300 pounds
can barely read and write
and now the book just two spots behind
michelle obama yeah
hopefully hopefully we get it above
today right just because i was afraid
yeah
but you overcome those fears guess what
happens the whole world you unlock this
door and everything opens back up again
in the race of life
life's not going to give you a glass of
water when you're thirsty
and i realize that
and once again people at my god your
life is horrible
it's not yeah this is how i live it's
how i live this is what i want i don't
judge anybody this is how i live
and there if there's not people
like me in this world
with this kind of mentality
it's not be like david goggins go around
200 miles take something from this
take something from this
remember where i started from you don't
need to go where i went right i went
this far i started opening different
doors
to the cellar in my brain my god is this
possible oh my god that's possible this
is possible i start to open up different
compartments
you can leave them shut
i don't care i'm looking at all these
different races and one comes up number
one the hardest race in the world
bad water 135. 135 mile race through
death valley
i'm like that sounds nuts
but i did
but it didn't describe that it was a
like a couple day race
i'm thinking okay that has to be like a
seven day race because i don't know
people run like that
so
i end up calling chris cosman up chris
carson is the race director of bad water
and he lives out here in california
he's like hey man i'm like hey chris i
call him up in the first conversation i
actually have all the emails in my book
yeah for me him going back he's he's a
stickler man i'll tell you that
so i called him up and said hey man i'm
gonna do this race it's like have you
ever run 100 miles before
i'm like no
he goes well to get my race you have to
do 100 mile race and you got to do 100
miles in 24 hours or less
there was only two more races i could do
before the deadline dropped
and so i'm like he goes you live in san
diego right i'm like yeah this was
wednesday
i called him up on a wednesday morning
he goes well there's a race on saturday
and it's a it's called a san diego one
day at um hospitality point in san diego
where you run around a one mile
track for 24 hours so many miles you can
get
something like this guys kind of call me
out i'm gonna get done i'm a seal i'm a
badass been through ranger school and i
got this
hardest thing i did my entire life dude
was this one race
so
i go
harder than
than getting through hell yeah
i was not prepared okay at all
so i go
i sign up for the race i show up i'm
this big bodybuilder looking guy
shirt off black hat arm
you know and i'm i set out so every mile
i'm going to see this blue lawn chair i
had rich crackers and mild plex that was
my nutrition man no water no not just no
water no
no
plex dude come on
you know i never drink water on runs and
i didn't know about all this
so i go out there and i'm running i get
through 50 miles i'm gonna cut to the
chase because i detail it really well in
the book
um
i get going i sit down at mile 70. um
and buddy
i hadn't sat down yet
and i sit down and everything falls
apart
literally man i'm like peeing blood down
my leg
i have some crap coming out of me
and i got 30 miles to go
and i'm in the worst shape in my entire
life
and so i won't get too deep into it man
but i end up going back through my
cookie jar and i talk about you know my
my cookie jar is basically something i
invented about we forget how badass we
are when we're suffering
because our mind just stays right there
and suffering the cookie jar is a
reminder
you know how your mom used to have the
cookie jar you want you know you don't
know what kind of cookie you're gonna
get
but it may be uh oatmeal raisin maybe
chocolate chip meat because you know
she's dumps him in that [ __ ]
he's grab one and go
so my cookie jars the things i've
accomplished failed at didn't fail that
just just kept on grinding through so i
take this one second i calm down so i
realized okay man
i gotta be able to just stand up first
come all dizzy and lightheaded now go
through this process
and i said i might quit but not yet
i go this is the worst shape of my life
so i said i might quit
because when you're not going to quit
something you have 30 miles to go your
mind's spasm like i'm
like i like 30 miles a long way to go
just fresh
i've already gone 70 i'm the worst in my
life i'm like okay so i i'm giving my
mind some space because if you don't
give it space it's just going to freak
out something you know what i'm going to
quit but let me just sit here for a
second and drink some water now now i'm
drinking water i i have my crew going
over to get some you know nutrition some
food for me i'm getting better
so now i stand up
like wow i'm able to stand up now
because i wasn't able to i was all
light-headed
yeah i'm going on this track and i get
to my 81 and i wasn't going to make the
time because i was moving slow you're
behind time way behind okay
and this is the this is the craziest
thing in the world
and i think
you not
i'm in the worst shape my entire life
ever i've never even been close to this
again
never my 81
i'm not gonna make the time as slow as i
was moving
and
when your body and mind connect
and i think this is the only time i've
ever done this okay
you become a
cyborg
i end up running
20 miles
at about a 10-15 mile
and get done with that race i did 101
miles and 19 hours and six minutes
and to this day
and i don't and i don't detail it well
with you but in the book i do
i learned
more
from that 19 hours and six minutes
than i did in all three hell weeks
ranger school and this is months ranger
school was 60 something days hell week
and and all the buzz is six months i was
in i was in buzz for like 18 months
you know i went through delta four
selection twice you know pull up records
i learned more in that one race that i
wasn't prepared for that 19 hours
brought me from
utter misery happiness
failure success depression i went
through every emotion in the world in 19
hours most people who are failing are
trying to [ __ ] ass off yep
most people who are feeling are being
criticized by people who haven't
attempted what you're even trying to
fail at so what i'm failing at so after
i did 2500 pull-ups my first time going
for the record yep you mean people were
criticizing me people sitting there
eating chips on the couch
do a pull-up exactly look at your
audience who's criticizing you first of
all yeah they're not even in your
world yes you don't even talk to me yeah
block them out that's the first thing
yep
the second thing is through failure you
get all the answers you get all the
lessons all of them yes they're all
there yes so i was able to go back
through and say okay this happened this
happened this was wrong this is wrong
this is wrong so i don't even look at
failure like i didn't call it failure
yeah
i i don't because i don't look at my god
i failed no i look at okay
like trying to invict [ __ ] light bulb
i'm afraid you know what what's failure
i'm trying to invent a light bulb yeah
i'm trying to break
4020 pull-ups that's failure yeah
anything you do
along that way is
amazing so on this journey in life
there's a lot of people who are
right now
on the journeys you always be that
in the sewer you came from
that's grabbing at your ankle as you're
leaving that sewer that's going to drag
you right
back down because you
figured it out
they're not willing to figure it out
there's not much to figure out
the only thing to figure out is this
gosh and everybody has a different
equation
my equation is different than yours
my equation was very different than most
people i have to live what i say
so when you come from a world of used to
lie a lot
and my big thing is facing all this crap
i cannot tell you something i have not
done right because why
when you start to formulate this
character
this code of ethic
this ethos that you live not anybody
else this your own
i cannot tell you something that i
haven't done why because it will haunt
me
you are now drinking the kool-aid a lot
of people write books on
self-help mental toughness all this crap
half of them
are living up to that standard
half of them are living up that standard
you have to be able to practice what you
preach
it has to be what you are
that's why people say my god when you
speak on stuff it's so passionate
because you're making me relive my life
it's not a comfortable life
this life was made this life was earned
yeah and if people like it great if not
so be it real how much time you waste
during the day and most of it is on
these computers phones
you know instagram and back and forth
whatever the heck you call nowadays
tweeting and texting
we waste so much time on our little
gadgets
it's unreal and we talk about we have no
time if you really take you have to take
your day
and write write down this one day
everything you do write that down and
you're like my god i am wasting so much
time on frivolous not even funny i mean
it will it will if it doesn't infuriate
you
it should
because there's so much time i can't get
it in look at your schedule you just
wasted seven hours now
i mean you don't have an hour a day
to try to get something in for yourself
i guarantee everybody can find an hour
most of us live our entire lives
avoiding failure
it's funny
i walk around people come to me they say
man
you're that navy seal you went through
ranger school you were you know air
force tac p
you know you uh did the pull-up record
you run all these ultra races all this
[ __ ] man
the funny thing about it
that i think about is this they know
that part of me
this is the part i don't know about
myself
i thought the asvab tested in the
military three times
in the air force thrown at pear rescue
in the seals it took me three times to
get through navy seal training
the pull-up record took me three times
this is what i know about me
so what i'm saying is this
you can't live your life
being afraid to fail
all those failures
made me the success in the day
stay hard not giving civilized is
about having a savage mentality
civilized is something where people um
it's a it's a comfortable world a lot of
us say you know like for instance i see
these athletes right now who retire you
know i'm 38 you know i'm 39 i did 20
years at the top of my game and i'm
chilling out now you see them a year
later and how they look
what the hell just happened to you dude
what the hell you're one of the greatest
athletes of all time
kids looked up to you women men of all
ages looked up to you
and they hit the pinnacle where it's
time to retire and their mind says
i'm civilized the worst thing that could
ever happen to any human being
is they become civilized it's that total
accountability like even when you retire
there's a
looking at me and judging me right now
man
i'm i was the baddest person to ever
live
it doesn't go away man
you got to wake up even though you
retired you're never retired
you're setting the example every single
day of your life
and being civilized feels so good i'm
sorry man
once you get to the top
you may retire but you ain't never
coming back home man because now you're
judged
people see you falling off you want to
be that guy who knows i may be retired
from the sport or forever i did
but i'd be damned
if you ever see me looking like
feeling like not arriving people i've
arrived
i've arrived mentality you're always
setting the example civilization feels
so good
these comfortable feelings are what
people want they want retirement
they want that they need that they it's
a it's a yearning feeling
i want it too
people love putting a label on me about
my god man you're just wired different
not wired different dude
i'm thinking right now after i got past
my stuttering thing now i'm on a roll
i'm good now you know what i'm thinking
about right now i gotta wake up tomorrow
and do the same again i gotta leave this
interview and go stretch out for two and
a half hours
i hate that
but guess what it does though
i'm constantly callousing over my
victim's mentality that i once had
growing up
every day you have to do this
because why when you stop doing it you
don't just maintain it if you stop
shooting a gun you're not going to be a
great shot if you pick a gun up a year
from now
the only way to keep from getting rusty
is to constantly oh that
machine the machine is this
you got to keep challenging it every day
and i always talk about it i talk about
i'm always paying rent
in that seven dollar a month place
where i grew up in that nasty little
place i grew up in
i remember it i remember like it was
yesterday and i'm glad i do i never want
to forget
the dungeon of where i come from
even though it's real spooky and it's
scary and there's no lights on in there
and there's cobwebs and some creepy
mothers in there some demons
all those mothers in there made me
goggins made me who i am today that's
where the strength came from you got to
go back to the beginning to to the
fundamentals of life
to the very fundamentals of where it all
like playing basketball
you gotta go back to the fundamentals
you just you know you can't always just
stay up here
you got to go back to scratch i learned
to visualize in my life
by watching rocky and mainly rocky one
i'll have them all but like the rocky
three running on the beach seeing all
that but rocky won 14th round at least a
thousand times what about you
no
at least 20 000
why is that yes
um i've dissected that two minutes and
some
seconds two minutes and 13 14 15 seconds
at least 20 000 times
when i did the pull-up record
and i finally broke it took you three
times yep did 4 000 30 in 17 hours
i listened to one song
for 17 hours and it was going the
distance oh my god 2 minutes and 13
something for 14 seconds
on a loop on a loop but first the guys
guy named nandor
he kept playing out loud for everybody
and i brought my own little ipad i don't
ever listen to music but i was failing
so many times at this record i had to go
to that place
so i said you know i don't want to bore
you all anymore with this same song
because i had i had a crew of people
there filming it you know because they
had to be documented
so i didn't want them to be there for 17
hours listening to the same song kind of
it born so i put in my ears listen the
whole time but i'm going a step further
in that round
when rocky gets knocked down
and mickey's saying stay down stay down
and he's getting up
apollo creed thinks that he knocked him
out
so i have this thing called taking souls
okay
and when you see apollo creek turns
around arms in the air i got him
do you see when he turns around
and he sees because he apollo creed
knows i was
this dude up
he kept coming after me and i finally
knocked him down
when he turns around and looks at rocky
and and he says and watches him get up
and rocky gets his gloves and most of
him to come to him
apollo puts his head down
and just goes like this
it's not so much
rocky getting up that's big for me
apollo creed's face
became
every
that verbally and non-verbally
looked at me because you know that look
they give you when you think that you
know
they may not tell you your piece of your
nobody
they look at you almost like you poor
thing
i got them all
i got them all now you know that that
that little wheel you have with
everybody's name on it and phone numbers
i got my number in my head and i spend
that every day
and
i know right now
whether you hate me love me i'm a
i'm like this i'm a dad whatever you
want to think
i made it
and i know all of you
are looking just like apollo creed did
because i just kept
getting
all i wanted people to do in my life i
don't care about the money i don't care
about the fame i don't care if i care if
all my followers go away tomorrow
i wanted
a lot of people
that doubted me to look like apollo
creed did in that 14th round because i
got back up repeatedly and when you keep
on getting back up like that no matter
how strong the person is beating the
[ __ ] out of you they eventually
look at you and say you know what i'm
tired
and i just want people to be tired
just be tired i want to make you tired
because i just continue so that's what
that movie did to me that that movie
changed
how i looked at life me too it did how
do you pick the next challenge
the next challenge is usually
the toughest thing out there the thing i
don't want to do the most
yeah so my challenge has come off of
what am i afraid of yeah
what am i kind of cowering from
what am i looking at saying um
yeah because we all know what it is it's
in the back of your mind it kind of
floats back there it's like you know for
some of us it's as simple as i don't
want to get up and run today yeah that's
what's next so for me it's always
what am i not wanting to do yeah we have
a theorist and we have a practitioner
the theorist is a person that can sit
back and read books
from a library that someone else wrote
they become real smart about what
someone else wrote okay
a practitioner as a man
is me
i put myself in hell
lived in it for a long time and figured
out how the human mind works
while being while suffering while in
pain while misery and that's how i wrote
my book yeah i want to tell you exactly
what your mind is thinking
most of us don't stay in hell long
enough to write the book yeah
i stayed in long enough to write it and
finish the book everybody thinks i'm the
world's toughest mom right if i just
talk about i broke the pull-up record
i i i did all these races i went through
seal training went through i was in
three hell weeks ranger school if i talk
about all the badassery
like we like to do on social media
and i don't tell you
that i was a
kid and i was scared and i was depressed
and insecure and and all this
what good am i for anybody right i'm a
superhero
i'm a liar
i'm that now but i wasn't born that yeah
i had to make myself into this what's
your morning routine
every morning without fail the first
thing i do is i run
without fail i haven't missed a day of
running since 2016. okay so i get up i
do that four days out of the week i go
to the gym and every single night
for five and a half years i stretch out
for at least two hours that was the
killer part of the book every
night
that is that's where i so when you go so
hard
mentally physically emotionally
spiritually you have to have time set
aside to quiet
and recover
recovery's big the mind especially the
mind and the body this is my time
there's no phone calls there's no emails
the world does not exist
because i have to get ready for tomorrow
get the body opened up why because as i
won't get you know two you wouldn't be
through you went deeper
it was awesome but your body's getting
tight yeah you go hard tom yeah a lot of
people go hard what happens is that
stress yep starts to tighten up that
psoas muscle hip flexors so
lower back you got back problems all of
a sudden you have no idea why it's all
tightness it's all tightness man because
you're constantly charged and going hard
a lot of us are being forced into
solitude right now in our homes
apartments where we live
but we're also being forced
into solitude our own minds
life is the most brutal endurance sport
of all time
and that's what we have to love about it
we have to flip it on his head and love
the fact that life continues to attack
us there are no timeouts you can't just
go like an important event when a coach
doesn't like something call time out
you have to figure it out on the fly you
have to be that person who's always
prepared but the solitude right now that
a lot of us are dealing with is what we
don't want to deal with
it's the fact that we have to think
about
all these things that we don't like
about ourselves we like to use life as a
big escape the escape is not there
anymore all these distractions that we
use they're no longer there
this is the time right now for you to
stop avoiding things get that pen of
paper out look inside yourself stop
looking at me or other people out here
to be the hero of your story this is
time for you right now all that solitude
to get to know who you are as a person
be alone with yourself
write that down
start to start to face these different
things in life knowing one thing in life
we are all very fragile in this world
we have to know that when we die
we die with some meaning
and some purpose in this world stay hard
in chapter 11 which that's the last
chapter right last chapter and adam does
a wonderful job uh you know sort of
narrating and telling the story but but
then you broke into this piece that
i just like i had such an even deeper
appreciation for you
where you're like look man like this
visualization about like one day when we
all die
right so would you mind i mean i know
it's totally in the book no it's fine i
think it's a great way to wrap this so
let's say this man
so
i don't care what you believe in i'm not
judging you yeah i i am i believe in god
yeah i don't care if you're eighth i
don't give a damn what you are but for
this scenario yes
let's say that you're god yeah
let's say that
you guys you know for those of you who
read my book get the audiobook or the
hardcover or whatever i used to weigh
300 pounds yeah yeah i was 175 in high
school and 300 pounds yep let's say
that i didn't improve myself at all
i die at 75 years old on 300 pounds i
worked for ecolab my entire life making
a thousand dollars a month that's what i
made yeah and i go to heaven and you're
god
and you have a big long line of people
and i'm standing in line i'm coming up
i'm next so you have mary anne
and marianne you're talking to her
you're judging her and i'm like what
what what the hell does god have in his
hand what's that paper yeah
and so god tears it away and throws it
in trash can and marian goes walking
away yeah
now
you have a piece of paper in your hand
and i'm next and god says sit down david
david gaga that's right david geiger's
on top of the paper and i say
and god gives me the paper
and i look at it
when i'm reading this paper and on the
paper i'm seeing
all these amazing things
you were a 185 pound athlete you ran all
these crazy races you broke records you
were a navy seal you were the only
person to do this do that do everything
you had a
best-selling book man you changed
millions of lives
now look at god who is you right now and
i say um
this says david goggins up here which is
my name god but this isn't me i'm like
you know i think he gave me the wrong
the wrong paper and god says no
because god knows all god sees all and
god looks at me and says this is what
you should have been
this
this is what you should have been yeah
you should have been
this we all have a choice in the world
god or whatever you believe in
knows what you're supposed to be knows
what's inside of you
but most of us take the choice
that makes us feel good
we're not willing to break through those
barriers
to find because so my whole mindset was
this
that's how i visualize i visualize that
one day i will be judged by something
much more powerful than me
and my whole thing is while i'm living
on earth
god knows everything about david god
even god i want god to be up there with
a pen get another piece of paper saying
he did what i didn't even know he'd do
that i know he'd do this i know so i
want god to be impressed with how i turn
out yeah which means i want to check off
every single box of all the
possibilities of what i'm supposed to be
in life you are your own hero
you are your own leader you are your own
master
and
that is a big one because
we idolize so many people
and we want to be them
we want to be someone else
and in doing that
you lose all the potential of who you
are
you
mimic
you be them you are them you become them
and you lose you
and we look up to so many people in this
world who will let us down we're humans
i'm gonna let you down you're gonna let
somebody down if you put them on a
pedestal you then lose time when that
person comes up and lets you down
you must hold yourself accountable and
being your own hero that's what that
does
you make yourself so
totally accountable for who you are you
focus on you and only on you
to become the best person you can be for
others
because we leave a lot on the table
not searching who we are
and then therefore you die not knowing
your greatest potential so i'm sitting
there and i think i'm i think i'm going
to die
and we're saving my life
and i'm in this tub and i'm
jackhammering and this and i had this
hot water hitting me and i'm literally
in the worst pain my shins my feet i'm
broken
and i'm just sitting i'm cramping up
and she said we gotta get to the doctor
you know your mom's worried i'm worried
about like i we've
never seen this for my life
and i
go i'm not going anywhere
huh
i want to sit here and enjoy this pain
and
and
i and i know
the listeners hearing this are going to
say man you're a
no i'm not
what i
got a chance to experience
in that 19 hours and six minutes of my
life
was something i didn't want any
painkillers i i this was proof positive
what i was feeling is what i just did
i
i did something
without training without coaching
without a cheering staff without
any knowledge
i took a raw
human being with no training whatsoever
put him out in a condition
and just through this alone
got through it amazing and i sat there
and i was like
this is it was the best feeling
i've ever had and would ever have in my
entire i was in the worst pain in my
life and it was the best feeling
i ever had in my life not because of the
pain i was in
by the pain was confirmation
of my god
did i just do that wow and i had
completed hell weeks
but that right there was like don't take
this from me man
and and it was confirmation proof
positive
that
this young kid that came from [ __ ] that
wasn't [ __ ] that lied and cheated for
i was now
the truth i get a lot of questions
people asking me for help
so i asked them
what have you done to help yourself
most of them say
i've been working hard
i'm all about being your own hero
but i'm not about kissing your ass
in life a lot of us believe
that we're working much harder than we
actually are
we think if we got up early for four
days
we've earned something
you gotta drop your entitled mindset
is dead weight
we believe you work harder than we
actually have
trust me
most of us have it
the one thing in life you gotta realize
is this
learn to help yourself
don't count other people
to help you
stay hard i think pushing yourself
physically is the number one
factor of life
that is the true spot where you can
really dive deep
into life's about self-discipline
it is about self-discipline we tend to
do the things that are easy
and that is the it builds no mental
toughness it builds no mental hardening
it builds nothing
when you work out
working out is where you can build that
the fastest
because it's a constant it gives you
instant feedback
it's yeah you may not lose the weight
you want to real fast but the discipline
it takes it transfers over to all
aspects of your life
it's not people man why are you always
working out stop stop looking at that
way
this is the foundation of life
when you look in the mirror
every morning we all look in the mirror
to get ready to go to work to go
anywhere
the first thing you see is your
reflection if you don't like what you
see in the morning you lost the war
already
it's not by even liking what you see
it's about looking in the mirror and you
may start man i feel different
that reflection maybe not that
reflection is not everything it's a
feeling you're supposed to get
so you have to in life once you leave
your house the war begins
in your house you have some control
and that reflects in that mirror you
have to control that reflection in the
mirror that's how you start your day if
you leave your house feeling like okay i
can fight
i've established the mentality to fight
and that all that comes from working out
it's not just from you know you can't
find that in office the one thing that
only gets me mad nowadays is that so
many people die with untapped potential
because they think that someone else is
better than them
and they were born
you know not with the greatest tools
you don't need
you need the ability to
grind your ass into a fine powder and
when that fire powder find a way to
build that
back up repeatedly
and it's possible mediocrity is
everywhere right now and we're all
trying to find an easy way out and we're
judging ourselves let's say there's 10
people in this room and we're all
mediocre
but i'm the best
of the mediocre people
i now think i'm great
i'm great we surround ourselves around
people that make us feel great they tell
us what we want to hear the second we
put ourselves amongst the uncommon
people
we don't like that feeling
that challenge and feeling that of that
person is waking up at 3 30 in the
morning hey push your [ __ ] on we're
going for a run
we don't like that challenge we like
that person who says hey you know what
man i don't feel good today man and they
say oh it's okay brother we'll take a
day off maybe get a pizza and watch the
game we like that we we love that
feeling why because you understand man
we're good bro we don't want that much
like this hey man no bro get your on man
stop being a punk
we don't want that in our lives we don't
want that person who's constantly
challenging our weaknesses
we want that process constantly you know
making us feel nice and good and secure
in ours that's the mediocrity of life
we want to be the best amongst the
average people
people wonder how do you stay
hungry all the time because after i
accomplish something i don't sit back
like a lot of guys who graduate buds
graduate this graduate that they get
comfortable they wonder why i'm getting
weak man i don't know i lost my edge
what's going on because once you hit the
top of the mountain guess what happened
i'm good
i'm good so you wonder why you're
falling down now because once you're top
of the mountain you gotta build another
one that's mediocrity there's a lot of
people in mediocrity who have a nice
resume
but they're one-timers man they hit they
hit a one-time deal they busted it open
got a lot of money but they're good
you're mediocre now man
what are you
doing today tomorrow the next day that's
why i'm listening to theorists
i don't listen all that
i listen to who's like this man
what's wrong man tired dude why are you
tired because tomorrow
i gotta do the
again man whatever it is that made me
nauseous and sick to my stomach it made
me hurt
there's no ending
and that's the person i listen to
that's the person who's gained knowledge
you gain knowledge through suffering and
on the other end of suffering
is a world that very few
very few have ever seen it's a beautiful
world because that's where you find
yourself
you don't find yourself in over here you
find yourself on the other end like the
100 mile race i was on i ran it for 24
hours
i found myself
on the other end of that race
that 19 hours i found wow there's a
whole nother
world out here that never even saw that
the world is in your mind
and that's what all that mediocrity is
about mediocre is contagious i had to
stop caring what people thought about me
i realized that everybody's
that's the one thing i realized i walked
around i put these people on a
pedestal everybody was better than me so
i can't tell you anything about me
because you're going to judge me and i'm
going to feel even worse than what i am
what i realized once i calmed my mind
down and sat back and looked at how
jacked up this world is
once you realize that you are not alone
everybody that's talking to you about
how jacked up you are the only thing
they've done better than you
is they've hidden
their world better than you have
that's all they've done
so once i realized that
if you want to sit back like for
instance there's all these things that
are on tv and we have all these news
people judging people who [ __ ] up in
life and yeah they made big mistakes
but that person who is judging you on tv
i guarantee you that that news person
they say i'm glad that my didn't come
out
but i'm gonna judge the hell out of you
i know that about people so if you want
to sit back and judge how jacked up i
was and how messed up my life was merry
christmas go for it have a good time i'm
smiling at you right now knowing
you have a secret that you're not
willing to share
it gives you a lot of power when you're
able to go on
a podcast this big and say hey
tell me i'll tell you anything you want
to know can no longer care how do you
react or respond when someone says
something to you negative or cuts you
off in a car or something happens in
life every day
that could potentially upset you do you
react do you respond do you do nothing
do you give them a hug i mean what is
the process for you the process used to
be angry david goddard scream at them
swearing at them yeah yeah pick a fight
that was the old me yeah the old me was
pick a fight go go do whatever
through this process of my life
when you get to this point i'm at yeah
and i still be in the car and i talk to
my fiance this this is jackass with
everything or whatever
i now know
that i can escalate a problem that's not
really a problem
i now now i have a
throttle
and that's through self-examination
is this a b is this a big deal
is this something i need to approach
with a level three
engagement of like
we're going at it right or just a level
two engagement
so now you have to be mature enough and
i'm really big on maturity because i was
never mature for so many years
with age and knowledge you have to bring
in maturity
age doesn't mean you're mature
it's going back in and say okay man look
i'm at a point in my life
what is smart
if i do this i i can see the future
i can see that if i do this this is
going to happen
i'm going to escalate this problem
is this warranted
there are some things that warrant me to
escalate a problem yeah yeah and that's
what i do now i take it through a
process rate yeah yes
it it goes on a rating program got it
the most important step we're ever
taking life
is our next one
but a lot of us get our feet stuck in
concrete
we get our feet stuck in concrete
because we're afraid
to make enemies
we're afraid to speak with our mind
we're afraid of being in that group of
people
and when you walk away
we're afraid what they might say behind
your back
all that fear
clouds your brain clouds your thinking
one thing in life you're gonna always
have haters embrace them
if you can walk up the water
trust me your hands are safe
you can walk on water because you can't
swim
learn one thing
shut the [ __ ] noise out
embrace the fact that people don't like
you it makes you doing something right
stay hard
stay in the fight if you can dream
and not make dreams your master
we all have dreams
i had it when i was younger
so i figured
the best place to make those dreams come
true
are in isolation
so i walked into isolation
as dave the goggins
but i walked out of isolation as
guidance
where you become a savage
is in isolation
when you train for a big mma fight
or just a boxing match
you don't stay
outside of isolation you go in isolation
and that's when your mind changes that's
when your focus changes your dedication
changes don't use this time to up your
mind use it to grain strength
gain focus
isolation is the key
to strengthening your mind come on
savage how do you feel about letting
others in on your goals and and and
having like external pressure to hold
you accountable
no there's no external pressure that's
best
no you know what i mean but i think
other people oh yeah yeah it no it's
important to have circles
it's important to have like like i talk
about man like like that big rabbit hole
of bad people that you want to get away
from like if you're drunk and you want
to stop drinking
you got to get away from those people
you want to build this nucleus around
you of people who are saying
it's not okay to sleep in today
we gotta get after it hey let me see
your journal you're supposed to be
running five miles today you only ran
three
you got to have those people some people
need those people
and it's important but you want to get
to the point in your life it's real
important that you hold yourself
accountable and those people start to
fade away because you now got it
you want to be that person because
they're not always going to be there to
hold your hand your mind has the
ultimate tactical advantage over you
it knows what scars you
it it it knows your fears it knows your
insecurities and it protects you which i
talked about the 40 rule in my book
the 40 rules all about the brain has the
tactical advantage over you it knows and
it keeps you away from all that that's
why it says don't jump out of an
airplane don't go in the ocean where
there's sharks it's a protective
mechanism don't go back to the place
where your dad beat the [ __ ] out of you
in your mind don't go back
the brain protects you
but protects you so much
it doesn't allow growth
so the brain is an amazing thing but the
brain controls you you must control it
you must take power over your own mind
or your mind will guide you into all the
soft spites soft places that your brain
wants to live in your brain has enough
information it doesn't want to go
through that process of
of mind hardening doesn't want to do
that i gotta remember what time i gotta
be here what time i gotta be there this
is where i wanna stay i'm peaceful and
wants to stay very peaceful away from
scarring i think we're all an underdog
i think i think the top ceo on the
planet earth still has that doubt yeah i
don't give a [ __ ] where you're from kobe
bryant michael jordan the best on the
planet we're all underdogs
whether you're underdog because you put
yourself there to be hungry or just a
real life underdog we're all an underdog
and so this this is about
the mind and people
discovering the mind their own mind and
one thing i know is we all have an
equation we all have an equation like
you know i'll talk about three point you
know 3.14 is pi
there's different equations to figure
out different kind of you know
mathematical problems we as human beings
are mathematical problems
i cannot give you a book
for every [ __ ] body in this world
that's from my book even though it's one
book it's tailored to
the individual
it's not like you do these five steps
you're good
no i'm helping you figure out your
equation
because it's different my equation's
different from your equation what's
going to make you tick what's going to
make you go the distance what's going to
make you go to that spot in hell and say
i love this spot
it's okay
that's what this book does it helps you
figure out your 3.14
helps you figure out your mathematical
equation and say oh because once you
figure out the equation in any math
problem
you no longer fail man you got it
figured out and in times of need
even the hardest person forgets how
badass they are
so
i've been through a lot of my life
when you're going through a hard time
right now
you forget all the hard you endured
so the cookie jar is a reminder
that oh
i can get through this hard time right
now but you gotta take a second or two
to reach into the mental cookie jar
let's say it's a fortune cookie but in
my mind my mom used to buy these cookies
now in the cookie jar and there's an
oreo or chips or whatever that's where i
got the cookie jar from
but you got to open up and say okay man
i was in three hell weeks
and i got through two of them you know i
was in ranger school i i endured being
called [ __ ] i i saw these beatings i i
you know my mom's soon to be husband got
got murdered i saw all these i saw a
little kid's head get ran about all
these things i endured alone
i have to remind myself of the strength
and the power that i have that it's in
me it's just a reminder of how badass
you are in hard times because you know
we just forget
that that bad time consumes our mind and
we forget who we are speaking of
making that list accepting where you're
at so that you can address it
in the book you talk about like what the
things are that you're going to be doing
you're going to be putting the list
together how do people go about using i
don't know if it's the accountability
mirror how do they go about addressing
each of those issues okay
so
let's say the first one is
you're not the smartest person in school
i had that issue
so my big thing was how i addressed that
problem was
how to sit down
each thing that is wrong with you has to
be a focal point
you can't look at this gigantic list
since i gotta change all the my god this
is crazy
no
you take off the first one i want to be
smarter for me that was my thing i have
to i have to become more intelligent
i have such a severe learning disability
man i can't retain
i had to now get that one thing
and then strategize in that one problem
how can i do this i'm not gonna learn
like you i'm not gonna learn like
anybody else how am i gonna figure this
out so i then figured out okay
where are my strengths here where my
weaknesses in learning all right man
how am i going to do this and i figured
out
a way to do it
by this strategizing so how i learn
to this day if i have a big manual to
study
i will have to get a bunch of spiral
notebooks
from the from the daggone store
and each page
i have to write each page out maybe 10
times
so there was a thousand page dive manual
that i got 18 months before i went to
dive school
most people
i'm not smart i'm a ghost if i can pass
this test i realized hang on a second
i'm not smart
how can i get past this how can i get
through this obstacle i need to get i
need to acquire this book 18 months in
advance because it could take me 18
months to write down
each page over and over again to then
put it to memory so when the question
came up
i'd written that question so many times
down in that in on you know on paper
that i can recall okay page 71 was where
i remember seeing this
and i can recall it that way
and that's how i did it so you got to
strategize on each problem you have in
life
slowly break down that problem don't
think about all the problems you have
just one at a time
and before you know it you fix all these
problems but you cannot focus on all of
them just on the one thing at a time i
believe in a higher power don't know the
names don't know where it's coming from
don't anything like that but i believe
that
this power
and visualizing me real quick
let's say it's a man up there or a woman
whatever and they have a chart
and when you're born
they say david goggins
born february 17th 1975 at 6 00 am
they write the chart down because they
can see everything they know exactly
where you're supposed to be
they know what you're supposed to be
you die you go to so-called heaven
you arrive at heaven i'm 300 pounds
i retired as an eco-lab guy which is
okay just a job whatever
i go up there and god
looks at me and he shows me my chart
and my chart on there says you're
supposed to be a navy seal
you're supposed to weigh 185 pounds
you're supposed to be one of the
smartest people on the planet this this
all this you see this
and now you're in heaven you made to
heaven but you're like god dawg i was
supposed to live that life
i was supposed to live that life and
then you find out that the reason why
because we all think that if we pray on
it if we do this if we do that whatever
if we don't work we just whatever it
could magically happen for us
no
i believe that when i'm all said and
done with my whole job is to outwork the
chart
whatever the chart says about me the
all-knowing power up there i want to get
up there and say him look at me and say
i know everything
i didn't
see this
i didn't
see this
i want to feel that i want to get to the
other end of this
world
and however i'm being judged
whoever's judging me to look at me and
say i did not
no i had you at 185 had you did this but
all this other i was riding as you were
living it
i want to
i want to find
more all i can
and in that
second
you have to dive in that
to find more
because if you're not willing to go in
there and face yourself
you're not going to find anything
you can live right here on surface man
right here on surface
so if there is an ending to this world
and there is somewhere to go and there's
a judgment
you're gonna get there and you might see
a chart
and that chart may tell you who the you
should have been
and now you get the rest your life to
think about that man i could have lived
a much better life you become complacent
you become very civilized in life
you know the worst thing that could
happen to a person you become civilized
when you get to that point where
you believe that you've arrived
when you
my god man
i'm up there near michelle obama on my
book
i've done it man mm-hmm
i'm good you can coast i can i'm good
you don't have to do her dude you played
your man card i'm doing i want to be a
wildland firefighter man i retire from
the middle i ain't got i gotta go out
there and dig fire line for three miles
i'm 43. i've done it you should just be
flying first class everywhere everywhere
doing speeches and getting paid crazy
cash laying in a hotel kicking it man
and that's exactly when it's over
that mindset right there to me is death
i'm not saying you can go as hard as you
did when you were 20
or not 43
but there's a new bar that you must
always set in your life
and once you become complacent
and you become civilized you've arrived
you're no good for anybody
sometimes where the mind gets
overwhelmed
and you cannot slow it down
but by these these certain tools are
developed by not allowing your mind to
get away from the moment
you cannot you have to think about the
exact moment that you're in
but i saw when i was younger
the moment became too big
when it became too big i spazzed out and
i would quit
but now i don't think about even like an
hour from now i'll be eating i don't
even go there ah because then your mind
goes oh
no
we must embrace this because now
there's you have to be a leader in this
moment it's not about you just getting
through it
i had six guy i had five guys and six
including me in my boat crew now is the
boat crew leader
so now another trick is this
if you don't think about yourself
there's no pain
which can also lead to pain later on in
your life but in these moments when
you're struggling if you are a true
leader and you're worried about your men
or women beside you
your mind doesn't care how cold you are
anymore your mind's only worried about
taking care of the men and women beside
you so i started realizing man if i take
care of these cats to my left and my
right in the worst moments
my mind is no longer thinking about
you're miserable david goggins get the
hell out of here think about
how is john how is andy how was sam how
was pete
hey how are you guys doing you're not
thinking about me i didn't have any
drive i'm gonna go be a navy seal what
kind of stupid is that 300 pounds
there wasn't like a drive to go be a
navy seal i was an insecure lying kid
afraid
i had to
look in my insecurities
and in my fear and find drive in that
we're all looking for passion
passions all around you
you have a whole a whole sack of it all
around you it's your insecurities all
that sh
you gotta dive deep in that all this
it's all in there
all the energy and fuel you need is
right in yourself
it's all there you got a lot of stuff to
do to overcome
and you know that's where i found it i
found it right there among insecurities
i found drive in my own insecurities
and that's that's the most powerful
thing in the world when you can find
drive in your own doubt
fear insecurities
you become very unstoppable to do that
take a different vantage point in life
when you are in the hell
you can't see the beauty of being in it
when you're in it
get on top of that mountain top in your
mind guess what that mountaintop and
look down in what you're doing
you can see a whole different world and
that world is beautiful but you got to
get a different vantage point
in this in the suck
don't be in it
spiritually get out of it
get that soul
look down on what you're doing be amazed
by the process of where you're at now
and where you came from by no means am i
expert at this but i do know a lot about
living the sewer of life i've been
getting a lot of emails from different
loved ones about people who have killed
themselves my next door neighbor two
months ago she just killed herself tons
of veterans i know they killed
themselves i got an email two weeks ago
from a family member that an 11 year old
boy killed himself from people at school
bullying them one thing about life is
that people in life they are the
ultimate puppet masters they exploit
your weakness and they love to walk you
around life and own space in your head
one of the biggest ways to cut those
strings and walk on your own two feet to
your own destination in life
is to build self-respect self-esteem
self-discipline all those things stay
hard is not just about going
gym stay hard is about going that extra
step and you can't that's what builds
self-esteem and self-respect stay hard
your biggest enemy
your biggest
the most important
conversation
you will ever have in your in life
is the one you have with yourself
you wake up with it
you walk around with it you go to bed
with it eventually you're going to act
on it
whether you're good or bad
you have to that's why the whole thing
about this book i have it's about you
it is about you
is strictly about you finding who you
are so many people die
live a hundred years never know who they
are
never know who they are you have to look
in that mirror and know
this there's so much more in here man
because i can literally right now be a
300 pound guy spraying for cockroaches
still to this day if i did not look in
that mirror and say there has to be more
to this
this can't be it
and then willing to go into it dive deep
into it and give all i have to find it
there's no hack what do you think is the
biggest stumbling block that most people
face with this kind of journey
honestly is they have the woe is me
mentality
is too hard
life isn't fair
these things in life are are not easy
for me you you look to your left you
look to your right and you start to
judge yourself off other people
like if you're a female well she's
skinny and she doesn't work out as hard
as i do and
everything starts to corrupt your mind
you start to look around too much at
other people what they're doing and that
starts to corrupt your own dialogue
we are judging ourselves against too
many people
you have to judge yourself against
yourself
and that's the one thing i started
learning man this in the race against me
and rich roll
this race against david goggins and
david goggins alone
and once you can silence all that
all the outside interference and things
that are attracting your mind to
everything
you can then start to grow and realizing
i'm stressed out for no reason
this is my own little race
this is my own timeline
and this is how i'm going to run it
let's say for instance we have a family
let's say we're all a big family here
all three of us all four of us are a big
family and every morning i'm getting up
training for a 200 mile run
and you see me get at four o'clock in
the morning
and all you are sleeping and by time i
get done running my 30 you come i come
home just getting up how are you going
to feel about yourself
a lot of times when you're overachiever
and you have people that's what talk
about the mediocrity thing a lot of our
family members a lot of our friends
they're mediocre there's always those
couple of guys who are uncommon who want
to be better but you make that mediocre
mother feel like
whether it's your mom your dad whoever
you make him feel horrible i've been
there i'm speaking from experience when
you get somebody around you man who's
trying to be better and you don't have
the drive that they have
it's a constant reminder of how
you are
you have to know that that's what it is
anybody in your court's not saying man
get after it brother i'm so proud of you
they have a problem with themselves
because all you're trying to do is
achieve more if that's a problem for
somebody
you have to look at them and say man
you really have a problem with yourself
huh i'm
in a search for a feeling
i'm not in the search for a trophy i'm
not in search for love not so much for
more followers on instagram or social
media
when i started this journey years ago
and i realized that i'm going to be
somebody and i'm searching for a feeling
a feeling of true victory for myself and
only myself the second i shut out the
whole world
and realized that one thing that i am in
this world alone
i'm fighting in this race by myself
yeah i'm all about people i'm all about
team i'm all about that
but i'm really all about right now and
in my life it was important for me to
finally realize stop being all these
fake people i used to be
stop being afraid there was no growth
until i cut myself down
to nothing
to the person i really was the real
human being and once i found out who i
really was
that's when i started growing i was
trying to build on top of a lied
foundation
you can't build a house in the
foundation so i had to get down to the
actual mineral soil of who i was and
that's when you can start real growth
so the other day i got an email from
this lady
she said she truly enjoyed my book but
as she read it
she thought i was just crazy
so after she read it she put the book
down and started living her normal life
just going back paying bills going back
to work complaining about
a few days later
she has time to think about the book and
it scared her
she thought well maybe this guy isn't
crazy
and that's what scared the most maybe
he's here trying to show us human
potential
what we're all capable of doing
a lot of people like to put titles on
other people who are doing extraordinary
things
it makes them feel better about
themselves give them a good idea free
card
i'm not crazy i'm just not like you
in sports there's a thing out there
called load management
a lot of us like to load manage our
lives
when you do that
you're gonna find yourself right at
normal
get off that stay hard is there
something that you want to be known for
the one thing that you want to stand out
through all of these accomplishments and
be remembered for um honestly
i honestly want to be considered one of
the hardest men to walk to planet earth
in the history of the world
and what i mean by hard i'm not talking
about the guy who does the most pull ups
the most sit-ups runs the most
just a person who's able to overcome any
adversity in front of him to figure out
a way hardness isn't about
all this physical [ __ ] man yeah it
helped me get to where i'm at
but all i was doing in the whole process
the process wouldn't be ripped it
wouldn't walk around my shirt off that
wasn't it i knew through the physical
challenges
through the physical suffering
my mind was getting stronger i was
literally doing that for a reason i had
a weak mind
all the rest just happened to come with
it i was trying to strengthen the mind
to handle
all the
all the judgment that's passed on me
perceived and not sometimes you make it
up in your own head
you know i i just want to be able to
handle all of that
everything physical mental
i want to be perceived as that like an
old school barbarian an old school guy
that's like god dawg man
nothing can hurt the guy which is why
the book is titled can't hurt me
i want people to have that mantra in
their life take that with you take it
everywhere you go in life
and if you believe that and you work
towards that callous in your mind
strengthen yourself
can't hurt me as strong
in any situation like when i was in buzz
they beat the [ __ ] out of you
i'd be the first one to give and say
can't hurt me
and they were beating the hell out of me
but you say that enough to you false
motivation becomes
real motivation after a while so i got
the vfw award for the
for the um americanism award
for military service and giving back
i'm as human as human can be
that's why what you see is what you get
um
at that moment when i was giving my
speech and i thank my uncle for being
there and i got to my mom
it wasn't just about her
it was
i i i know what she went through i know
what i went through and we got knocked
down so much
i had a moment in front of all these
great american heroes
where i had a chance it was like so fast
it went through me like like lightning
of i can't believe
i'm here
i can't believe i'm getting an award
like this
that
that kid who was in the fetal position
the majority of his life
and so much the fact that my body my hip
flexors are tight to this day
that even though i was standing erect
my mind was in the fetal position
and when i looked out amongst all those
people
it was a sense of pride
that
i can't even
i can't even explain it's the moments of
three hell weeks it's the moments of
in that room by myself studying for
hours and hours and i was trying to
catch up with all the kids who are above
me
it's just those moments
like the real raw moments of life
that was like boom hit me
and we're gone but i was like i did that
i overcame this you know it's like this
is power behind all that
and
that's the feeling
i was looking for in my life i found it
wasn't money it wasn't fame it wasn't
awards
it was that feeling i have right now
the feeling i'm about to break down
but it's not of like oh my god i'm upset
it's like i worked myself
so hard
that i turned
a person this
into this
right here not off of reading a book off
a theorist
off of going to work on myself and
saying i don't know how to do this
but i know that to get over there that
inside
i gotta grind myself into a confined
powder
and i did it
i did it all for sure will
and
very few people will know how that feels
to get up every day or five days a week
whatever when it's snowing shiny not not
shiny not not comfortable and to go in
the gym and work out when you don't want
to go to the gym it is not fun if you
don't see results in the first two days
of the first week i'm done that's the
mentality of most people the struggle is
too real we're not patient
we like in a world where you can google
the best restaurants around me right now
no one is patient and for you to lose
weight for you to stop drinking if you
wherever the hell you're going through
it takes a lot of patience a lot of time
and a lot of pitfalls a lot of plateaus
you can hear so many plateaus if you
don't know how to get around that
plateau
it's not going to happen fast
yeah everybody wants the hack yeah
everybody wants to have there is no hack
man
there's no hack well my morning routine
is every day i get up and running
every single day because why i hate that
the most
so that is why we share that feeling yes
i hate that the most so
you have to do something that sucks
every day
because why once you overcome the suck
oh
now you're powerful you've overcome
yourself already so now you're ready to
battle
i go to the gym about four times a week
but my biggest thing i do
is my nighttime routine
i stretch out anywhere from two to four
hours every night for the last five it
used to be a lot longer than that
and i talked about in my book why i
started doing this thing but i had
through my whole life as you see i was
using my fight-or-flight muscle i was
under severe stress as a child growing
up my job whatever a lot of stress
just sitting down right now raw using
our psoas muscle your hip flexor muscle
and i'll give you a two second on that
that muscle attaches to your t12
and
about five or six years ago i got really
really sick
doctors give me all kind of hormones
take this take this take this
and it's in the book real good so i
won't go deep into it now
but i laid back and i literally said you
know what i'm dying
the doctors can't figure out what's
wrong with me my blood tests were coming
back fine
i just like my i can't even run a block
i went from around 205 miles i came
around a block i'm in my bed sitting
there
and i started realizing i had these
humongous knots
on my hip flexors
and back in my head
and i said i'm just done so i started
slowly stretching out i couldn't do
anything
over a period of a couple of years
i got off this medication that
medication i was in like 15 i was on
several medications now i'm on one
and honestly i what i believe no doctors
have said this is what happened to you
i was literally so tight i was cutting
off blood supply in different places in
my organs
the more i opened up my body so now i
went from running 8 30 mile on a
training run to now running a 7 15 to 7
minute mile on training run
it's the same heart rate
and it's not because i'm trained any
different
it's just because my body my body's
opened up and it's allowed my blood flow
so every night i stretch out and it's
truly i have to be wound so tight like i
couldn't sit in this chair for this long
i'd like i'll get i could get out of
here man give me i go
it's totally changed my whole
perspective of life
it's changed everything so stretching
out yoga all those things has put me to
a whole different state of mind and i'm
the healthiest i've been in my entire
life my purpose right now is to continue
i used to have a wash rag when i did
this
and you know how you take a shower you
have a wash rag and a cloth and you uh
you're sitting there and you're just
lathering up and before you hang your
rag up you want to get all the water to
come on it and you know get all that all
you know all the suds out of it you want
to ring it out and you want to hang it
up
so my big thing is when i live my life
i want to make sure that when i'm dead
and gone that i ring that wash rag out
and that rush rag is my soul and i also
believe that we're going to end up one
day meeting a maker if you believe in
one
and i believe that maker knows
everything about you
everything about you one's else could be
here is talking to you knows everything
but you also have a choice to make
you have a choice to make we have
choices and the one thing that scares me
to death in my life is getting to heaven
and
not being what i'm supposed to be and i
believe that god has a chart
and he looks at the chart and he puts it
in front of you and you get to heaven
and he says hey this is what you're
supposed to be and one of my biggest
fears in life
was to see that chart
and not have every block checked off
you know i want to make sure that i'm
constantly pursuing whatever it is i'm
pursuing just to be the best i can just
constantly grinding
myself into a fine powder if you want to
be great you want to be best forever at
what you do
you could be misunderstood by everybody
because you're going to be so [ __ ]
obsessed and so driven to get there
that's what it takes that's the truth it
takes every second of your life anybody
says balance yeah balance is important
for a lot of people it is but if you can
go to that edge where people do not like
you don't understand you question
everything you can do
you you've arrived
when you are misunderstood to the point
where people think you're psycho and
you're nuts and you're this and that why
are you in the gym at one o'clock in the
morning you just got through doing a op
for 13 14 hours after ranger school man
at the gym was wrong you will never
understand what is wrong with me
and that's why i'm so glad you don't
because i'm in the right spot when
people don't understand you anymore
you're in that spot
of obsession and drive where people like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this guy
i don't want to talk to you man because
you're not going to get it
you're not going to get it boom i want
you to get it yeah i want you to get it
and people wonder why am i not achieving
more
it's because once you m all of us once
we achieve something
we celebrate for a long
years
time and we wonder why don't i have
drive anymore where is it all at
if you don't develop a routine
of suffering and suffering it's not like
go out and kill yourself every day it's
being uncomfortable yeah
that keeps you hungry every day if you
live in your victories for so long and
say i'm gonna go challenge myself for 30
days or for two weeks or one dish run
this one marathon
it ends i did one marathon
okay
that's why it leaves you
it leaves you because you haven't set up
the next obstacle obstacles is how you
grow you must continue to have friction
friction is where growth is at with no
friction there's no growth you have to
be on a constant reminder almost like
how you put a reminder on your phone 15
minutes you got this that has to be in
your brain
you've done too much
stop
and what happens in life is that we
start to see our lives becoming so
successful
we're making money we're doing this
we're doing that i went more i went more
i push harder i'm all about pushing hard
don't get me wrong obviously i'm all
about it
but to push as hard as you can
you have to be mindful of the machine
that's pushing
it is going to end up dying
and then it takes years to get it back
so you lose that time totally that time
is gone
you know i lost five years of i could be
crushing it
where now i'm just now back to crushing
it realizing god man i learned the hard
way let's believe sometimes one way to
learn so i just finished the leadville
100 mile race
tough race went through all the ups and
downs
there's two kind of mindsets
you have um
under load under load under stress
one mindset's a brittle mindset
and that brittle mindset gives you all
these ways out oh
i don't need to finish the race
i can come back next year
i want to drop out because things aren't
going right
you also have a savage mindset the
sadness mindset is this
like in a house a house you have these
low bearing walls
some people aren't really educating low
bearing walls doing remodeling to the
house
they tear the low bearing wall down the
house crumbles
that's a brittle mine the savage mine
when things are going bad guess what
they do
quitting's out of the question
all they think about is how the am i
gonna get through this
there's no quitting it's just getting
through and thriving not surviving walk
me through a day in the life what's it
look like right now well i mean it's got
to be crazy
right now i i leave here and i fly out
to oregon
and i'll be in oregon with uh cameron
haynes we'll be getting out there for a
few days
a lot more podcasts a lot more
interviews but every day
every morning i get up i still get my
run in every morning
how do you structure the training the
training is basically structured off of
my schedule
so look at my schedule
and i said okay
um jennifer what do we have today
we have this at seven o'clock in the
morning
roger that that means i gotta be up by
four o'clock in the morning to run
that's how it works
that's how all my [ __ ] works so she lays
out the schedule of events two out you
just you just set it two hours earlier
she says it could take an hour to get to
rich rolls let's say we were at seven
o'clock today in the morning it takes an
hour to get to rich rolls with no
traffic okay let's let's block into hour
15 for rich roll okay we got that the
morning time i'm gonna run seven miles
this morning
i need uh 52 30 for that roger that put
in [ __ ] shower shave add that in
so the schedule dictates but
i have always just push it back right so
that means getting up at 1 30.
trust me roger that i've done that
several times yeah
several how much sleep do you usually
get
i i like getting seven to eight hours of
sleep nowadays i can do that but there's
times where the schedule says hey man
you're getting three hours and if that's
the case
right merry christmas you look in the
mirror and say wow i eat a little too
much no you're fat my exoskeleton is
larger than yours right no that's the
new one right yeah that's i mean you you
cannot say that to yourself no but see
you have to make a list yeah of the
things that you don't like to do
this list should be very long like if
you're like making calls yeah yep the
very first thing you should do
is start making a ton of cost
because why that begins to own you yes
you start to drive yourself this way
versus this way
but you'll figure out if you start
making a whole bunch of calls if you
like calling call a lot yeah guess what
happens you get over it you get over it
so what we do a lot is i heard a lot of
people say triple down on this triple
down on most of your strength no no no
no that works for a lot of things
but when you're afraid
and you don't have the courage
you have to triple down on your
weaknesses
and make that become where you start to
guide yourself okay i'm like calling
today i'm making a hundred calls we all
have a voice in our head
some of us are very spiritual some of us
are not but we all have this voice and
you're doing [ __ ] up this is wrong
don't do that
the more you don't listen to that voice
the further that voice gets away from
your head some people call it the holy
spirit some people call it gossip monks
whatever whatever you call it it's there
we all have it
it's the right or wrong voice
but the more we don't listen to it the
more that voice goes away the only voice
you hear is yourself
we all when the only voice here is
yourself you're wrong
there's a voice that guides you through
life
but sometimes it's guiding you in
direction that you don't want to go
that's usually the right place to go
it's that uncomfortable place so that
voice is always talking to me but we
don't listen to it and the thing about
it is like if you're in a in the kitchen
and you're cutting up cucumbers yep you
cut your finger
it happened 30 years ago that scar is
still there they say what happened to
your finger guess what you do i was in
the kitchen one day i was kind of
cucumbers you know cut my finger
you have those scars on your brain yeah
from life yep
but what we don't do is we try
to hide those scars we don't want to go
back and revisit it this is not as
simple as a cucumber you know you know
cutting a cucumber
so i started realizing that my life was
causing a whole bunch of scarring on my
brain
and i had to go back
while i wrote this book i had to go back
and really
break open that scar
and let it bleed
and that was a very painful journey for
me to go back because you know like
right now this is all surface learning
disability
call me [ __ ] well
it's all surface
a lot of people have dealt with that
stuff yeah very sad yeah but the way i
talk about in the book i'm i'm getting
your hand yep and i'm taking you back
there with me yeah as that kid in that
classroom who opens up his spanish
notebook he'll sit in the back because i
had a fourth grade reading level i'm in
the back
up my spanish notebook on the first page
they had a hangman drawing of me saying
[ __ ] we're going to kill you
very back i'm a sophomore in high school
nothing but white people i shut that
thing up and i leave class what's the
impact that you want to have on the
world
the impact i want to have in the world
is for everybody
to be able to face who they are i want
to have that kind of impact where you
can go on tv you can put your life on a
billboard you're not ashamed of who the
[ __ ] you are you're not ashamed of what
life made you what you helped life make
you all that all that bad that's now in
this big pot that's stirring
you're no longer ashamed of it
you realize we're all
stop judging yourself against other
people who have hidden it better than
you
it's all they've done they've mastered
better than you have and now they're
flipping it back on you and saying
you're
i want you to realize that this world
life
is one
big head game
and once you learn to play the head game
it's no longer a game anymore at all
you can start living your life it's easy
to look at you and that guy's that guy
is lit up on anger and resentment
back in the day so i gotta say i've
never said this before i was actually
telling my fiance this the other day
people think anger was my fuel
just so yeah anger can be a fuel
anger got me
to look into things to become better i
want to show him but i'd tell you one
thing when you're suffering
and you're
at the wit's end and you want to quit
that anger is gone brother well it's
also not a sustainable feeling
your mind is thinking about let's get
out of here so i realized this angry
i didn't think about my dad beat me up i
think my kids call me [ __ ] i think
about him
i thought my man
water is cold as balls man i get the
[ __ ] out of here
so i realized anger was no fuel for me
it may have got me to say i want to be
somebody
anger got me caught up in some serious
ego trips man i uh stuttered real bad
severely bad
fifth sixth grade fourth grade horrible
had like my hair would fall out white
splashes over my skin
horrible horrible anxiety
so
me talking about myself as much as i am
on stage on podcast
i'm still overcoming you're still
battling because it's comfortable for me
to say i'm off to sort of meet you don't
talk to me i'm good go back to being my
hermit
this is very uncomfortable so i'm
constantly coming outside my comfort
zones and doing this stuff now sharing
my story with people as much as i can
buddy of mine calls me the other day and
says uh he's having trouble running past
eight miles
this is a guy who can run 30 miles any
time of the day
so tell me to come out to my house
and we'll get some runs in so he comes
out he goes mad i'm telling you i can't
run past eight miles but i realize in
his life he's had a new kid
more responsibilities at work all this
stuff he's not thinking about this i am
so i take him out for a run
we get 30 minutes into it how far are we
going goggins
i ain't telling him
get an hour into it i ain't telling him
hour and a half into it didn't tell him
so soon he shuts up
we run three hours the guy does fine
next day we go out there he's able to
run 20 miles again
so this is what happened to him his
circuit breaker blew our minds are very
similar to circuit breakers
when they blow you got to figure out
what it is
sometimes you just add it too much to
your plate go back in your mind and
figure it out what's the best advice
you've ever received
i didn't receive any advice
and that's the thing about it when i
grew up i just didn't receive any advice
my my family was in such turmoil
that the best advice i received is for
myself
and and that has to be to study yourself
all the bad because the good's already
there you need to study that study study
the bad stuff about yourself and learn
from that and grow the truth of the
starting line
we live in a world that's very
unauthentic
so who are you
what do you stand for what do you
believe in
you know a lot of people don't like what
i say
a lot of people hate that cuss
a lot of people
[Music]
[Music]
make sure
that you have something to say
say it
social media nowadays is one of the
biggest
forms of being fake in the world
people buy likes
people buy friends people buy comments
all
this make sure in life
you do what you have to do
say what you have to say and live the
life you have to live
don't walk around being a fake human
being
don't be scared to be who you are
stay hard our mind
wants to protect us
the mind is like honestly it has a
tactical advantage over us
it knows our deepest darkest fears or
insecurities it knows where we start to
feel
uh
we start getting that doubt creeping
that says hey man you know what man
maybe this isn't good let's go back home
to the wife let's go back home to the
kids this is not comfortable so in that
moment the mind directs us it's a
protective mechanism it saves us for
doing bodily harm
or
or it really saves us from discovering
that the mind's like i want to be in
charge of you
i don't want you to be in charge of me
so it tells you let's just stop right
here
but once you start breaking through that
barrier
and start breaking down that governor
the governor that you've put in your
mind
because we forget we
are in control of our mind
we believe it's the other way around
no
we put in our minds what we should do
but we believe our mind is telling us
it's giving us all this feedback
we have to reprogram it and tell us no
no no we're good
we're good we go this sucks but it's
okay when you really sit back at your
life and you are in that dark room
and you're looking at where you started
from
and you tell yourself
ah man my mom is this way my stupid step
dad got murdered my dad beat the [ __ ]
out of me
i can't read and write to say my soul
i've lied about it to everybody i've
cheated on all these tests
my god man
and then you put a goal
in your mind
how are you gonna feel man when you
accomplish this goal coming from that
[ __ ]
coming from the hell you came from
a lot of people start from a good
starting point they have a good
foundation what if you can surpass all
these
we have everybody who was way up here
started up here and you had you started
with no legs you had to grow legs to
even start walking and then crawling and
then running and then you start passing
people with all this given to them
i had to use all this negative
that was making me weak and horrible as
a person
i had to use this as the power that now
fueled me had to flip it on his head and
say hold up
this might be exactly what i need
the darkness
is exactly what i need it's how you look
at your situation
and i was looking at it all
if you're willing to suffer and suffer
and go back in the grind that internal
dialogue you have with yourself when
you're in misery and you're
uncomfortable it's a real
scary
unfiltered no lying dialogue between you
and yourself
and people know exactly what i'm talking
about when you're in a bad spot in life
and your mind is saying all kind of
that's who you really are
that's the real you no rocky balboa
moments going on up there
like hey you know it's around 14. that's
come on we got this no it's like this
i'm out of here man this is crazy
that's where the growth happens when
you're able to stay in that moment
and talk to yourself talk yourself back
into the suck
of wherever you're going through and you
start stripping those layers away but as
you're stripping those layers away
you're building calluses
over top
in your mind
that's where the growth starts to happen
is when you have to force yourself to
stay in it
you can't you can't leave it
i'm the only person in history of the
military
who has ever gone through air force um
tactical air control party training
um army ranger school whereas arnold man
um in three whole weeks yeah so only
person ever do that but the reason why i
did it was when i was a young kid i
considered myself very weak
very weak and as i started developing
this
indestructible mental toolbox
because what i realized was
the things i was like most afraid of i
cowered from
i had to start facing these things and
becoming an expert at the things i
feared the most yeah i was afraid of my
own mind my mind would get off on these
crazy places of what was me
my my internal conversation wasn't great
yeah so i had to start mastering it
once i started mastering it in the
horrible place i was at i was literally
i considered myself the worst person
ever alive
that was my conversation but once i
started mastering my own life i started
realizing my god man this was in me yeah
i was a 300 pound fat guy now i'm 181
pounds or 90 pounds there was i'm going
to go through all these hell weeks so i
started realizing the capabilities of
the human soul in the human mind as i
have the ability to see the end before
the beginning even begins
and what that means is i know that to
get to the very end i can see it right
now so before i went to butts and i was
losing weight
i saw myself walking across the stage
at 191 pounds that's what i had to get
to to get into the door
i saw myself
six months a year later whatever's going
to take me to do i saw myself walking
across that stage getting that
certificate of graduation from buds
and i was able to be there
at 300 pounds
and that feeling that i was nowhere near
that feeling i was able to put myself
there
a million times every day that feeling
of like my god that is going to feel
amazing
that's what made me suffer
that's what allowed the pain to be real
and say this is worth it i want to feel
for this next 18 months it took me 18
months to finally become a navy student
if i'm you know just get through butts
18 months it's six months took me 18.
that's what woke me up every morning was
i'm gonna put myself through this much
pain and suffering for a few
seconds
so it is
a few seconds of joy
it's so worth it man i said people don't
get so i'm able to put myself at the
finish line even though i have no finish
line
but at the finish line of an event
before i even start to
say how are you going to fill it into
this that's why i i've been able to
put myself in cold water put myself in a
hundred mile race
millions of times before i've done it
and i'm able to go through the race and
see i'm going to feel at my 50. almost
to the almost to the exact
exact feeling right so when it comes up
it's no surprise no surprise i've
already done this a million times sealed
training became pretty hard and a lot of
guys weren't getting through it so they
designed a sil pet prep program
like a boot camp for the boot camp
that's right yeah and it was two months
in my last two years before i retired
from the military they sent me there to
train these kids wow to get ready for 15
19 20 years young kids
so when they get to navy silk training
man they were physical studs
they were running swimming i mean they
were they were hybrids wow
but they get the buds and the same
amount of people would quit why is that
this is why
we were training bigger stronger faster
quitters
hmm
it's not about not the mind that's right
we weren't diving into the sewer
everybody's got a story
we don't share it on social media
we share our nice life on social media
we have we all have a dungeon i'm just
willing to talk about mine yeah most of
us don't really talk about it i want to
talk about my dungeon
i wasn't getting into the dungeon of
these guys minds
i wasn't building that so-called mental
toughness mental toughness isn't
something that you
sample
is something that you live in every day
so when something hard would happen to
these kids like in hell week
it would
draw on something that made them very
insecure
and they look for comfort
whenever hardness comes and you don't
know what it is it may be different for
you than this for me
but you go back to your insecurities
and then when you go back to
insecurities you then look for comfort
within those insecurities
and we all look for that cookie that
your mom used to give you when you were
sad when you were sick
we look for our wife or our husband we
look for comfort
it's in those moments
you must retrain your mind
to think differently in hell
i wasn't training them to do that
why weren't you training i wasn't
training myself yet because at that time
i was doing what i was told
these guys needed me a standard physical
standard a physical standard
the physical standard is not what they
need to meet it's a mental standard you
must meet in life in the book you tell
people to make a list
of everything working against them every
real valid excuse right why do you have
him do that
there's a lot of power in that list
so
in that list of
who you are what makes you [ __ ] up all
these other things it goes back to once
again accepting
you have to first accept it before you
can fix it
a lot of people walk around oh man i'm
good
i'm good
no you're not
you have to accept what you're not
you have to and people don't want to do
that
that's the only way you can fix it
you have to accept it first before you
can go on the journey a lot of folks
never even start the journey man
they never start to join because they
live in this fake life
that who they want to be
they act like they are but they're not
because they haven't fixed all this
stuff yet you got to fix this first
before we can start our journey in life
so that's why i have them make this list
you fix these problems now your journey
can begin because you no longer care
about how people are judging you
when when you care more about how
someone's judging you you're going to
stay right there i understand that you
lost some friends in operation red wings
so how did what did that feel like to
you being that i went through i was in
three hell weeks i knew a lot of the
guys i knew every guy that died on the
operation
so the story touched me so much i wanted
to find a way to raise money for their
families
so i found a special operations warrior
foundation if you're a special operator
and you die
it will give 100 tuition to your son or
daughter to go to college
great foundation
so now i gotta find something to do to
raise money for it so i started googling
all these different races i found the
bad water 135.
so it's 135 mile run through death
valley in the summertime
had no idea about ultra running i'm 250
pounds i'm a big meat head
so here i am
calling the guy up on wednesday he goes
hey you gotta qualify for this race i go
how you qualify
he says you gotta run a hundred miles in
24 hours or less
i'm like is that even possible i haven't
run over 20 miles the whole year yeah
going through buzz i started realizing
that you had to learn to control your
mind in these situations
so at mile 70 when i was in the worst
shape my entire life
i was able to draw on
being calm i never thought my wildest
dreams i could be a navy seal
it's until you opened your mind
open-mindedness creates that we all shut
down our mind like for instance
when i broke the pull-up record
everybody around me who heard the
pull-up record was thousand and twenty
pull-ups
that's the first thing they did oh my
god
four thousand and twenty-four hours or
yeah it's four thousand twenty pull-ups
in 24-hour period yeah yeah
the first thing i did versus closing my
mind you're like oh my god that's
crazy i went and got a penny
how many is that every minute exactly
every hour every second instead of
taking life and making out to be
this grandiose thing start breaking it
down
start breaking it down
and
most of us
we live in a box
and we don't want to go outside that box
at all ever
outside that box
is all these possibilities of life
what we do is we shackle our mind we are
a prisoner in our own mind that this is
all i can do this is all i'm good at
and we
we we take away the possibilities of you
could be this you could be that yeah you
could be all these things
and i never thought at 300 pounds i
could be negative wow so if my mind was
shackled
me and you would never meet
there'd be no book right there'd be no
book right
there'd be nothing
so
what people understand is that they live
for themselves not knowing that you have
the power within yourself to change
millions of lives yeah by facing life it
doesn't go from like one morning i'm
this way the next one i wake up and
presto the you know five steps to
greatness no
it ain't that brother you read my book
this is hard work it's every day like
right now
i had to be honest with you man
i'm even shaking right now being on this
show i'm a big time introvert
how you address it is you face it
you face it every day you face it every
single day of your life
where you say okay like if you're fat
you need to lose weight
it's patience
it's patience in this fact of accepting
who you are right now i'm fat i don't
like myself
except in fact if you lose three or four
pounds
that's a huge accomplishment
you have to live in your own [ __ ]
world you cannot judge yourself that's
why social media all these things are
horrible you can't judge yourself off of
the so-called competition that we have
made up in our mind
the things that how people look how
people like how smart someone is this is
a race that you run completely alone
and you're all by yourself i had tons of
sticky notes all over my mirror it
wasn't like be better than john or be as
fast as whoever okay david yesterday you
did this today our next goal for the
week is this
so i had a year goal
weekly goals daily goals hourly goals
and the big goals i lied a lot growing
up
i wanted to be accepted
one goal was let's go one day without
lying
let's go one day and then when i would
lie to somebody i would say hey man
now go i had to go back now and
apologize hey man i lied to you you know
how hard it is to go back to somebody
say i lied to you
hey man you know what back there i lied
to you dude i i was really jacked up so
i figured out these ways of total total
accountability like right now i had to
run this morning before i talk to you
because why
that's what i'm about
i'm about mind mad body fitness
a lot of folks talk so much
about hey i'm going to change your life
i'm going to do this i'm going to do
that
are you accountable for what you're
doing are you accountable and i mean to
the t
for what you're saying
i am and that's where it started it
started with that total total
accountability of let's not lie today
let's tell people the truth
about who you are and when you can get
on and tell someone like i'm doing right
now exactly how [ __ ] up you are
that's the goal in life
to put your life on a billboard on the
busiest road in the busiest highway in
the world and say
this is how
i used to be i have to be very present
in everything i do like right now i'm a
rich role
i'm not thinking about
but rich roll and what the [ __ ] coming
out of your mouth right now
that's what that's what gives me a huge
advantage in life especially today in
this day and age with so much going so
fast and everybody wants to keep
everything going everything up and
everything i want to be the greatest you
know the greatest multitasker of all
time not me
if i put my hundred percent into what's
in front of me i will destroy it if i'm
out here just multitasking it i'm gonna
half-ass everything i do
so that's it is the most important thing
awarded me is being focused at the task
at hand
there's so many times in life you don't
want to be doing what you're doing
you can't just quit
remember this this isn't a hobby it's in
the joke it's a lifestyle
so what you say to yourself is important
there's no [ __ ] coach there's no
trainer to keep you going it's only you
so think about this you've been working
your whole life to get a seat at the
table to see the tables you want to be
the best amongst all the best people in
your career field so you finally get
that letter it's steak lobster it's a
big dinner
everybody's showing up
dressed to the nines
make sure you show up soaking wet for
[ __ ] after working out hard tower on
your neck you respect the event
so make sure you put that towel over
that nice chair so you don't
the whole thing is this
don't say a word
stay uncommon amongst uncommon people
you're never done
don't stop when you're tired
stop when you're done stay hard the
reason why we go back to old habits is
because our goals are too lofty
we're not achieving our goals fast
enough
so what happens is you know what ah man
we're very impatient nowadays
for me
it was good i have a phone i was i was i
was out of this world by myself
it was a race against david goggins it
wasn't a race against god i don't look
good for this person or that person it
was me i got to change myself
so for me if i lost five pounds in a
week
i got a feeling i allowed myself to feel
proud of that
i didn't look i gotta lose 106 pounds
i'm like man i went from 297
now i'm
292. in one week man i'm i'm killing it
we don't we're not proud of ourselves
for the small
accomplishments what we need is we need
this monstrosity of the thing to happen
say i did it no
there's a process that you have to go
through and patience is the process
and if we don't have patience after a
week
i haven't lost 30 pounds and i'm done
i'm over it so that's why i found out
with people man they're not patient
enough to realize and to enjoy the
moment not living it
just enjoy it there's no finish line in
life but enjoy that moment roger that
man i lost five let me go 10 next week
so that's the whole thing about it
that's how people lose it you you get
the opportunity to become a navy seal
and then you end up going through buds
three times
it's like yeah merry christmas i got
lucky yeah i was very fortunate to go
through three times
and not in a sadistic way
in a life-changing growing way i found
out so much about myself through going
through that training three times and i
went through the hardest part of the
training three times
you know after the first so so first
phase is the crucible man
and that's where i was at for three
times i spent most of my time in buds
and first phase in the hell week in the
hell weeks
and being in that grind and in that
grind i got time to examine myself
i caught the live autopsy
and also examine other people because i
was really good about putting people way
above me because i was i wasn't
i was never nobody so for me to be on
the same stage as these
great wannabe navy seals and bus trains
like my god you guys are amazing i
actually got here with you all thank you
so much for allowing me into play
but as i was there for so long
i got a really good chance to sit back
because now the cold water is just water
now it's not a cold anymore your mind
starts to change they say get in the
water most people think about it for you
it became my life
so i started learning that if you start
to change your mindset versus it being
like oh my god this sucks
i became a professional bud student
so i wasn't going to leave until i
graduated so i started realizing if this
is my home this is what i am i had to
always reset the bar
i had to reset my new norm there always
had to be a new norm so one thing we
don't do is we don't have a new norm my
new norm is you get up every morning at
four o'clock and you suffer
this is your new norm
that became my new life
most people want to get out of it i said
no this is your new life this is who you
are
you your new norm is you wake up and you
suffer
and i started realizing if that's my
mentality
this [ __ ] ain't hard anymore
you're normal you wake up you get in the
[ __ ] cold water you're gonna be here
to this
done whenever they say you're out you
get out so my new norm so i i do that
now today my new norm now is
if i'm doing a 200 mile run your new
norm now man you are doing 200 miles
the roger that mentality that's it man i
don't i don't live on the surface of
anything yeah surface is what got me
where i was at it got me from 175 pounds
to 300 pounds telling everybody i'm good
i don't i don't give a damn i'm good
no
they're they're hollow words
a lot of us speaking hollow words i used
to speak in hollow words
i don't do anymore everything that comes
on mouth has substance is real
and
we all have these feelings in our bodies
and our minds and our souls
i act all mine
a lot of us who are afraid of something
we allow our minds to choose the path of
least resistance so we go a different
route
i'm afraid of something that's telling
me you must conquer that you must do
that
yeah you have to go that way
and most of us don't understand that
mentality
we go left and we wonder why we haven't
fulfilled something in our lives
it's because we continue to take the
journey that is mapped out
and how i look at is i i i talk in life
like
a lot of us in life want to take the
four-lane highway
that has road maps and all this other
stuff on it man it tells you where to go
gas stations
the next 10 miles up you're gonna see a
mcdonald's a crackle barrel yeah it's
the easy route very few of us want to go
to the right side a lot of us dream big
you you should dream big drinking big is
important
you know some of us will be doctors
lawyers dentists so much money you know
want to be in special operations so you
have this big dream you can see it so
clearly like it's right in front of you
you can go out and touch it but the
thing about it is somewhere if you dream
big enough somewhere down that journey
that dream becomes a
nightmare and what happens in that
nightmare start to have all these
questions like if you want to be a
special ops you may not be a great
swimmer you may just realize that i'm
not a great swimmer i'm not a great
runner you may start to fail tests and
all these questions start to flood your
mind why am i here i'm not good enough
trust me i know all about the questions
they will flood your mind if you do not
have the answers for them you will quit
the answers lie in the repetitions you
must not forget the repetitions you put
into trying to dominate the craft that
you're in today
always always embrace the suck adapt
this up a lot of us
don't know of a whole nother world that
exists
it's on the other side of suffering
once you
break these barriers that you have made
for yourself
like the mind is the most powerful thing
in the world in the world it is so
amazing that i used to be a 300 pound
guy and i thought that was it
could barely read could do anything and
now
that what was inside that person
was this guy that's in front of you
today that's how scary the mind is
and that's what i started realizing
through this journey
is that
once i got a taste of wow man i haven't
even cracked
i haven't even begun to crack what the
mind is capable of
and when i start realizing is on the
other end of suffering that's the real
growth of life because you realize how
the mind processes
and i talk about another thing called
theory and practice a lot of people are
theorists
they
these smart guys that read these books
man and they sit down they tell you what
the mind is supposed to do
and a lot of us listen to that it
becomes like this is it man this this
old man who has been studying the mind
forever
this is the cap that we have
by being a practitioner i went out and
realized
a lot of these guys are so wrong man
the mind has capabilities that are so
unknown and i found that through
suffering
and there's a whole other world on the
other end of that sometimes we can be in
such a bad spot in our lives
that the only answer
is to say
and go for broke
in my life
27 years ago i was in that spot
and this guy asked me a question
yesterday was a question jennifer he
asked if you're paying the price
physically now for what you put your
body through am i paying the price
so my answer is yes
i am
but what he didn't know was
literally
i stepped back at 297 pounds
looking the accountability mirror i saw
a reflection i didn't like
it wasn't so much the outside
it was a lot of the inside
so
that bothered me
and i was going to do whatever it took
to change that reflection
you got to find out what you want to do
to change the reflection accountability
mirror so one big thing is the
accountability mirror
you have to start with yourself
so what happened in my life
was we start to get i call it like the
rucksack a rucksack is a pack that you
carry in the military and you put all
your stuff in it your radios your food
your water all that stuff you have to
carry the military that's your rucksack
it's a backpack pretty much
as you're growing up
we all have a backpack most of ours
hopefully is empty
you know and what we put in it is all
the crap we go through in life
that's what is in the backpack for the
civilians and we carry it around with us
so what you have to start doing is
realizing that no matter where you're at
in life
i got called [ __ ] a lot my dad abused
me
you know learning disability stutters
immaturity insecurities self-doubt so
much crap on top of me
so much stuff i lied a lot to create
friends
so people so much stuff was in my
backpack
no one's coming back to help me
so it starts with that person in that
mirror
you have to realize you are on your own
now and whatever else you believe in i
don't care what you believe in but
on earth it's a very lonely journey
it starts with the accountability mirror
of looking at saying hey my dad who beat
the hell he's not coming back all these
things are coming back i have to face
myself
and you have to own
all those things that people may have
done to you now it's yours you got to
own it it's yours now to fix the
problems that people did to you it makes
no sense it's not fair
i get it but if you live in that what
was me mentality of guess what
my dad did this to me my mom just did to
me people who bullied did this to me
you're gonna always live right there
you have to figure out ways to move
forward because you're not coming back
it starts with the mirror i call it the
accountability mirror in the book if you
walk into any kind of
event
whether it be physical or mental if you
walk in with already putting that block
on your mind if man
this ain't going to happen people go how
did you want to hurt 35 miles to death
batting how did you run 100 miles with
no training
because i went into it not thinking i
can't do this man
i went into it with a strategy i had an
open-mindedness
so until your mind is open to the
possibilities
that i can do this
you would never be able to do it once
the mind starts to believe it can be
achieved it then only then does it start
to break down tactically
how we can do this
until then you're gonna always lose when
you're afraid of something you have to
master it
that's how you start to overcome it so
what i realized when i get to that point
where i want to quit everybody they get
the point they want to quit this is what
happens
the mind tells you
let's go home
let's take a warm shower let's get some
food this is not right this is that
if you cannot answer the questions at
that moment because your mind's gonna
start giving you all these questions
all these questions
and if you can't answer them
you're gonna quit what i realized when i
was going through budge ranger school
officer 100 mile race 200 mile races
pull up records
my mind would come creeping in like when
i was doing four thousand thirty pups at
two thousand pull-ups and my hands were
ripped open my mind said look brother
we've done all these other things you've
proven yourself you're good
if i didn't have the answer
to respond to my mind and say why i'm
here
why i'm doing this
you will always lose that fight you have
to have the response to what your mind
is going to tell you and another thing
about that is
self-talk
a lot of people have like these big four
on mental toughness all that crap
about self-talk
visualization it's true
but the thing about self-talking all
these things
they ask me what do you think about when
you're on mile 100 of a 205 mile run
what are you thinking about when you
realize you've run for 24 hours
and you have 24 more hours to run and
yeah another 105 miles what goes through
your mind
what do you say to yourself i want to
know
a lot of people think self-talk works it
does but it doesn't work
without the suffering
before your mind starts saying we need
self-talk so what i tell myself
is
i go back to the months and years of
preparation to get to that day
and i'm telling myself
the 3 30 in the morning and i'm looking
at my shoes and i want to go out there
and run 30 miles
i have to in that second in that moment
of this self-talk my mind said you got
to find more you got to find more i once
again calm down go back into my mind in
my cookie jar i call it and i had to
reflect back
on the [ __ ] i did to get here
and that becomes my self-talk self-talk
does not work unless it is real
most of us lie to ourselves in this self
it doesn't work
it has to be real it has to be something
that you've done to make it really work
what happened most is that if i would
have died at 300 pounds let's say i was
75 years old
i got to heaven and god has a chart like
that on everybody's life
god knows all let's say that
i don't care what you believe in doesn't
matter i'm not judging anybody let's say
my thing is god
you get to heaven i'm 300 pounds i sit
down as a cockroach terminator my whole
life
and we're sitting down just like this
you're god and i'm david
and he gives me that chart
and he says look at this
now look at this chart and on the chart
it has
all these different things
but my name's on it but these things
aren't me
i was gonna change the world i was gonna
i was gonna set records i was gonna be a
navy seal i was gonna be
all these things in the military that i
accomplished you're gonna get the vfw
award you can be honored here honored
there and i'm like god i was this isn't
me like it says david goggins
i was an ecolab guy i sprayed for
cockroaches and i'm 300 pounds i said
here i'm 185.
it says here i got a
a bachelors and the masters it says all
these things
and god goes no
that's who you were supposed to be wow
my biggest fear in life
is if there is a final resting place in
this world and there's a final judgment
and you talk to something much bigger
than you
i don't want to sit down and have a
conversation with someone
with something
that says you're in heaven
this is what you should have been on
earth
and
are you really in heaven now are you in
hell
thinking about how much i left on a
table for fear
for not willing to go over the wall and
over the next wall and over the next
wall so in my mind i believe that
and god knows all
at least i believe that
i want
god to be up there right now as we're
speaking
writing stuff down saying my god he
exceeded even my expectations
that's how i live my life i now know
that there is no cap
on the human mind
there's no cap
we cap it ourselves whenever i'm weak at
something wherever i'm scared of
something i master it
i was a weak my you know a weak minded
person so i mastered my mind and it
mastered my mind i mastered the human
mind and i realized why i no longer
judge people why i no longer put people
on a pedestal because we're off our own
way we all have demons
some people hide them better than other
people so i know we all have them but i
mean knowing that i know that most alpha
males are very fragile
very fragile they never want to see
another person
harder than them
especially in that kind of ego
attachment the ego is very strong ego
will flip every time
ego is serious
so if i can hurt your ego
i got you
so by me having such a fragile ego
growing up all this was my advantage i
was doing a live autopsy on how
i was
i was like hey this [ __ ] me up i better
tell people up too
so i started using all these different
tools and tactics to get instructors
heads
and taking souls that's what happened
man we're we're wednesday
freezing cold everybody's jackhammering
everybody's everybody wants to you know
everybody's just want to get through it
now jackhammers when you just can't stop
shooting you can't stop shivering you
know you're sitting there this
uncontrollably jackhammer and the
instructors take great pride in watching
you suffer
they do we're you know in a in a sick
way it's it's kind of funny you know you
know you were there once as a as a
student now you're an instructor but i
knew how would i be thinking if i was
instructed i would love seeing this
sadistic go on
but what would i what wouldn't i like to
see
i would hate to see
some guys just looking like this is just
another
day on the beach and go
yourself i would hate to see that
so they all want to think like when they
did it they were harder they were harder
yeah everybody's hearts i said you know
what man
it's time you all i can't fight you you
guys can be up all day long that's your
job and i love your job i love what you
guys are doing you guys making us better
but now
i want to take the tactical advantage
and i'm going to start with you so i got
my boat crew bill brown i had chris kyle
my boat crew right american sniper i had
a couple of hardcore
and everybody right now is kind of like
in their own world let's just get
through this man i can't wait till
friday so we can graduate how we can get
going
i said let's go ahead and have some fun
i said we're gonna start we're gonna
start
so
the evolution here was we've got through
with medcheck you know we're stripped
down to nothing and they're checking us
out making sure we're good you know
checking for pneumonia checking for
knees my knees all jacked up they're
giving me shots
and i was like the boat crew leader of
boat crew 2.
so i'm in the front of the boat i tell
our guys this we're gonna do the boat
was like on our heads so it was we're
supposed to lift the bolts up above our
head that's all you gotta do but when
you're this week
in this frazzer you're this tired the
boat's heavy so there's a thing you can
do when you do boat presses you can get
the boat like just toss it up toss it up
and catch it and that show is like
you're jacked up
so everybody's holding the boat and
they're shaking and they're both
starting to come down their head and all
the boat crews are all lined up and
they're
now i'm looking at that and i turn
around my brokers hey guys it's time to
take some souls they'd be like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about i said we're
gonna get i go you see like instructors
out here on their jackets and drinking
coffee and laughing and smiling
i want their faces to go straight up and
numb so we're gonna do this we're gonna
start boat pressing this
just take my lead trust me you'll get
energy from it
we started throwing this boat up in the
air catching the throw up and kiss and
we start yelling i can't hurt [ __ ]
bull crew too we're yelling our ass off
and we doing it and they make a stop
like like what the [ __ ] like to stop
i look at these instructors
and
their faces
literally look like someone like just
like took their soul out because i know
where their minds were like they were
thinking about themselves like what
just happened man i know me on wednesday
i couldn't have done that
how they doing it so the rest of the
time
going through hell week
it was like we just we owned it right
bro crew 2 we we won every single race
we were just dominating
and um it was a it was a strong boat
crew and
that's where
taking souls is uh there's a few taking
soul stories but that's one of them
there's energy all around us but we
think that we have to have it has to
come externally a lot of times we gotta
have like a tv in front of us watch
somebody listen to a podcast listen to a
great music a lot of times in life it's
quiet
and those are the times when you want to
run and hide
you got to be able to find energy
you got to make up games make up tricks
make up whatever you can to get to the
next evolution of life
so taking souls is just another way it's
not about hurting the person you're
against
it's about finding the tactical
advantage in every situation you
physically can
to get to the next you're trying to inch
further
to the goal line
you don't want to what is that line the
goal lines whatever it is for you for me
i want to get through hell week
i want to get the hell with with like
you know with my head up high being
strong i don't know what the goal line
is for everybody my goal has been very
different from most people but you're
trying to find energy and strength to
stay in the fight
to continue on until you get that second
wind
the second wind is coming whenever the
second wind may be for you it's coming
but what happens is we get so stressed
out
that the end is so far away
that we just can't find another
foothold or another handhold so we jump
off the cliff and we just fall well life
took me somewhere unexpected i'm
unprepared
um it's about six degrees out here and
i'm underdressed but guess what no one
gives a [ __ ] you gotta get them
sometimes life can really hijack your
mind when that happens to you you're all
your goals your ambitions everything is
out the window
in life we all go through different
things sometimes your girlfriend or
boyfriend breaks up with you guess what
get the over it they no longer want you
maybe you fail a test in school you
worked your ass off guess what you
filled the test get over it move past it
learn to not let life hijack your brain
at work you've been working your ass off
that new promotion you don't get it
someone else does maybe they kiss better
ass than you do guess what
get over it life will hijack your mind
if you let it don't allow all these
things to make you a lesser person you
must own your mind don't let life on
yours all that i went through in my life
to get here today it is tattooed
it is tattooed in my brain every day i
wake up
i am constantly
battling
that person that is like man you know
back in the day this happened to you man
you know like you got called [ __ ] so
many times and your dad beat it out of
you man and you know you you couldn't
read and it's dad going junior you're
all these things start to creep up even
now where you're at today
every day you're having to constantly
battle it's not as bad as it used to be
by any means right but that person is
still there
it's that person always lives that's the
that's the point about you have to
continue to always challenge yourself
every day the one thing i'm most scared
of in the world is is uh losing
losing touch with the the best thing in
the world is is your mind
your mindset how you can picture
yourself how you can focus how you can
drive how you can put yourself in so
many situations get out of it because
those headphones we listen to those
those phones that that we google to find
information there's so many situations
in my life where that's just not going
to help me
it's not going to help me and you're
able to just
turn that off
so fast because i know what's helped me
none of that stuff has ever helped me
none of that stuff's very helped me what
has helped me has been me alone getting
my together and being accountable for
who i'm not
and who i want to be i coach a lot of
people nowadays billionaires
who call me on the phone and say matt
i'm still missing some
it's because
they did what they were good at
and they had this beautiful family
two three houses cars everything has
everything to work on the outside
looking like my god man how can you be
unhappy
i walk around with the backpack with all
my stuff in here no car right and i walk
around
happiest person in the world have
nothing happy as hell it's because
i found out the whole key to life it's
not in all that
you have to face yourself so many people
live to be 100 years old and they die
miserable having everything
because they never examined i call it my
live autopsy
you never examine this
happiness peace
enlightenment it's all up here man
it's all up here
if i start talking like this people are
man you know
i don't know it's the truth man yeah it
is true it's all up here he's gonna be
willing to go and face it
and that's the hard part a private
school you don't need to have this
humongous gpa and also
what you need is the one thing i talk
about my book which is straight up
brutal work ethic
you have to be willing to outwork
everybody
in the world
and that
that that's the hard part
that's the hard part this isn't like
some five-step process where you do
these five steps
you're going to end up with this magical
world
no
i'm basically teaching you how to
callous over your victim's mentality
i'm teaching you how to like i did 67
000 pull-ups and training for the
pull-up record
i was seriously calloused in my hands to
protect them
what i'm trying to do with people is
teach them how to find more themselves
to where they empower themselves i'm all
about the underdog the most important
conversation is the one you have with
yourself
you wake up with it you walk around with
it you go to bed with it eventually you
act on it sometimes you act on it good
sometimes bad you got to change the
internal dialogue
that person in your head that's talking
that to you until you change the
internal dialogue in your head
until you callous over the victim's
mentality
that the world is out to get you
because of you are the only
you got to change that [ __ ] man yeah but
you don't understand my life david yeah
i do
so that's the thing about it and that's
what i can talk about but yeah i i get
what you're saying a lot of folks don't
under i get that mentality i once had
that mentality that no one understands
what i'm going through and if you keep
that mentality
you're going to stay in the same exact
spot that you're in
that no one understands me there's a
whole there's millions of people
why you think a book that i
self-published
you know is doing so well
with a story that's so people like i
never give up i went to a publishing
house like who's gonna resonate with
this story
no one's gonna buy this book
i'm like
are you not in the world
are you not in society you're never
alone
everybody's going through
so when people get this mentality of
like you understand me
you can throw a rock to someone that can
understand you if they're willing to
break themselves down and stop hiding
a lot of people understand you but you
got to stop hiding and that's why i tell
people
a lot of people are going through
they just hide better than you did what
happens is once you
transform yourself
and even though i'm still i'm not
running for myself i'm constantly facing
myself i'm constantly battling myself
i'm not running from them anymore i used
to
but now i'm constantly battling them so
now what happens is once you get to port
in your life where you're able to be on
a podcast or be on a tv show and tell
everybody how you are
i will answer any question you want
about me anything i did anything bad
good ugly i will tell you when you get
to that point in your life
that's where your real journey begins
and you no longer have to have a a small
victory to keep you going you now
realize what your purpose in life is
and you realize all this just part of it
but at first you need all these
different tactics to keep you going
because you haven't figured it out yet
once you figure out that you're in a
race amongst billions of people that
live in this world you're in a race by
yourself
you have a purpose and it's your purpose
not everybody's purpose
it is your purpose and only your purpose
and it's your race
so then you're like hey man i'm doing my
thing i'm doing the best of my ability
what's next there's no longer these
small
increments to get through life
because once you figure out why you're
here
it just becomes a process talk about mr
dobbs
um
he's a good friend of mine still to this
day
and he went into that place man and i
knew where he was going is my third hell
week
and i knew sean real well but i knew he
was real arrogant he had a serious chip
on his shoulder like i do i still do i
gotta control it every now and then it
got me in a lot of trouble sometimes
but i knew he had it i knew that chip on
your shoulder not being controlled
it will it will get you up and it and it
cost him a lot going through buds and i
saw the look
i saw the look because i once had the
look when i was going through pear
rescue school when something got so hard
and your mind can't process the hardness
you don't know the the
the right tools to get through something
hard because you've never been
challenged before i could tell he was a
super human
that nothing never challenged them but i
knew
because i already been through hobick a
couple times i knew
don't don't underestimate that
it will it will find a demon and we'll
bring out some insecurities in you and
it did and i it was like uh maybe 30
hours in the hellbrook or something like
that i'm looking over at him
and i smiled at him we're standing just
like this in line and he's getting his
med check a doctor's looking at him a
doc it happens to be beautiful timing
and i'm sitting there i'm getting med
checked and i'm looking at him
and his eye says he's a thousand yards
still looking right through me
and he's getting met checked
and i'm looking at him and before all
this happened i told him i said
don't underestimate this
man he was i can't ever see myself
quitting goggins
i go watch out
i go watch out i go this will get in
your head i go the end is a long way
away so we're sitting there eye to eye
and he didn't see me i'm right in front
of him and i can tell you thinking he
has that quit in mind starting up
i look at him i go i told you
i told you
the next thing i knew man
a car pulls up
and um he he rolled out rings the bell
he rings the bell and he quits but um it
was uh he's a great human being
um hard mother
it
it doesn't make you you know when you
quit something like that man
it's a huge lesson learned
that i can't go into anything thinking
that there's nothing that's not going to
get in my way you got to be prepared for
all those obstacles when i picked up
your book the thing i loved about it is
the amount of effort that you've been
through to give us i'm sure this was
suffering too like writing this book the
amount of effort that you've been
through to actually give us
detail right on your life we all have
different things in our life that have
scarred us
we want to act like those scars don't
exist so those scars like you know if
you go out and you get cut
that scar is going to be there on your
arm you can go down and look at that cut
and say oh or or that scar and say oh
that happened from
you know i was in the kitchen or what
happened
we have the same thing in our brain
i have all these scars on my brain
from growing up from you know
being abused from suffering through life
from having a learning disability from
stuttering from having just a really bad
childhood and so all those memories i
had to cut open that scar
and go into it and that was a hard
process for me to do not only was that a
hard process for me to do for me to have
the courage to share that with people
you know because i'm the so-called
toughest man on the planet so they think
so for me to break open that shell and
tell people hey
that wasn't always me
you know it's it's hard to do you know
it's hard to do so it was a tough
process
throughout this journey i started
becoming this new person i started
creating this new person people started
seeing me
as this
amazing superhero
in the back of my mind i knew the real
story and i was like man one day you
have to really share it i'm like man but
do you have the courage
you know like it's great to live right
here i've established this people think
you're great just stay here don't go
back let's not go back but the only way
you can help people out is let them know
that this is possible so i had to go
back and say
this is where i come from yeah and where
i come from as hell we live in a world
now
that's so kind we we find the kind way
around everything
like if you don't look good
i have to find a kind way of saying i
don't like your shirt right that's not
the approach if that's the approach
you're looking for that book is not for
you
can't hurt me is not for you the
approach you have to take at least i
took you take whatever approach you want
the conversation had to be a real honest
conversation in the accountability
mirror guess what
i was fat
don't find a kind word to say that you
know what i've gained some weight no
you're fat
when i couldn't read
not like hey you know even learn
disability no i cannot read of a fourth
grade reading level i'm struggling
and sometimes i call myself stupid not
in a way to put myself down
so don't take it like my god those are
so horrific yeah the hurtful
dishonest
the conversation has to become an honest
conversation of where you're at mentally
where am i mentally i look like
i feel like
i'm not this i'm i'm falling behind in
school i'm lazy
my house is a mess
you have to look at what it is and call
it what it is don't find words to make
yourself feel better because that's what
so we hang around people
that make us feel better that tell us
what we want to hear not what we need to
hear
and so we stay away from those people
and we stay away from those people like
our internal dialogue becomes that kind
it's okay
it's not okay
so that's where it starts it starts with
that accountability of it's not okay
anymore
this can no longer be okay
and calling yourself out for exactly
what you are
and exactly how you need to fix it as
you know i'm a serious introvert
and
um
very afraid of people
i i got judged so much growing up
that
this is uncomfortable for me all these
podcasts you know that's why i post once
a week yeah i don't you know
people are ugly people are nasty they
make me want to choke the [ __ ] out of
them
and they're just nasty people so i stay
away from them
but the one thing i realized
why i wrote the book
is
honestly i have a story to tell as we
all have a story to tell and
what i realized on my journey was a lot
of us
don't believe
that we can achieve the impossible
and along my journey i started realizing
man
i gotta tell some people about man
like i discovered something that some
people have
but they don't even know all of us have
it but along this way i wasn't like i
said i wanted a theorist i became a
practitioner and i was like my god i'm
busting down so many barriers of like i
have a learning disability
okay
but i'm catching up with everybody i i
figured that out i figured out all these
negative things in my life that were
keeping me in this hole
like i gotta tell people man that hang
on a second man
you can achieve the absolute impossible
i used to hate people
not liking me
one of the hardest things in the world
for me at a young age was my god i just
want to fit in
i want to fit in i want you like me so
that's a horrible place to be in life
because you lose yourself
when you want to fit in with people so
badly
normal people
no better than you
you do whatever you can to fit in that's
a bad place to be you lose yourself in
trying to create a character that other
people will accept
and
the that's what i found a lot of joy man
this is god this is me i speak in the
third person i got going on i'm still
working on myself
take it or leave me you don't like me
take a number and get in line man the
motivation when people are losing all
these people who come out here and talk
about how great they are and i see it
all the time it makes me sick man get
real with yourself
people cannot relate to you man you are
unrelatable when you come out here and
say hey man i'm the baddest mother would
ever live
okay great well i
what am i to learn from you
you learn from people who are willing to
tell you this is where i started from
this is how much i fell on my ass this
is how bad i used to really be i still
have those moments because why you're
human we're all jacked up man we're all
jacked up and that's what makes my story
relatable i'm willing to let you in to
see i'm decently successful now
but didn't it come out like this man
i didn't come out that's the story is
you have to give people just a little
bit of hope
there's no hope
when they see greatness in you
everywhere
you have to be able to get yourself down
to a level of check it out man
there's hope for you that's all i'm
trying to give you
just a little bit
so what's your [ __ ] excuse
is it too cold where you live is it too
hot where you live does it rain too much
now it's time for some real talk
maybe you're the only black person
applying for a [ __ ] job maybe the
only female maybe the only [ __ ] gay
person
job whatever the market may be
maybe that's in your [ __ ] head maybe
that's your excuse for not being better
life's a real big picture
when i was young
all those things got my head black
not smart enough single mom all their
own space in my head
if you're allowing people and things and
situations throwing space in your head
you're losing
last thing
last one big head game
you play with yourself
if you lose it's because you allow life
to get in your head when i got through
with that first hundred mile race that i
did around that one mile track that i
didn't prepare for and i was
considerably
it was horrible
and i'll never forget
i found
such peace and beauty and i got that i
was in the worst pain in my
life
and i got done and my wife pulled the
car up on the my ex-wife
pulled the car up on this
little lawn and i got in the back of it
and i got up the stairs i'm not gonna go
through the whole story but i remember
laying in the in the tub
and she put the shower on me
and i ran 101 miles like 19 hours and i
was like peeing dirt out of me
and i'm sitting there and i'm i'm jack
hammering and my body is just the most
broken it's ever been even to this day
and this feeling came over me
call it crazy if you want but very few
people i guarantee they've ever felt
this before to push themselves so far
outside of what they thought was even
possible even for me
i laid in that tub
and i didn't want it to go away
[Music]
i had drained myself of every bit of
strength energy i had
and
it was the best feeling i had in my life
all that pain it was
it was confirmation
it was confirmation that i had gone
through a crucible
and i figured out another level of david
goggins a level that i thought was
humanly impossible for anybody to do
when i was at mile 70 and
pissed all over myself
and had 30 more miles to go and i was
damn near dead
and i was able to go 31 more miles
in that process of that next 31 more
miles
i found out more about myself and that
31 miles to never have in my entire life
the conversations
the mental blocks the road blocks the
everything horrible it was just feeding
at me like light speed get the
out of here man like i was able to
figure out different tactics
and when i finally got done with that i
laid in that tub and it was over
the feeling of my god man you just
really
discovered a whole new world
a whole new part of the brain that i
guarantee very few people have so think
about when i say suffering people cringe
people that's the that's the one word
whenever i post about it
people cringe
it's not about suffering how people may
look at suffering like you have to just
go to a place that just every day of
your life is suffering
you have to tap into suffering every day
of your life because we have so much
scarring that we have to clean up you
have to look at suffering as almost like
i look at failure
to succeed you must fail
in failure and in suffering
all the answers are in there
all the answers to all the test
questions the test is your life
all the answers are in there you have to
live in suffering and pain and failure
all the time
you have to learn
i need to visit it like people hate
working out
you're only going to visit working out
maybe an hour a day
23 other hours of the day you're not in
it
but how you become in shape is you must
visit suffering visit working out one
hour a day visit suffering one hour a
day visit your past failures one hour a
day the relationship with it is the
answers are in there
they they are in there
within the suffering go in there
and i call it the live autopsy
the live autopsy how you find out
someone died they crack you open after
you're dead
how you can live is do it while you're
alive
go back in your brain crack it open
while you're alive don't wait until
you're dead to figure out why you died
do it while you are living
go in there go into the suffering go
into the pain of your life and say why
does this suck for me so bad
why am i afraid of all this stuff why
have i shut down the whole world
i guarantee i'll tell you why you shut
down the whole world it's in these nooks
of the suffering within your brain in
the scarring
are all the answers
to why you are on the couch feeling
sorry for yourself
they lie within the scars
visit them for at least an hour a day
study them
and then you'll find out more about
yourself you will then grow
so don't look at us every day i suffer
go into it an hour a day
learn from yourself learn from life
learn from your failures learn from your
insecurities learn from your self-doubt
don't just say i'm afraid to jump off an
airplane
what makes you afraid of it study it
that's why i studied my mind why i
became so powerful in the mind because i
realized i was weak
so instead of running away from the mind
i dove into and said what is making me
weak
oh
this makes sense
i came from hell
i came from a place that beat me down to
nothing
which is why i'm afraid
all this makes sense
so systematically one by one i went back
and met every single person in my mind
every situation
i went one-on-one with them again
in my mind it's okay
let's now revisit this and that's how
you do it i'm okay with going on this
easy highway over here the easy highway
has all these signs and directions how
to get somewhere
and you have to first be uncomfortable
with how you feel about yourself with
that voice that a lot of us like to run
away from we all have it we all have
that voice to say hey man you know
you're you're kind of wimping out right
now you're kind of being a little punk
right now but a lot of us say okay
that's okay
it's okay to tell these little white
lies to ourselves so we first have to
face the real you
the real me is david goggins the real me
is a guy looking at you right now saying
i don't wanna be on this show right now
because i used to stutter as a kid and
i'm afraid of that i'm afraid that here
in a second i'm gonna start stammering
and stuttering and the whole world is
gonna know that i have all these issues
but that's when i see right now okay
goggins you gotta go on the show
that's goggins
goggins is saying okay david goggins
you're a punk life made you this way we
can't live like this we can't live in
fear we can't live in judgment
we can't be afraid of what
people right now are looking at me
saying about me we cannot be afraid of
that
that's goggins
god is saying all of you who don't like
me who don't want to and that person
then comes in
but you have to be david goggins and say
man i'm afraid of this i'm up here life
made me this way here i stutter i i have
these issues with with the reading and
writing and and i'm i'm fat and i'm
insecure
you have to face that in that dark room
and that dark room is who you are
but in that dark room is where you have
to create
another human being that walks out of
that dark room
to face who you are
that's the only way you're gonna get
over
all those things you have to create
someone else not like you have two
different personalities it is you
but you have to find strength and that
visualization of almost me
cracking out goggins like almost like
that superman cape like i'm coming out a
different person a person that doesn't
give a [ __ ] about anything who doesn't
care about being judged who knows i'm
weak who knows i'm afraid who says
whatever you think about me take it
whatever i'm here
that's goggins
in the dark room you face yourself you
realize you want to be better you
realize you don't want to be this weak
insecure person in the world who has all
these problems that we all have
we all have social media is a great
platform to tell you who we want to be
not who we are what are
the some of the most valuable things you
learned in the navy be it about yourself
or
you know what some of the most valuable
things a lot of people say teamwork and
stuff like that
teamwork is big
but i learned that you have to be a good
individual first
you have to
triple down on your weaknesses
because a lot of times like you always
count on your buddy next to you to help
you out sometimes that buddy's not going
to be there
you got to make sure that you are
a jack of all trades and a master of all
trades
and that's one thing you got you got to
have your buddies back they can have
your back but you got to work on
yourself every single day i'm not a big
guy on social media you know i'm just
not big on that stuff even today
i'm just not a big fan of it man i'm a
big uh introvert i get a lot of my
strength from being introverted
and um going out there and doing what i
do is very all this is very difficult
for me man all of it i don't what do you
have like 600 thousand plus on instagram
or something like that yeah and for
somebody who's you're averse to it you
don't like it you hate it you only post
once in a while you don't really
advertise what you're doing at all but
you've grown this huge following of
people who are super interested in what
you're doing well i think it's important
um to do things you don't like and
i am i was very ashamed of my life story
for a long time
i i i didn't want to go out and tell
anybody [ __ ] about me
so that's why i had two people i you
know i created one david goggins and one
goggins right and um i didn't want
people to know that i had all these
issues but after a while people start to
give you these different taglines you
know like you're super human you're
amazing they start i'm like you [ __ ]
don't know anything about me man i'm
this
insecure kid i started realizing there's
a lot of people out here who are going
through a lot of problems
that i once tapped into you know i had a
whole bunch of issues growing up
and you know i felt compelled to this
you know what
you got to start sharing this stuff man
because people see where you're at today
they see where you're at today they they
see the man you are today this this hard
rock hard human being
show these people where you come from
right as many people as possible you are
pretty good about celebrating the
victories along the way and celebrating
yourself i talk about with my fiance
every single day
i talked about with her two hours today
i said we are
grinding so hard that we are losing the
vantage point of what we have
accomplished today
we got podcast podcast interview flying
do this do that i'm like stop
stop
it's just me and you in this mom-and-pop
thing that we that that we're doing look
at where the [ __ ] this book is at right
now it's crazy look how many people were
touching shut shut up
and just think for a second let's let's
stop because all we did was talk about
this and this week i don't know enjoy
this for a second let's we we have to
take time and realize what we've
accomplished here that's an evolution
for you man huge
huge but it's a very different david
goggins than even from a couple years
ago huge because you have to what is all
about
i'm gonna keep on grinding
that's not what i'm saying what i'm
saying though is
you have to
respect what you've done
take a second not live in it
not sit around and say i'm good
sit back and say
let me look at the vantage point now
that i'm at
we when the that's why you reset the
vantage point get the tactical advantage
if you get the tactical advantage too
quick and start fighting you gotta take
a second to
take observation of where where i'm at
what have i done am i in the right spot
i'm obviously in the right spot right
now now we can go back to fighting i get
a lot of questions about how i lost so
much weight
um
people want to know how they can get
started
so basically
you're thinking too much off the bat
when i lost my weight
i didn't look for a trainer i didn't do
all that thinking
i didn't go on jenny craig i didn't do
all that
what i do is i basically stop eating so
much food i cut my calories down
so as far as the workout goes we
overthink that also
until you find a trainer
go out there and start walking
put some shoes on start running go to
the gym do the elliptical trainer it's
not rocket science
a lot of folks talk about over training
you gotta train first before you can
over train
sometimes you wake up in the morning
time and you're sore and you feel like
you're over trained
no
you got sore [ __ ] legs
get out of your own head
and stop overthinking it the world is so
fast-paced
the world is so noisy so my conversation
now a lot of times is my god
slow down
the world can take you here here be here
be there be everywhere and i lose myself
sometimes
so i catch myself in the airport i catch
myself in the plane when i'm writing
stuff down okay remember this remember
that i'm like hey hang on a second guys
what got you here
this isn't what got you here slow the f
down
go back to the quiet place of that dirty
mirror in that seven dollar a month
place you used to live in
that's where you grew
you so i so that's what i'm constantly
reminding myself or go back to your
roots
i'm not saying go back to hell
but i'm saying don't forget where you
come from as you start to explode out of
the gate when you become someone
my conversation is
do not forget your roots
do not forget your roots don't let this
become so big that you lose yourself
amongst the noise go back to the
quietness of what made you successful i
write down my day
and what i do is i go back and study
that day like sometimes i might i might
get sick i might be over trained i might
um
gain a couple pounds here i might feel
whatever
that and i it's like my accountability
journal
of what i'm doing with my life physical
mental um
i had an eating journal all this
and helps me go back to once again study
i'm a lab rat
and i study myself
and i'm like when i'm feeling i go okay
what i do last week
and usually i can find out where i
messed up
last week you know how much i'm
traveling how much i'm sleeping how much
i'm doing all this stuff and
and through journaling man you can
really figure out so much
about where you're messing up in life
and what you need to fix about yourself
taking constant inventory costing honest
about that and that's thing about you
cannot put in there yeah it's gotta be a
real a real journal about hey today i
messed up here today i should have been
a better person here and not just saying
it
but actually trying to fix it tomorrow
well i sat back and i had the top five
people come at me top five publishing
houses it was down to the last two
and
they're offering 300 000
i'm a first-time you know
first-time author
and i decided to go with one of them
and three hundred thousand dollars for a
guy i'm sending back no that's pretty
good money
so
a few days before i was going to sign
the contract
i sat back talked to my fiance my family
and everybody's like you know hey you
know this is good this is great whatever
um
but
i started thinking about my life i
started thinking about everything that
i've gone through my life
everything i had gone through and had a
chance to reflect and that's one thing i
never did in my life long enough
is have time to reflect i was always
what's next what's next what's next
what's next what's next
now that i'm retired
and you have a lot of time to look back
on what you've done
where you started where you're at now
and i said you know what
this shit's not for sale
300 000 isn't even a fraction of enough
money to sell this so i decided not to
sign it and i self-published i pissed a
lot of people off
and i said i'm not signing this i'm
going to self-publish and that's kind of
how it came to be i took that time to
reflect and i'd rather not make a dime
i wrote this book and that's honest to
god's truth
um
i i am fine with the trophy i have in my
mind don't do everything in your life
for money
don't do
everything yes we needed to survive
there's a great drive and passion behind
doing things for the mind and the soul
there's a great drive in that
everybody's married you talk with such
passion
this is a life
this is my life so that's so that's what
i want people to get from all this stuff
man like there's something inside you
the the brain is the most powerful thing
the mind's most powerful thing that we
have it's not your phone it's not the
computer it's not anything it's your
mind and if you can tap into that you
can come from the from the daggone roots
of hell
and become such a great seed
a powerful seed that can grow into some
great daggone garden and people don't
get that it's all up here and if you
don't believe that you're here for a
reason
your life will seriously hurt
and i started looking at my life and all
that i went through
as god put me some god whatever you
believe and put me here
to go through this
and now i see all the hundreds of
thousands of lies i'm changing
by the hell i went through
there's a lot of power in that so my
purpose as i started going through this
journey instead of looking at like what
was me god man why why the man why why
i started looking as
it's the perfect training ground
you knew exactly what you were doing
you knew exactly what you were doing
obviously you put me in every situation
possible to tell a story
that needs to be told so i get an email
the other day
this young man wants to be a ranger but
he's afraid to go to ranger school
not because how hard the training is
but because he's afraid if he fails
what people are going to say
by judging them
one thing in life this applies to
everything in life
anytime you move from being normal
to trying to be exceptional
people aren't gonna like that those
normal people
it makes them feel like they're gonna
judge you
and nowadays it's very easy to be a
coward why
we got instagram
most folks don't tell you to your face
they go online
they post about like cowards
don't let cows get in your head
and last day
make sure you do you i i came home one
night from work spraying for cockroaches
and
um long story short i turned on the um
discovery channel i saw some guys going
through navy seal training
and they're going through hell week and
they're getting their ass just beat you
know in and out of the water guys
ringing the bell
um there's suffering and i was weighing
like 297 pounds
and i had to make a change in my life
you know i was at all-time low
and i wasn't going anywhere and i was
exactly what everybody said i was going
to be which was nothing
so i had to make a change what was it
about seeing suffering that's that's
really interesting and i actually get it
but i want to hear you explain it why
suffering was the thing that triggered
that thought
well for me growing up i came from a
horrible background i got called [ __ ]
every day of my life growing up um lived
in a small town the klan headquarters at
that time
was about
um
20 minutes from where i lived
the uh
one of the high ups in the kkk son sat
behind me in two classes so you called
me [ __ ] all the time i got my first
car they spray printed [ __ ] we're gonna
kill you on it so
i was just an insecure scared kid
and the only way i could find myself
was
to put myself through the worst thing
possible because i'm going to say the
exact opposite of what the world today's
world is saying so we read a bunch of
books nowadays as as humans we we want
to find out how to be someone else
what we don't do is we don't go
inside
so literally turn yourself inside out
read the book that says like we're
writing a book every day of our life
every day
we're seeing who we are as people when i
was growing up
i i lied for people to accept me because
i didn't accept myself so i would make
up stories so then you would accept me
into your world
i would uh everything i did was for
someone else to like me it wasn't until
i started reading my own book about how
pathetic i was as a human being i could
blame my dad i can blame kids at school
i could blame having health issues atd
my mom not being around great mom but
she was doing her thing right i could
blame a lot of people
and that's the book i was reading
and i put it off on everybody else it
wasn't until i said you know what for me
to fix this i get to read what the hell
what is wrong with david goggins not
blame anybody
read my books okay i'm afraid of my
shadow
how can i overcome that
go in the military get your ass kicked
do things you hate to do be
uncomfortable every day of your life
roger that i'm not the smartest kid in
the world
okay
is there somebody saying oh no you're
smart no no don't say that to yourself i
said to myself no i'm a dumb mother
okay roger that how you get smarter
educate yourself
so the things that we run from we're
running from the truth
we're running from the truth man so the
only way i became successful
was going towards the truth as painful
and as brutal
as it is
it changed me
it allowed me to become
in my own right
who i am today i never
set out to write a book
when i was in the dungeon and no one was
coming back to help me
i just wanted that reflection in that
accountability mirror that i hated so
badly
to be something that gave me pride to be
something that made me feel it wasn't
it's not about money it's not about
success it's not about people oh my god
that's david goggins sign my book no
when i started this journey out years
ago it's about i just want to learn to
read
so now i'm at a place now where i see
the possibilities
of the human of human potential
what are we capable of is the
conversation now
the conversation now is how can i now
talk to people
in a way they can understand the message
that i have for so many people for so
many people
so that's the that's the new
conversation now is that i you are
constantly evolving
you never stay either you're getting
better you're getting worse not staying
the same
so for me i have to constantly be
getting better i could constantly be
evolving my message so i'm constantly
thinking in the quietness of my mind
honestly my my biggest fear to this day
is um
and i say it a lot and i say a lot and
it's
it's it's going to heaven
and being judged by god
and
you know god has i believe that god has
this
knows
everything about you from time you're
born when you're gonna be born when
you're gonna die when you're gonna
graduate buzz whatever's gonna happen to
you he knows all this
some people never
do what god
knows you're capable of doing because
you keep getting you know we have
choices
my biggest fear in life was to was to
get to heaven
and god looked at me as i'm being judged
and i was some fat 300 pound guy like i
used to be that still sprayed for
cockroaches with a [ __ ] you know that's
that's okay it's what you want to do
i didn't want to do that
and i made a thousand dollars you know a
month and i got to heaven and god laid
out this chart in front of me
and they said hey man look at this chart
and it had my name on top and all this
amazing
i'm like that's not that's not me man he
goes that's who you were supposed to be
my biggest fear in life is that one day
if i ever get judged
by something someone some some energy
force
that go up there and i failed the
mission
whatever whatever force up there thought
i was supposed to be some badass
and i went up there underachieved
you know i want that force up there
that knows everything to be riding as
i'm living and saying i had no
idea he even had this in him
so i want to just be the best i
can and a lot of people say that
i truly mean that
and what is it that you have to learn
i still learn me
you know i i still feel there's you know
there's times where as a human being i'm
a human
and you you still fall back in these in
these ruts of life
where you think that you had a permanent
fix because i'd done all that i realized
it's not about money it's not about fame
it's not about
being accepted by your peers and
everybody else it's about figuring out
who i am and being happy with who the i
am
even though i'm going to be judged for
all these things being able to put a
middle finger up to everybody and say
this is david goggins
and to get to that point it felt great
david
tell them about the cookie jar
the cookie jar is something i invented
as you all know your mom has a cookie
jar and sometimes you might have an oreo
sometimes you might have a chips ahoy
sometimes you might have a oatmeal
raisin cookie you never know it's just
in there
my cookie jar
has
every single failure and success of my
life something i overcame
so what happens in this in time of life
when you're stressed out and things get
bad even the hardest guy in the world
me everybody thinks and i think i'm the
hardest guy in the world you got to
believe that you got to believe you are
something
i will in my mind
reach into my cookie jar
and sometimes you forget how hard you
are in times of of need
you because you're you're stressed
but you forget i'm a navy seal i'm a
ranger i'm this and that but you forget
all that because your life sucks
i calm down take that one second get
control of my life
[Applause]
reaching the cookie jar
well you got called [ __ ] your whole
life and you're now the only person in
history do this this and this
put it back in the cookie jar reset my
mind you have to remind yourself of how
badass you really are
in times of need
that's the cookie jar so many of us are
on cruise control myself included and we
get into our daily routine and routines
are unbelievable but routines can also
be a rut only if you really challenge
yourself and push yourself and get out
of your routine your comfort zone
can you get better like you can't
improve when you're on autopilot so you
have to set goals and you have to set um
challenges that you don't necessarily
think you can do or going to push
yourself way further than you think you
can
to improve
so you got to get out of the complacency
of the routine the whole thing about
comfort zones is if you live in one for
too long that becomes your norm it never
allows you to
gain experience gain knowledge gain any
kind of
mental toughness well i learned that we
all have a reserve tank that we're all
capable of doing so much more than we
think we can
and only by really tapping into that
reserve tank whether it's in business
whether it's in physically you want to
get more fit
only when you really push yourself and
and push your limits can you find out
what you're really made of and what's in
your reserve tank and i mean he taught
me that every single day
and it just led to me getting better in
the various buckets in my life as i
tapped into that reserve tank yeah i
think i said don't be
you know we call it the 40 rule that's
something that david uh kind of
told me and shared with me and i bought
into it and it's but it's proved
effective not just in working out but
even in business or my family life it's
like when i'm frustrated when i'm done
when i hit a roadblock when things get
complicated you have so much more in you
people are saying man you cuss all the
time why
well
i hate to say it the best way for me to
get how i feel across
i can't sit and say you know what yeah i
went through hell weekend man it was it
was really hard
no that
takes your damn soul rips it inside out
and then they say
now we're going to start
it
it allows me to express
where i was at at a point of my life
if i don't give you all of me why the
hell am i here
why how will you learn from me
people take so much offense to me
you will never learn from people if we
always tap dance around the truth oh god
i love that we tap dance around the
truth by
finding the right word so i don't hurt
you because you have thin skin no
tighten up people it's okay trust me
it's okay you might be called [ __ ] one
day
it's okay
you might be called some jewish word or
some [ __ ] or gay word it's okay let
them call you that what are you going to
do now they don't own your life how are
you going to control that now how are
you going to flip it upside down and say
roger that
now i'm going to harness this
and you'll read about me years from now
how that's the question how are you
going to do that
thicken your skin become more of a human
being don't be afraid of the reflection
in the mirror because that's all you can
be afraid of
once you overcome the reflection in the
mirror
you've done it i literally broke
all the metatarsals in my feet
stress fractures shin splints everything
the pain going with my body i've been
through every train on a man ranger
school held week three times all kind of
stuff this event i'm explaining to you
right now enough time to explain to you
in detail was the worst thing i've done
in my entire life pain wise this is when
i realized human being is capable of
going through limits unknown to most
people this is where hardness comes in
people can read a book on hardness and
tell you about mental toughness and
hardness but until you put your body
through hardness and realize that
there's walls and doors you must break
through and once you break through them
you are amazing
and your body resets
but we are scared to get to that wall
because that wall says what stop right
but every wall has a what
a door
you got to get that key from your pocket
and don't be scared essentially there's
at the door i would like to know when
you're in that moment failing
and you have to keep going what do you
say to yourself
what if
a lot of times i'll be in a 200 mile run
or something like that
and i'm all jacked up
body's broken mind's broken spirit's
broken
i start to say what if i can pull this
off when i first walked into the navy
seal recruiter's office he looked at me
and said there's only been 35 african
americans in 70 years make it through
you know i said to myself
what if i can be the 36th
it's the what if
i can pull off a miracle
what if i can become someone that no one
thinks i can be and just that just me
talking about that
i have the hair going up on my arms
because it makes me just like
what if
i can be that guy that people who call
[ __ ] and this and that and now
i'm speaking at tom ferry's [ __ ]
event
what if
that's it the first ultra marathon
wasn't smart at all
at all
um
just so basically what happened was i
was at military free fall school with
morgan latrell
marcus cettrell if you guys don't know
was the lone survivor the guy
he um was in a bad op off went bad he
was the only navy so that lived
long story short you got to get the book
read loan survivor great story morgan is
marcus charles twin brother
and i was there with marcus so what
happened was myself and morgan were in
free fall school at the same exact time
marcus
was in the worst incident in still
history so i knew that marcus might be
dead he wasn't dead everybody else was
dead so i actually brought
more you know i actually told morgan hey
man your brother wasn't a bad incident i
don't know if he's alive i don't know
what's going on
long story short marcus is alive and i
go on to want to raise money for
families all these guys died they all
had kids i want to raise money for the
special operations warrior foundation
it's a foundation where 100 tuition goes
to
these kids to go to college you know
full tuition whatever
so i found this great foundation i'm
gonna raise money for it so i said you
know what i have to google something
that's that's evil something very hard i
knew nothing about ultra marathons i
hadn't even run a marathon i knew
nothing about this world
so i googled that you know the top 10
hardest races in the world and what
comes up is a bad water 135. it's 135
mile race through death valley in the
summer time
i thought it was a stage race
i thought it was a race where you run
like 20 miles set up camp you know
barbecue outside and then go run some
more the next day
so i called the race director up at the
race and said hey chris his name is
chris costman i want to do your race so
we had a long conversation you know i
was i was much heavier than
and i hadn't put running shoes on over a
year how heavy are you at this point i'm
around between 240 to 270. whoa i'm in
there i'm in that range i've my my
weight has buried a lot through the seal
teams and out of this hill team so i was
a heavy guy but the long and short of it
all was i hadn't put running shoes on in
over a year i was a big time power
lifter i lift their weights heavy that's
what i did right i got back home from
iraq went straight to free fall school
and then this happened so i called chris
kosman up on a wednesday he says look
man the only way you can qualify for my
race is to run a hundred miles at one
time
in 24 hours or less
there happened to be a race
that saturday
so four days later
and he said if you qualify by running
100 miles or less in 24 hours i will
consider you my race
i'm gonna cut to the chase
i signed up for this race it's called
the san diego one day where you run
around a one-mile track for 24 hours to
see many miles you can get my goal was
100 miles
so
i got to mile 70
and i cleared 70 miles in like 12-13
hours pretty quickly but i was done my
feet were broken i was stress fractures
shin splints
muscles were tearing i was in bad shape
i was eating rich crackers and drinking
bile clips
that's all i had
no water didn't know what the hell i was
doing out there had on some tube socks
it was just ridiculous it was it was a
clown show
so
i sat down at mile 70 and at this time i
was married
and i i looked at my wife and i was like
um
i'm i'm messed up bad
so i literally start to turn white and
when a black guy turns white you're
pretty
so
here i am i'm off in this chair
i'm at mile 70 they got 35 miles to go
i'm jacked up i got to go to the
bathroom and the bathroom's like 20 feet
from me it's a porta potty
i can't get out of the chair so i'm
peeing blood down my leg whoa
pooping up my [ __ ] back
and i got 30 miles to go
and i'm i can't stand up because my my
blood pressure's all messed up i've been
in three hell weeks ranger school
overcome so many obstacles in my life
this last 30 miles of this race
is when i realized
a human being
is not so human anymore
we have the ability to go
in such a space
if you're willing to suffer and i mean
suffer your brain and your body once
connected together can do anything
and this 30 miles was the life-changing
moment
i was out of it i was in the worst pain
in my entire life
i was to me
on the brink of death
and i was able to chunk this 30 damn
miles
into small pieces i was so driven
and i'm not going to say motivated
because motivation is crap motivation
comes and goes
when you're driven whatever's in front
of you will get destroyed
so
i sat in this chair and i was so driven
to succeed in this race and at this time
everybody goes were you thinking about
the guys that died and
i'm not gonna lie to you i wasn't
this became
a personal
thing
this became me against this race me
against the kids that called me [ __ ]
me against me
it it it just became something that i
took so
so violently personal
and i broke this thing down into small
pieces i said okay i gotta get nutrition
i gotta be able to stand up before i can
get off this curb and get off this chair
and be able to go 30 miles
so i went through all these small steps
and i was able to stand up
and then from staying up
i was literally walking around with my
wife at the time and she goes you're not
going to make the time she goes
you're walking like 37 minute miles
i got to my 81
and the second she said that i'm not
going to make the time
i ran the last 19 miles non-stop
and i can show you right now when we get
done with this matter of fact i'm going
to show you right now
this was years ago
and i had to put compression tape
on my ankle
and i had so this was years ago
i had
literally the size of half dollars
i had to get compression tape
and i taped up my ankles and i taped up
my feet
and that's how i got through that race
it was like a hematoma i mean what do we
know see what happened was like my shins
hurt so bad from having stretch
fractures that the only way i could
continue on was i taped it so i wasn't
doing the flexor motion that that
activates
your your shins
so i taped my ankles and my shins up and
i got that from
because in my third hell week
they won't let me go back through you
know train anymore right
so i literally went through
all the buds my last seal training with
stretch fractures and shin splints and
how i did it was i would take my ankles
all the way up to my calf every morning
so for the first hour the pain was
excruciating but what happened is my
feet would go numb
and i did that every single day for six
months
whoa and that's how i got through my
third healthy because i was so broken
from the first two
that the commander said hey the ceo said
this your last time we're sending you
through so that's how i got the idea
to do that so
with the right and people may listen to
this and say
this guy is sadistic he's crazy he's
no if you know how i came up
you realize i was just
a scared kid
that found drive and passion to be
something much better than what he
thought he was self-talk
and visualization are two keys to my
success
i believed
for that last time 19 miles
i was indestructible because i took
myself in that chair
crapping up my back peeing blood on my
leg shin splints stretch fractures
i use all that for motivation versus
negativity i use it for motivation i i
said to myself who on this
earth
would still be going right now
you are
you are
you got to be the hardest mother on the
planet is it true i don't give
at that time right
it got me to the finish line of that
[ __ ] race
i believed it
i believe it today
i believed it enough to where my body
said
he's not going to stop
and that's i took all the negative
things i need to go to the hospital this
and that
and i use uh who the hell could even get
on that chair you did
who the hell would even think about
taping stress fractures up
you did
all those things are used for motivation
but routines can also be a rut what's
the point of living
you know a lot of us go through our
daily day routine kiss the wife kiss the
husband whatever you're doing and that's
our life you know i believe everybody's
put on this earth for a journey and
everybody's journey is different
but most people don't you know take
their journey they they try and take an
easier path so that's what it's all
about you got to accept your journey and
a lot of times your journey sucks but
that's what you got to do it's always
about giving back you know god gave me a
gift you know a gift to kind of achieve
what i need to achieve you know a strong
mind and if i can kind of relay that
message you know to these young kids
young young men and women it's just uh
having these events around it's just it
just helps them out helps them grow kids
need mentors nowadays yes and and to
hear a positive message from people who
don't have much
to know that hey i can do it yes
that's what it's all about you don't
need much to you know become a lot i
started doing this triathlons and
enduring sports ultra runs just to test
my soul to see what i'm about to see
in 150 mile race at mile 75 when i feel
really bad
that's when you know that's the only
time you can find out what human body is
all about what what you're made of to
find out
limits
to myself
limits of the human soul
and every day i'm trying to see if i
have limits
i run anywhere from 125 150 in a week so
i'll try and put in about 450 miles a
month
usually every day i wake up at 3 o'clock
in the morning and i run anywhere from
10 to 15 miles in the morning and then i
i live about 25 miles from work
so i i get my bicycle commute into work
do a normal work day
at lunchtime around noon
i'll run again anywhere from five to
eight miles whatever maybe come back
work
and around 5 30 i'll ride back home 25
miles on my bike if i'm feeling good and
when i get more miles i'll get off the
bike and do like a short three or four
or five mile run
that's my everyday life so i don't just
train like an hour or so
i train until something is uncomfortable
and then naturally you know who you are
[Music]
the only easy day was yesterday
it just never ends i mean i've done some
races where you're on a one-mile track
and you're running for 48 hours straight
so imagine running 48 hours running my
mile track
and it's not like you're sleeping you're
you're running for 48 hours how many
miles you can get
i want to talk about mine torture
[Music]
my life doesn't have a finish line so
when i cross the finish line of the iron
man it doesn't matter because i know
that you know two or three weeks from
now i'll be doing something else to my
body through more pain
i believe you know everything i try to
do is kind of defined by excellence
but
i don't think i ever reach excellence
myself because i have my standards of my
life are really high
so i don't ever reach it but i try to
every day
you have to be a good individual first
before you can be a good team player
i know for a fact how bad hell we get i
i went through it a couple times it's
probably the most brutal like brutal
military training anybody can go through
so everybody's my left and everybody to
my right they've been through this so i
know mentally
you know these individuals are extremely
hard
and when stuff gets bad
and you know in this situation i know
these guys have my back
i've done a lot of things i thought were
impossible nothing's impossible anymore
my favorite cream is swim yeah you know
what i'm saying i mean
we had little athletes in my damn family
and um and i was a kid who kind of got
the kind like the the bad genes you know
all these little sickly issues all these
allergic to it i was a little sickly kid
and it's funny how when people hear my
story now they want to put a title on me
like um
i'm super human yeah like you had some
special
capability and i love it because
basically it makes you feel better
by putting a title on me right you can
do it too
that's right right and so
basically choice yeah it's a choice yeah
it's a horrible choice right it's a hard
choice it's a lot of suffering involved
so for me to get the start line
through that start line journey i
realized
i'm capable
so what happens to this whole process is
the change of the mind
it's a change of the guard
someone once owned my brain
i never owned it yeah i never had no i
had no control you out you outsourced it
that's right everybody had it it was my
dad's fault it was the kids that called
me [ __ ] fault my mom wasn't home fault
my soon-to-be step-dad's fault the
little kids that get rid of by the bus
fault my life was everybody had a piece
of my frame
and through this journey of suffering
and the suffering i put it in because i
started finding myself yeah i started oh
no i'm taking something back from me
this part of my brain is mine now i
start puzzling back this piece of my
brain and through that i grew confidence
in this process i went from david
goggins i started forming a guy named
goggins
i had to really invent i realized i had
to reinvent a whole nother human being
right within myself because
who i am wasn't going to make it this
this is not this guy is not going to cut
it
so he i'd be a guy who can take any kind
of pain
any kind of suffering any kind of
torture mentally physically emotionally
spiritually
i had to have the people who i
visualized everybody that called me
[ __ ] you had to be in a room of people
like this
i had to make up these things in my mind
of things i had to overcome
and i started callous in my mind
do it through a process and it they
start with working out
it started with working i started with
doing
like if it started raining outside for
instance
my mind would say man i'm gonna go run
if it was three o'clock in the morning
start raining outside my mind said
you gotta go get up and go around you
have to because i was fighting this
other person so you essentially
tried to do everything you didn't want
to do that's all it was period
everything i didn't want to do is what
got me to where i'm at today interesting
every single thing so
where we find comfort yeah that's where
i started getting scared yeah when i
started saying oh it's raining i'm not
going out there no you cannot say that
you cannot do that
you you have got to do this
the other so whatever my brain thought i
did the opposite
where the comfort wasn't with the
opposite direction and over a period of
time boy it callouses
out of your mind you start to really
develop a whole another being my biggest
advice to give everybody in the world
is like i say we live in an external
world
everything is is you got to see it touch
it it's external
if you can for the rest of your life
live inside of yourself
stop listening to people who are calling
you fat gay transsexual [ __ ]
everything that is makes no sense all
these insecure people putting their
insecurities on you you got to flush it
out
you got to just be whoever the hell god
or whatever the hell you believe in if
you believe in nothing but yourself i
don't care what it is
you got to take everything and throw it
away
you have to believe in one thing and
that is
yourself and and i'm not saying don't
believe in god or what you believe in
but right now for you to find
greatness in yourself
you're not going to find it
by looking in a book or by even hearing
me i may give you the spark
but you've got to go inside yourself to
find it and that means you got to be
quiet
shut the [ __ ] up go in a room
stop talking search
your soul search your mind search your
abilities and you'll find it
but if you're not looking for it
you won't find it
so you got to go start your journey and
the journey starts with you finding why
the hell am i here on this planet earth
why am i here and if you don't know that
you will live the rest of your life
searching
always asking the question why as a
leader the one thing i did horribly
wrong on my second platoon i actually um
started developing an attitude towards
people who didn't pee too hard mm-hmm
who didn't get after who worked because
i know
i i took it all the way to the limit and
so i should have been a better leader by
no one okay you know not everybody wants
to be david goggins yeah everybody wants
to go 100 miles everybody everyone's got
different everybody's got different
skill sets and you know right you know
maybe they you know want to go to the
gym
whatever the gym is fine but it was just
a different standard so i couldn't take
away my standard for the whole of the
group interesting i looked at people i
[ __ ] you man you know yeah you ain't
trying to get hard so my mentality i
wasn't a good leader
and i look back on that now
trust me a lot of people could do things
differently i'm taking accountability
before i could have done differently
i looked at that so my mentality from a
weak kid became super hard
like beyond hard next level hard
and um but that's what i was getting
myself into as a leader i should have
stepped back and was hey these are your
expectations david goggins right
what are we here to accomplish right
it's important to lead by example and
when i say lead by example
if you're the leader it's the longest
job on the planet
and if you do it
you have to be up early you have to
leave late you got to do the sucky jobs
at least that's how i look at it you got
to be the man that is is is always the
person
who's being held accountable to the
highest standard
and not expecting your people to do
anything that you're not going to do 20
times more than they are even even when
you're the leader
and and i and it's all about
accountability for yourself in
leadership roles not about being pissed
because
people aren't doing what you're doing
[Applause]
when you think that you are done you're
only 40
into what your body's capable of doing
and that's just the limits that that we
put on ourselves
we've got our leader of the 150 mile
coming in
[Applause]
he's just won the
2008 150 mile run
you're never gonna really know how i
feel i never really tell you the truth
i'm always gonna feel good he's the
person
i want to feel and show you no weakness
congratulations thanks a lot man 150
mile champion first place new course
record way to go congratulations
i'm never happy and satisfied with
one thing i do it's always a continuous
journey and in all my races
there's never been they just kind of
fall in together it's like one big
journey that that won't end i die
growing up being the kid i was i found
strength in different movies yeah so i
come home in one movie i found a lot of
strength as funny as it may seem but i
visualize this scene i do it today
during the pull-up record i did 4030
pull-ups
the last time i did it actually got it
took me three times i played one song
for 17 hours pretty much
it's from this movie
rocky one
round 14.
i related to the person in the movie
but just the one scene
when apollo's beating out of rocky
he falls in the corner
and everybody and rocky and paul turns
around arms up happy i i got this guy
he turns around not knowing that rocky's
trying to get up off the canvas
mickey's saying mickey's his trainer
saying stay down everybody's saying you
did good
you did good you had 14 rounds with with
the champ
rocking in here
he got up and was fixing my mind today
still
and i've seen it right now when he got
up
apollo starts to turn around
to see the aftermath of what the [ __ ] he
just destroyed
and he did not expect to see what he saw
right
and what i see are the whole movie
i see apollo crease face yeah fear crept
in yes
and i said to myself as a young kid
i want to be that
i don't need to win
i don't need trophies i don't need
people to like me i just want what he
has yeah
a fictional character whatever the hell
it was
i want that
and i visualized that
and i want to become the guy who can get
off the canvas and look at somebody who
beat the [ __ ] out of him life
yeah it's about life right now
in life
even life itself pushed her head down
towards david god yeah this is not going
to stop right so that mentality
became
what i wanted nice
and that's how it started with that
visualization
of the canvas
and all i got to do is just keep getting
up you once said that if you were
growing up in this generation that you
would have a field day because you would
take their souls what did you mean by
that the the younger generation quits
not everybody
so i gotta i gotta put that people get
their butt hurt so not everybody
most of this generation quits the second
they get
talked to
you did this wrong you did this wrong or
they get yelled at it's so easy just you
know to be great nowadays
because everybody else is most people
are weak
this this is a softened generation so if
you have any mental toughness
any any ability you have any fraction
of self-discipline the ability
to
not want to do it but still do it people
have a hard thing understand i hate to
run and what makes me so crazy it
doesn't need more is people well why do
you run if you hate it what are you
talking about
i don't want to take showers and eat
either i hate that too
the whole that's the life man
and and
it wasn't until i changed that mentality
that i became somebody
i hated going to school so guess what i
was dumbest
that's what
one plus one is two
but if you can get through
to doing things that you hate to do
on the other side is greatness
that's what people understand
by me running i am callous in my mind
i'm not training for a race
i'm training for life
i'm training for the time when i get
that two o'clock in the morning call
that my mom is dead or something happens
tragic in life
i don't fall apart
i'm training my mind and my body my
spirit so it's all one so i can handle
what life is gonna throw at me because
the life i've lived
it throws a whole bunch at you
and if you're not physically immensely
prepared for that
you're just going to crumble and you're
good for nobody
talk to me about what it takes to be on
one side of a door in iraq or anywhere
knowing on the other side of the door
people who are not afraid of you
they're ready for you to come in and you
still have and they have guns and you
still have to breach that door
that's that's a great question it
that's
a very scary situation when you are
on one side of the door
and your mind is racing because on the
other side of that door
it could be no one
it could be four guys with four ak-47s
that
that door you're about to open can be
booby-trapped so once you open it boom
your legs are gone
so
there's a thousand things you think
about when you're the first guy second
guy third guy getting ready to go in a
room and flooding and that's why i talk
about the warrior mentality and that's
why so many people are lost when i start
talking
you have
the right
you're lucky
that you don't have to think like
warriors think you're very privileged i
chose this world to be a warrior you
know and i would choose it again if i
came back to this world
but the mentality of a warrior is very
different than normal mentality
you must be that person on that door oh
get ready to open it thinking to
yourself
if i die
so be it
the only way you can go in that door is
knowing there's a great chance you're
gonna die it's like being a seal you
train with live ammo
you jump on an airplane
everything you do
you could die
so to be a warrior why people don't
understand me i'm glad you don't
understand me merry christmas good on
you because being a warrior takes a
whole different mindset
a whole different mindset to know that
there's a great chance i may not be in
the middle like i was in for 21 years
i'm lucky
i'm very lucky that i'm alive able to
talk to you able to still run
but when you sign up on that dialogue to
be a
like a seal your mentality changes
i may not live
you gotta accept that
and that's the mentality you have and
that's what makes you a warrior if
you're scared to die
you're a bad warrior i hated jumping out
of airplanes
i hated shooting guns
i hated the job as a navy seal
but i did it because i wanted to
change myself
[Music]
everything i do i'm not really
comfortable doing
but if you choose to go that route to go
be a navy seal
you might as well go be the hardest in
the world
because if you're choosing to do
something you have two routes you can go
there and be a little a little weak
person and get through barely and that's
your reputation
or you can go through
the hardest guy you can possibly be
that's your reputation so my whole thing
is if you're gonna choose to open that
door in iraq or afghanistan open them up
and go in hard
because they're going to remember you
by slowly opening it and peeking in
so if you're going to open it and you
made the mind open it don't crack it
open
open the door go in that's with life
if you're choosing to do if you're
choosing to do something attack it
because they're going to remember you
as not attacking it so i want to be
remembered you can hate me but one thing
you can't say about me
i didn't attack it
so that's the mentality you have if
you're gonna do something you might as
well attack it because you can do it
anyway right
do you use that in civilian life like do
you still
employ the i'm going to attack it i'm
going to take their souls like how does
that play out in a non-um
combat
zone it still works for me in in life as
far as attacking things
because uh no matter what i want to you
know no matter what avenue i choose i
want to be the very best
and the very best may not be
i'm number one
the very best is did i leave everything
inside of me
out there
so attacking is not like oh i want to
win this or win that or be the best
the best is i'm i'm running against
myself and everything i do
and and that's and that's what i attack
i attack myself
i'm always questioning myself when
things hit you in life
that you're afraid of or you're not good
at
the first thing you're going to say to
yourself is
why am i here anyway
this isn't for me
the water's too cold the sun's too hot
i'm getting up too early why am i doing
this to myself
that's what the normal mind says
i had to start training my mind to think
about
how the
can i get through this
not giving myself a way out
never giving myself creating a wall
around all the [ __ ] ways out in my
mind
i just slowly started to build this
wall so my mind knew
this
is not going to give himself a way out
of here in my first hell week i had a
huge setback
i was broken
my legs were broken i had double
pneumonia
i got rolled back to day one week one of
navy seal training i got through that
second hell week
during the second hell week i actually
broke my knee i continued to limp around
for a couple weeks
i couldn't make it anymore got rolled
back to day one week one
i'll never forget standing there in
front of captain bowen he was the ceo in
charge of navy seal train at the time
and he had no mercy on anybody
if he believed in
managing your expectations
i wouldn't be here today he challenged
me again
i was challenged my whole life not by
the mindset of managing expectations by
exceeding expectations not by managing
them i'm standing there with crutches
i'm sitting in his office he looks at me
he goes dog is this your last time we're
gonna put you through navy seal training
this will be your third hell week in one
year
we're not gonna put you through a fourth
so this is your last time
i'm sitting thinking how am i gonna get
through this
i'm i'm badly jacked up my legs are
broken my knee is messed up
and he goes you have a couple of months
to get better
a couple months isn't gonna do it i
won't get healed up in a couple of
months
but i realized i'm gonna get through
this
i'm gonna find a way to get through it
because why i put barriers in my mind
so my third hell week i went in there
with pretty much i would put a black
sock
on first
i would get duct tape
and i'd duct tape my ankles all the way
up to my calf every single morning and
then i put another black sock over it
and what that did that prevented me
from moving
my ankle
so i didn't really
i wasn't flexing my shin as much
and i started running with just my hip
flexors
in this hell week it was a bad hell we
had a guy die
on thursday morning of hell week
i went on to become a navy seal
greatness is not something that you meet
once
it's something that you meet
thousands of times in your life and you
don't reach it
if you're not constantly in constant
pursuit of
greatness
so if my mind were to say right now
i'm great
i just lost
we're gonna grow we're not going to
triple down on our strengths
we're not going to do that crap
we're going to work on our weaknesses so
we grow we need friction to do that
without friction there's no growth
without friction there's confusion
confusion is david goggins how did you
become who you are today
i put a bunch of friction in my life
and i grew
that's how i did it you know you get
really tough
it's a lifestyle
instead of hitting that news button in
the morning and not making your bed not
cleaning your house
you don't hit this news button
you get up you don't want to go run you
go run you don't want to go swim you go
swim you want to make your beds you make
your bed you don't want to clean your
house and clean your house you don't
want to study and study that's how you
start to callous your mind so that
became my life
if you say you're going to wake up at 4
o'clock in the morning to go run wake up
at four o'clock and it's gonna suck
it's not gonna be fun
do something that sucks every single day
of your life that's how you grow
embrace the suck i never forget one time
during the basketball game
there was this coach
mr trout
he knew me when i was a kid
in that school when i was in third grade
getting set back mr trout always loved
me this white man loved that i mean i
don't know why he did
but he was my jv basketball coach my
sophomore year
the visiting team
was at our home stadium it was at the
end of the game
and the visiting team started chanting i
was the only black person in the whole
dad gone stadium
they started chanting [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] that's all i remember
at that time in my life that's all i
remember
but not 42 years old
i can look back on that time with clear
eyes in a clear mind
and see what mr trout did for me
he was in that locker room where i was
crying and upset and he cried with me
this white man cried with me about that
time i didn't see that all i saw was red
i saw hate this whole town hated me
everybody's against me
my mind lost it
and for some reason i couldn't sleep on
my bed until this day
i don't know why the floor felt so
comfortable
and at 22 21 years old
i went from 175 pounds
to
297 pounds
fat
out of shape
insecure i was everything everybody said
i was going to be that's what i was
[Music]
and it makes you feel like
so i got a job spraying for cockroaches
at night time not saying it's a bad job
but i didn't want to do it
so for about six months i went around to
your local eateries praying for
cockroaches
this one night i came home the first
thing i do i walk in my living room turn
the tv on
first thing i do then walk back to the
um to take a shower
and i was listening to the tv as i was
trying to take a shower
this day changed my life it held me
accountable
for what i wasn't facing in life they're
going through navy seal training and i
sat down i came out of the shower and i
sat down something brought me back to
sit down and watch these guys go through
hell
i saw a ton of them quitting ringing the
bell ringing the bell means you quit
navy seal training i saw him putting
their helmet down this went on through
the whole show
and it finally got to the very end
there's about 15 to 20 guys at the very
end
and there's one statement
changed my life
they were all sitting there and they're
dressed whites
and this co this command officer stands
up in front of these men
and he looked sharp and he i could tell
he stood for something and he said we
live in a world
where mediocrity
is often rewarded
these men up here detest mediocrity
when you hear a statement like that
it forces you to think about yourself
i wasn't even mediocre
i wasn't anything
i was at the bottom of the barrel of
life
i chose
the four-lane highway
for my life the easy route the route
that has gas stations the right that has
signs that say 20 miles to the next
service stop all this [ __ ] i chose that
right most of us choose the four lane
highway when i was born
there was also a shovel over here in the
corner that's the no one wants to go to
the shovel
they want to choose the four-lane
[ __ ] highway that's the that's the
nice route
the shovel means you're gonna hurt
the shovel means you're gonna suffer
there's something means you're gonna hit
rock a lot of times and we all know what
digging through rock is like when you
hit a route
you got to get some more tools out if i
had no more tools just a shovel i was
choosing a four-lane highway this is
when i decided to pick up that [ __ ]
shovel that we all decide not to take
i had to make a change in my life so i
said you know what
i have to join the military
i went on a navy seal training
became the only person i believe in
history to go through three
navy seal steel helmets
in one year steven saljo was my
recruiter i walked in when 297 he looked
at me strangely and i said i won't be a
seal
and lucky enough the guy looked at me
and said
let's see what he can do
he weighed me i weighed 106 pounds
overweight the guy said man
there's a program that that's about to
end
that you can go
and if you make it through buds you then
go active duty right and you'll be a
seal if not you come back home right i
was like yeah
so anyway
you're gonna make y'all lose 106 pounds
less than three months so about making
sure did you lose the weight in three
months
you just run your ass off i couldn't run
the first thing about it was so i said
to myself i'm gonna run four miles
my first run off the gate
i'm gonna run four miles i ran a mile i
went a quarter of a mile
walked home sat on the couch depressed
i said man there's no way i can do this
but what i realized though
is i wasn't going to give up
because i've already given up a million
times and i thought about
how would i feel at 50 years old if you
gave him that if i gave up now
not to have you know so i kept all this
stuff in my mind
and um
basically i started becoming obsessed
i slowly it didn't happen that night on
the couch
over a period of time i started becoming
obsessed with
studying with weight with being somebody
was making people who thought it was
gonna be nothing
kind of like feel like
i became obsessed with you have to make
this right
and the only person could do is yourself
so i became obsessed with just
being obsessed before i started race i
actually imagined myself going through
all my little checkpoints i'm imagining
all these different emotions and things
i'm going to go through so when it
happens
it just flows all this imagery is so
important in life if you can see
yourself doing something you can do it
if you can't see yourself doing it
usually you can't achieve it every race
i get into i hit a wall
in a race that's so long you hit several
walls
and every time you hit a wall it's a big
deciding factor in that race or in your
life if you're not running and you have
a decision to make
either you can stop at that wall you can
go parallel left or pillow right you're
looking for that door
and when you get to the door you have
another decision to make should i open
it or should i keep it close if you keep
it closed you made a decision to quit
if you open that door you made a
decision to carry on and continue on
with your journey or your mission
wherever you're on
and i
always open that door because once you
open the door and you go through it your
mind resets and it gets you a few more
miles
[Music]
i can't describe it to you how how you
feel when you know you're going to
complete the hardest thing you've done
in your life the second you realize not
to give up your body gets back in tune
again and you're ready to go
[Music]
i have those mental blocks all through
the race
but that's when i smile too i signed up
for that race to see what kind of
decision i'm going to make
and that's why i do it and usually it's
the decision to keep on going forward
i have to experience life and that's how
i experience life with your learning
disability with your dad beating you
screaming at you emotionally challenging
your mind with
the racism you dealt with with um
the different struggles you felt with
bullies what was the
hardest obstacle to overcome from
up until about 15 16. the hardest
obstacle was myself
i started realizing more and more and
more
that all these people were gone
what was haunting me was me
i can't control my dad
i can't control the people calling me
[ __ ] i can't control all these things
but they were things that kept me down
it started becoming my reality
my reality was what they made it out to
be
and i became all
the most important conversation you'll
ever have with your life you know in
your life is when you have yourself
and my conversation was absolutely
horrifying what were you saying to
yourself
i'm dumb
i'm nobody my dad i mean my dad was
great in mental warfare
a drunk insecure man
will make everybody around him feel like
hell
yeah because he wants to give you no
power
and that's why he was so
mean to my mom and myself and my brother
because he didn't want anybody to get
above him
he want to keep you down low so when
you're growing up with all this stuff
all this hate
and it wasn't the beatings
i could hit the beatings all day
it was a mental torture
so when at a young age your your parents
put a dialogue in you of confidence
or you're nobody
so that voice in my head was i'm a loser
and then it was confirmed when i got in
school and in third grade i was falling
behind they want to put me in a special
school yeah you know with kids who can't
learn right
then it was confirmed what you know what
my dad was saying so that confirmed it
then i started cheating so i started
realizing you know what i'm taking the
easy way out again yeah and it started
snowballing from there now now the kids
are calling me [ __ ]
but it wasn't all the kids so what
happens is
you start to get this picture that
everybody hates you
because your reality becomes so so big
mm-hmm that you don't you i mean you
can't see the clear picture it might
have been three or four that's it doing
it over and over right but it was the
whole town yeah everybody hated me so
the world hates me that's right yeah and
that's when it that's when it became
toxic
and that is where i became my worst
enemy well everybody it's groundhog's
day again for david goggins
if you pan it down here
you see it's about three o'clock in the
morning
and there's not a car or a person in
sight if you pan over here
it's the same thing
not a car or a person in sight
people want to know where i find my
strength at where i get my strength i
get it from a lot of places but right
now this morning
i'm getting it from there's nothing
that's up there's not a car there's not
a person everybody's in their bed sleep
dreading that it's a monday hey this on
monday and i'm loving it i'm loving that
where everybody's getting weaker i'm
getting stronger
it's not about the running the swimming
to push up to sit-ups
it's about what those things do for your
mentality you don't get better on the
daggone couch you get better by coming
out here and getting after every daggone
day what was the greatest lesson your
mom taught you growing up
honestly the greatest lesson she ever
taught me is a lesson that she
she doesn't know how much she taught me
because
she wasn't much in the teaching mode
my dad took her soul but what i did as a
young kid
is i observed
everybody
i wasn't really smart in the books yeah
but i was real smart when it came to
life yeah and i was able to sit back and
watch her mistakes i was able to see
how she struggled through life
and how i don't want to struggle through
life
and i was able to see
she never picked me up the biggest thing
she did for me and this is honest to god
truth and she doesn't even know she did
it
but i would bust my ass but i would fail
yeah when i was at the bottom of the
sewer
she never picked me up
she never gave me that cookie and said
hey son you know it's gonna be okay
never she didn't have time for that
and sometimes she gets upset when i talk
about my past because it pains her out
to be not the best mom
if i had any kind of mom in that kind of
environment
i would have never made it
because
she forced me for every reason
she forced me
till you better figure this out
or you're going to be a statistic wow
and this is something that she didn't
sit down and tell me
i realized this this is the world that
is in front of me
and what most people do is they see this
world
and they look at it as an excuse to get
out of it
yeah
i started looking at it
as
this is the ultimate training ground for
the rest of my life
[Music]
i have all these valuable lessons
because if you look out in the world
right now today it's not a nice place
but i'm very prepared for it yeah you
are i'm prepared for it i'm prepared for
all the failure coming my way
i'm prepared for everything my way and
that's the biggest lesson that she
taught me by not teaching me
by never saying it's gonna be okay
matter of fact you told me the exact
opposite
life sucks but when i started getting
these emails from people saying hey you
know what you changed my life
that part changed my life that part of
your story changed my life and because i
have so many different parts of my life
that so many people
resonate with different spots maybe it's
do obese part maybe it's the bullying
part maybe it's the learning disability
part maybe it's the abusive parent part
whatever it may be
so many people draw from my story and i
started getting these emails and i was
like
god man you know
i'm a big believer in something more
powerful than me
i don't know what it is but i'm not the
end-all
so i was like uh i gotta start doing
more
if i'm touching these people's lives a
few people hearing that right maybe i
need to go out here and do some more god
put me in a very
interesting spot of life
where he made hell
my teacher
he made hell my teacher and a lot of
people
don't understand that
so
i'm trying to give people a different
thought process of life
where
failure hell disappointment discomfort
is a great learning tool
and many people don't understand that
and a lot of people won't even
understand this interview when we get
done with it
but
it's these few moments in life that you
have like for me i always talk about it
rocky 1 round 14.
that one two minute
and 13 second clip
of
rocky getting up when apollo knocked him
down
that one clip when i was going through a
very bad time in my life i saw
what i wanted to be
and it wasn't a guy that won
the one the guy that won everything he
did
it was a guy that kept getting up
after being knocked down
so i realized if that two minutes and 13
seconds changed my life
so i was
i saw something that i needed to be
in the world i was living in
maybe my story
will give someone the two minutes and 13
seconds they need to change their life
means that people live in a very
comfortable place that's fine
don't listen to me
a lot of people are looking for that two
minutes and 13 seconds
and i might be that person and i believe
that we're all we're all teachers
we're all teachers
and if you don't learn something
and give back
like what you learned yeah what's the
point of living you're wasting yeah
you're wasting it you have all this
knowledge of what you learn
some people may think you're crazy some
people may you know may put a title on
you
but it's it's it is you know it's those
few people who are like you know what i
need to hear that and i i often talk
about taking souls
this morning
this person i usually train alone
this person wanted to run with me
and i said fine we'll run 15.
this morning comes
there's storms coming in this way
and the person calls and said hey
why don't we do it tomorrow
taking souls is when i told him
[ __ ]
i'm going to run 15 today
and i'll run with you again tomorrow
that's what taking souls is about
don't worry about the elements and
what's going on
you got to get out there and get it
and that's taking souls and obviously
he wasn't the only one
that felt about taking the day off
because the storm is coming in right now
and there's not a soul out here but me
everybody's journey is different i was
on a journey to see who david goggins
was
and that journey took me in some of the
hardest areas
a human being can even imagine
and right now at 41 i'm the happiest
person on the planet because
you know i had to climb mount everest
several times just to look down on my
life
to see where hell i came from and that's
what kept me going through all this
stuff like i i envisioned myself going
through
like when i was a young kid and they
called me [ __ ] all the time that got
my dad beat the hell out of me and i was
had no self-esteem
i had this vision
of
if i can make it to where i want to go
imagine when i look back on my damn life
how proud i will be
and now i'm here
i'm able to look back on this life i
lived that many people will never
understand because why when you're
passionate
they think you're crazy
and you can't even explain to people why
you're doing or why you did what you did
because
you found your purpose and once you find
your purpose you can't really explain it
to normal people because they don't
understand passion because they live
every day life just going
not really finding their purpose so
i become a foreign language to people
that they so they put me in a category
if you're just crazy no no no no i'm
passionate i found my purpose in this
life well there's something i invented a
long time ago
and when you have nothing to draw from
i was able to find strength in every
molecule of this earth
i'm able to be in a room with nothing
with no motivation no inspiration
nothing and find it
so what i did in those situations was i
invented this thing called taking souls
when everybody's off
and you're exhausted and you're weak and
you're tired and you're looking around
and everybody looks as bad as you or
even worse
i'm like you know what i want to now
make a statement
it's the perfect time to make a
statement to make a statement to let you
know where your life ends
and mine begins
and so the statement there is i must
drop every bit of strength from their
looks on their faces
and how they feel
and how i'm gonna now
from
my childhood where i came from how's the
bottom of the barrel i'm now amongst all
these uncommon people i'm now going to
now make you feel like you're common
so i use their
their sadness their weakness their
parts of their life for god this sucks
i'm like all poopy pants to messed up i
use that for my strength
and i have this moment of like
let's say we're
in the sand we're running or whatever i
would do a surge i would do something
everybody's like how the is he doing
this
and from that that look on their face
that feeling of god man this guy must be
something something special it then
surges me further
and further and faster and harder for a
long time
so
it's energy is everywhere
but the thing is it's so loud
that that that voice in your head of
pain and suffering and discomfort and i
want to do this is so loud that you're
unable to really calm it down it's okay
there's something here
it's a patient calm that you have to
bring yourself to say i know i have
something here but that voice is so
powerful they just want you just to
let's leave right we're done we're done
it spazzes you out and you want to go
versus saying let's take a second hang
on before we spaz
hang on
and in that moment you can think clearly
and find that strength out there for you
we believe like so many people before i
give them a workout plan they're talking
about recovery everybody everybody that
hears me speak
they want to go straight to recovery
work out first huh
work out first before you talk to me
about recovery how to recover yeah work
out first we are always looking for like
whenever i talk to people people take my
words
and they and they and they put it in a
way to where
they want to feel comfortable this guy
you know they they they want to put you
in a box
they want to put a title on you
no you're putting a title on me to make
yourself feel better about yourself
if you read this book of mine and you
see where i came from this person was
this person was not built
this this person was not made by god
this person sorry this person was built
i made this person
i made this person by diving in to the
insecurities that life gave me because
now they're yours they're yours to own
if you're not smart
call yourself dumb
it's okay
because you are
but take that knowledge you put yourself
down if you're fat car yourself fat i
used to be 300 pounds
we we want to talk so soft to ourselves
we're looking for that recovery day
and that recovery day is everything in
your life
everything in your life is a recovery
day we're looking for it it's not coming
it's not coming
get over that recovery day
and that's the mentality i took with me
and what happened through that process
was all the frivolous things of life
started to float away i used to tell
people lies so they would like me
because i was so insecure
when you start to build yourself up
and start to have the one thing that we
don't have is confidence yeah real
authentic confidence from hard work
everything else goes away you no longer
look to other people for your
self-esteem foundation
you now know
i walk in the room now and i know that
hours and years and decades
i put into david goggins
that's some
it's not on the wall
it's not a trophy on the wall it's not a
male around your neck
it is actually a feeling in your heart
and people why don't you ever smile
i don't have to
yeah
yeah i do have a story look at my face
i'm a very focused person but the thing
i have in my soul and my heart
that's why i need to smile
i don't need to smile i don't need you
to look at me and say oh my god you look
happy because half of us aren't happy
we're giving you something that we think
you want to see
i don't do that anymore
i don't care how you perceive david
goggins because through my journey i
figured out the one piece i was missing
i thought it was cars i thought it was
women i thought it was i thought it was
my i thought was everything the one
piece i was missing was me having the
courage to face myself i wanted that
comfort zone that everybody looks for
that pat on the back they don't want to
hear all the bad they wanted everything
that they're doing right
and i realized that's what kept me
in this world that's what kept me in
this world of not accomplishing anything
so
what i did was i became that big bad
nasty
that you don't want to walk into at
night time
i became the roughest critic in the
world on myself
and that's what changed me
i literally saw myself in the mirror i
saw the truth
versus saying you know
my dad did this to me from you know from
beating me kids in school from call me
[ __ ] did this to me
my life did this to me my
broken foundation this to me
i took that and said you know what well
some people may help this happen but now
i have to own this
no one's gonna come back to save me no
one's gonna come back on the couch and
say hey
it's okay
you're gonna be okay no i'm not
i'm not gonna be okay i had to realize i
had to take a stand i had to make a real
stand
and it was painful to look at who i
like who i was what the world and myself
created
it created a
a a very lonely depressed insecure man
that would do anything just to have a
friend
and i saw that as very pathetic
when you look at the truth it becomes
very ugly and pathetic my first time
going through buds i got the hell week
um stress fractures double pneumonia
i got rolled back day one week one
second time going through buds i
actually
um fractured my patella
before i got into hell week
made it through hell weep with the
fracture patella went two weeks after
hell week and then because why i didn't
want to get rolled back to day one week
one
but i couldn't keep up with the class
got rolled back to day one week one
after hell week and then i went through
my third time and i graduated that class
we had a guy die in that third hell week
class 235
so that's kind of how it happened i had
to have some so i'm really good at
creating an enemy i'm really good at
at creating something that i'm against
and i'm also good at if you ever tell me
something that i cannot do
i'm gonna let you know that i'm doing it
right somehow somehow you're gonna know
one way or another
that i'm doing it it may not be like in
your face it may i may make sure that i
run across the daggone world so then
it's on the news and you turn the news
on and say how the hell did he do that i
want to do something that you know i'm
here
i'm here
this isn't for anyone looking for a
break
there is no finish line so stop looking
for one
don't believe if you work your [ __ ]
that one day you'll hit that finish line
there's only one finish line
that is death
we must find our limits in everything we
do
and push slightly beyond it
remember this
just because you worked your ass off
it doesn't mean
you will achieve
what you've been working for
very few of the mindset to work through
[ __ ] with no guaranteed success
never expect immediate results
have an endurance mindset you're going
to stay in the stuck longer than anyone
else
true victory comes
when there are no crowds and no finish
lines
the real victory
is your goal is to work your ass off
while no one is watching
stay hard when i started figuring out
going through buzz
was that
the harder something is
the more it was challenging my mind
so i had to find different ways to stay
in the fight in the state of the fight
it got me tougher and tougher and
tougher so i'm actually happy i went
through three whole weeks i never
examined myself
and as a human being you got to examine
yourself and
i and i guess the best place to examine
yourself is navy seal hell week
three times so i got to examine myself a
few times
so it started there it started in hell
week
and it's still going now at 43 years old
some of you just don't get it
i'm not here trying to prove myself
how tough i am
i'm trying to make you think
i'm trying to give you
tools
on how to find more of yourself
so why am i in the water right now
at
three o'clock in the morning
well when i was going through training
i used to hate night swims
they bothered me
when i retired
i said i'll never get back in the water
again at nighttime
so guess what i'm doing right now
going for a swim at night time
think about being better you know people
didn't think i was human they thought i
came from outer space man from some
spacecraft and landed down here and just
formed goggins from the rocks and the
soul of the earth no that's not how it
is man so i said i'm gonna
i'm gonna share a secret with you all
when i talk to people
like i see where i'm at today
but i know where i come from
and it's kind of hard to almost separate
that i'm almost
not in a way i'm kissing my own ass
but i'm amazed at what a human being can
actually do so when i start talking to
myself in the third person is strictly
because i know that i literally made
this human being
out of uh
out of just like a whole bunch of scraps
and i wasn't you know i wasn't a a
mechanic i wasn't a carpenter so i
didn't know how to do anything
you know i wasn't trained in how to
build a human being from nothing you
know like my mom didn't train me my dad
didn't train me life didn't train me
well life broke training yeah life did
train me correction
and i started putting this scrap metal
together
like i wonder what's going to happen you
know the first year i try to do is off
and after a while i start learning more
and more and more through pain and stuff
i started learning just learning so much
about stuff
before i knew it man i built this
beautiful car i'm like how the [ __ ] did
i do that
and i knew how
i know how to do it because i have all
the tools
through all the failure i went through
trying to build this person who's
goggins i believe that most human beings
are only living at about 40 percent of
their capability
so
the mine has a governor like a car if
you're driving a car and the car has a
governor on it the car may say 130 miles
an hour but the governor set for 91.
once that governor sets in you get to 91
that car starts doing this the car wants
to go the car wants to go but that
factory said uh-uh we're not going past
91. we have a factory a nice governor in
our brain and it's a survival mechanism
it protects us from pain and suffering
the second we feel that our mind says oh
no this isn't fun
we should back off we should sit down
find something more comfortable and
there's something about the mind the
mind has the tactical advantage over you
at all times
at all times of your life
the mind has a tactical advantage over
you why is that it knows what you're
afraid of it knows your insecurities it
knows your deep dark lies
and it starts to push you away from that
it pushes you in a direction that is
comfortable
the mind controls everything so what i
realized was that when i was growing up
and i was 300 pounds and i got all fat
and i got all insecure
i realized that my mind kept taking me
in this direction when things got
uncomfortable for me when i was facing
my insecurities i was facing my fears my
mind said oh no we have the tactical
advantage we need to get you separate
you from this feeling this feeling over
your life's all about feelings we want
the happy feeling we don't want that
feeling of this sucks
why am i here and you don't have any so
so you can't answer those questions so
you leave
i started realizing that if in that
moment
you can answer those
questions
and you are now in charge of your brain
versus your brain ruling you
that's where all that stuff comes from
so so the 40 rule is all of that you get
to 40
your brain says we're done let's roll
man this is starting to get painful this
is uncomfortable so you sit down
you have to figure out ways and
everybody's different that's how the
book kind of talks about like we all
have these things about you know
five steps to this and four steps to
this it's it's a lot more than that
that's all
it's it's a practice that you have to
it's a habit
so if you know that at 40 i'm still you
know i'm feeling pain at 40 i'm feeling
pain that's where the 40 rule kicks in
now it starts okay i'm feeling pain my
mind's saying all to me is saying get
out of here run flee the fight or flight
kicks in okay we're done we're not good
enough it starts telling you all these
things you start to believe it because
the mind controls all
this is the time where you have to gain
control back of your mind
it's okay let me see if i can go 45
and once you start giving yourself more
and more hope and start realizing okay
the mind starts to be okay what are you
doing we're supposed to be going right
and you're going left
you start then controlling your mind
start finding more in you know in
yourself and it goes from 40 to a lot
further than that but that's the start
of it though get to get to the spot
where your mind is saying stop
wherever that is you gotta get there
first and then that's when that starts
to work for you you gotta control
yourself in that moment so i prioritize
trying to win the battle in the morning
so i always win the battle of morning so
i get morning time every morning i go
for a run
that's the first thing i do every
morning i haven't taken a day off of
running since
december 2016.
i've every day up in the morning so i
also stretch out
every day for about two to three hours
every day i've missed two days in about
five and a half six years
so
that's just my routine and about four
days a week i'm in the gym hitting the
weights
because you know you can't just be a
runner so this is every single day
the the monotony in my life
but this is what builds discipline
you know and not everybody i'm not
telling everybody to do this but this is
my lifestyle this is how i build
self-discipline you made this decision
to self-publish this book yes sir
right now it's at like number two or
number three on amazon on of all books
right right that just doesn't happen
with a self-published book well that's
been the story of my life
i uh
i see something that's that's quite off
quite not the same
and that's what i go for
this this book is exactly who i am as a
person exactly the way i did this book
is how i've done my almost my entire
life
is i see what is
not the norm
what's impossible with we know what all
the theorists say you shouldn't be doing
this
that's the wrong way to go and i'm like
hmm
let me see if i can pull this off it's
my junior year in high school
and i fell back a lot i fell back in
this whole of life the second you think
that you've overcome it you climbed
everest you're on that last hold
and life will say
not to
it'll push you down
and my junior year in high school i uh
missed a whole bunch of school
was lying to my mom had like a one point
something gpa i was just jacked up i
mean it was i was in
one of the worst spots in my life
and my mom was going with a lot of too
and she didn't have time to sit back and
baby me
and it was me against me
my pants were down to my knees i was
just i was not whatever was going on i
wasn't in a bad shape so i went to the
bathroom and i had this weird haircut
because i wanted attention
i was an attention getter i went to all
white school pretty much
um some of the kids like me a lot of
them didn't like me whatever didn't
matter i was looking for something so i
would dress differently crazy haircuts
and i went to the mirror
and
the reflection in it revealed
a lot of bad things
a lot of things that i was hiding behind
the saggy pants and i'm looking at
myself in the mirror going like god dawg
dude you gotta you are something else
man like you have created a character
i want to be the cool guy table
and whatever i could do to to get
attention i did
it wasn't me
it wasn't who i was inside but i was
scared for anybody to know who i was
inside
so in that accountability mirror i call
it i got real myself
i said
you have a third grade reading level
which is hard to admit when you're a
junior in high school that you copied on
every single thing you did because
of fear they're gonna put me in a
special school we all know what special
means i'm gonna have a title on myself
the rest of my life
and being cool you don't have a title on
yourself so i started cheating
i was dumb and people say oh you know
you're a learning disability out of
learning disability but i realized i was
lazy
so
um i called myself out there
i called myself out every which way
possible i didn't call myself i was just
honest
i was honest look at yourself man
look at yourself
and it was that day
in a couple of days after that i just
got real with myself and every day i
came home i called the accountability
mirror what am i going to do today to
change what i see in this mirror
what am i gonna do today a lot of it was
i stopped sitting with the cool guys
i actually tucked my shirt in went to
school looking like hey man this is how
i'm gonna look if you don't like it so
be it i had to really wear this this
this layer of skin
i had to develop a really callous skin
on me to take whatever you're going to
call me you're going to call me whatever
i'm going to be you know i want a geek
but whoever i am you're going to see me
you're going to see me for who i am
because i need to change who i'm not
and that accountability just became raw
and i became fat over the years i fell
back in a hole i called myself fat
because i was fat and people don't want
to do that
they want to say oh don't call yourself
fat don't call yourself dumb if you're
not real and wrong with who the [ __ ] you
are
nothing's going to change in this nice
new world that we live in we want to
hear
you're just a little big no man you
might be fat
and it's okay to hear that from yourself
and for maribel so that's where it
started at and it's raw it gets ugly
sometimes with me in that mirror
but i'm also proud of myself to be able
to tell myself that and then fix what's
in that mirror well i was praying for
cockroaches when i got out of the air
force i sprayed for cockroaches i was
about 297 to be exact
and i saw this discovery channel show on
tv
and i was like and that discovery
challenge show was just guys going
through hell week
and i saw these guys freezing a lot of
water
and i was like you know what it brought
back memories of me going through pear
rescue training so at 297 pounds i
decided to uh
try to be a navy seal
and to make a long story short i had to
lose 106 pounds in less than three
months
and that's where it became challenging
for me
so i knew to lose 106 pounds in less
than three months
you're looking at 3 500 calories is a
pound
so i was basically doing a whole bunch
of math in my head so i knew if i were
to stop and be stagnant there was no
calories being burned
so i i was basically trained all day
long
so that's how i went and before i knew
it
i lost the weight well it's that time of
year again we start to feel real happy
why because we're we're not going to
work if you believe in santa claus and
you celebrate christmas you're looking
forward to santa claus coming on the
chimney giving you some presents it's a
real good time of year so in a good time
of year we start to feel real good about
ourselves so i start to feel great so we
start making promises to ourselves about
hey i'm going to lose some weight i want
to do better in school i'm going to be
better here be better there but guess
what happens the real merry christmas
happens when all of that noise is gone
it's quiet
and it's you against you and now all
those endorphins are gone and i promise
you made by getting up early and getting
after it to go lose weight study harder
guess what
it's a lot harder now that repetition
becomes a lot harder now so a lot of us
can't do things on our own so find
somebody in your life so when you throw
that towel in
they throw that
back at you and say you're not [ __ ]
done yet
stay true to yourself stay hard
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and how are you going to take action on
it this week when you schedule in what
day what time and what place you're
going to take action you have a 91
chance of actually following through
versus just a 35 chance if you just got
motivated but never created a specific
plan and when you share your plan
publicly and have some accountability
you increase your chances even further
of actually following through so i want
to know your single biggest takeaway and
your plan of action this week in the
comments so i can celebrate you
how do i gain more confidence it starts
with yourself man you got to start
diving into those things that you are
afraid of
you don't gain confidence by going to
the spot that makes you feel good
it could be a false reality
and the second life gives you that
challenge
all you want to do is go back to what
makes you confidence or or or what gave
you confidence is that happy spot
no
what gives you confidence what gave me
confidence was spending years at a
kitchen table
trying to learn how to read and write on
my own
realizing i can't learn the way you
learn
i can't
but i can learn what gives you
confidence not being afraid
it's overcoming the fear
isis stutters severely bad so right now
i don't know how many people are going
to watch this you know what gives me
confidence is knowing i no longer care
if i see or start stuttering to you yeah
that's what gives me confidence is
facing these things overcoming them and
maybe not overcoming them every day
but facing them
and facing their face and preaching like
this you know what man this is where
it's at
it's not in that comfort zone
it's in the discomfort zone is where my
confidence is getting built mm-hmm
that's where it's getting built
but people want to and they want an
easier answer yeah there has to be an
easier way
it's not i'm sorry i searched for it my
entire life
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check out my
training right here below or if you want
some awesome motivation from mel robbins
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy them continue to
believe and i'll see you there